>> IT IS A BEAUTIFUL AFTERNOON
IN MILWAUKEE, WISCONSIN.
FLOCKING TO THE FIELD.
THE CARDINALS THE BREWERS.
ADD TRYING TO CLENCH THE N.L.
CENTRAL.
THE RED-HOT CARDINALS HAD HAD
SOMETHING TO SAY ABOUT THAT.
PART OF AN INCREDIBLE RUN.
LOOKING TO MAKE IT 12 IN A ROW.
IT IS AN N.L. CENTRAL MATCHUP.
PREGAME SHOW, PRESENTED BY JIM
BEAM.
WE ARE HERE WITH YOU AT STUDIO
42.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
WE ARE HEADED FOR THE
POSTSEASON.
WE HAVE ADAM WAINWRIGHT ON THE
MOUND.
HE HAS BEEN FANTASTIC.
ONE STRIKEOUT AWAY FROM 2000.
HE IS DOING THIS AT 40 YEARS
OLD.
I AM GOING TO ASK HIM ABOUT IT.
>> IT IS PROBABLY A LOT OF KALE
AND WIND SPRINTS.
WE WILL FIND OUT.
>> WILL TAKE YOU BACK TO LAST
NIGHT'S GAME.
>> TYLER O'NEILL JUMPS ON IT.
DEEP LEFT.
THEY STRIKE IN THE FIRST AGAIN.
ARENADO IS GIVING CHASE.
ARENADO WENT OVER THE TARP WITH
A BASKET CLUTCH FROM NOLAN.
HITTING IT OUT TO DEEP LEFT.
IT IS 10-TO ST. LOUIS.
>> THE LONGEST WINNING STREAK IN
THE LAST 40 SEASONS AGAINST THE
BREWERS.
THEY HAVE ONLY HAD A WINNING
STREAK THREE SEPARATE TIMES.
IN 1943, THEY LOST THE WORLD
SERIES TO THE YANKEES AND WHEN
THEY WON 14 STRAIGHT, THAT CAME
IN 1935 -- 1945.
CURRENTLY IN SECOND PLACE,
CARDINALS.
IT IS DOWN TO THREE.
THE CARDS HAVE OPENED UP.
WITH 11 DAYS LEFT, THINGS ARE
GETTING REAL.
SARAH, IT IS ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE
YOU.
WE MIGHT AS WELL START WITH THE
HOTTEST TEAM IN BASEBALL, THE
ST. LOUIS CARDINALS.
>> THE CARDINALS THE WIND
STREAKS AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
THE PLAYOFF ODDS ARE NOWHERE
NEAR WHERE THEY WERE, EVEN
EARLIER THIS MONTH.
YOU CAN SEE A CHART OF WHERE
THEY HAVE AN ALL SEASON.
THERE IS JUST SHOOTS UP OVER THE
LAST FEW WEEKS OR SO.
IT HAS BEEN COOL TO SEE.
GOING FOR WIN NUMBER 12, LAST
TIME THEY DID THIS, THEY WON THE
WORLD SERIES.
>> THE PERFORMANCE OF THE
40-YEAR-OLD ADAM WAINWRIGHT HAS
BEEN SURPRISING.
HE IS PITCHING INCREDIBLY.
HE WILL LIKELY GO OVER 200
INNINGS FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
YEARS.
YOU NOTICED A UNIQUE WAY THAT HE
IS GETTING HITTERS OUT.
>> ONE THING HAS BEEN REALLY
GOOD AT IS GETTING CONSTRUCTS.
65, THIRD MOST IN THE MAJORS.
WE CAN MENTION MOLINA THERE.
THERE IS HELP FROM THE CATCHER.
HE ACTUALLY -- I WONDER IF IT IS
JUST THAT REPORTED THAT HE HAS
WITH HIM.
IT'S JUST -- IT JUST TELLS YOU
THAT IT IS SOMETHING ELSE THAT
HE IS DOING.
>> THAT IS A PACKAGE DEAL THERE.
WE WERE SAYING THAT THE MAGIC
NUMBER IS DOWN TO THREE.
WE HEARD ALL THE NAMES.
CHRISTIAN YELICH.
IT HAS BEEN A GUY WHERE SOME
HAVE WONDERED IF THERE WAS A
SPOT FOR HIM.
THAT IS OUR FRIEND.
QUITE SEE HAS BEEN SO GOOD FOR
HIM.
-- FOR THEM.
WE REALLY SAW I EARLIER FROM
HIM.
THE 90TH PERCENTILE IN BOTH.
THIS IS BURIAL PERCENTAGE.
BARRELS ARE BASICALLY YOUR IDEAL
CONTACT.
THE IDEAL COMBINATION.
YOU CAN SEE THAT HE IS ON A
LIST, ALONG WITH SOMEONE ELSE
PLAYING THE GAME TODAY.
THE LARGEST INCREASES IN BARREL
RATE.
IT IS REALLY WHAT HE HAS BEEN
DOING DIFFERENTLY.
HE HAS ALWAYS BEEN A GOOD HITTER
BUT HE IS CRUSHING THE BALL THIS
YEAR.
WITH CHRISTIAN YELICH, NOT QUITE
GETTING THAT BACK GOING JUST
YET.
>> I HOPEFULLY -- HOPEFULLY THEY
CAN GET CHRISTIAN YELICH GOING.
ASIDE FROM THE EXCELLENT
STARTING STAFF, THE BREWERS HAVE
A DOMINANT BACKEND OF THE
BULLPEN THAT COULD BE TOUGH COME
OCTOBER.
>> THEY HAVE TWO OF THE TOP
THREE RELIEVER IS IN TERMS.
-- THREE RELIEVERS.
THAT IS WHAT YOU WANT TO SEE
HERE.
HE WENT TO SEE THOSE STRIKEOUTS.
THE MOST DEFINITIVE WAY TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU ARE HITTING IN THE
GAME.
THEY ARE THE ONLY BULLPEN WITH
TWO OF THESE GUYS.
WE TALKED SO MUCH ABOUT THE
STARTING ROTATION THIS YEAR.
IT HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY DOMINANT,
BUT WE HAVE NOT TALKED ABOUT HOW
OUTSTANDING THIS BULLPEN IS.
DEVIN WILLIAMS, OF COURSE IT WAS
GOING TO GO UP A LITTLE BIT, BUT
HE HAS STILL BEEN OUTSTANDING.
HE HAS BEEN SUCH A RELIABLE
PIECE IN THIS PEN.
IT IS GREAT TO SEE.
THEY HAVE A COMPLETE PITCHING
STAFF.
>> EVERYBODY KNOWS HOW GOOD JOSH
HADER IS, BUT DEVIN WILLIAMS IS
NOT SURPRISING ANYONE ANYMORE,
LIKE HE DID LAST YEAR.
THANK YOU, SARAH.
THAT WILL TAKE US TO OUR POLL
QUESTION.
WHO WILL WIN TODAY'S GAME, THE
CARDINALS OR THE BREWERS?
PLEASE GO ONLINE AND VOTE.
WE WILL HAVE THE RESULTS LATER
IN THE SHOW.
WE WILL ALSO TALK TO TYLER
O'NEILL, WHOSE FAMILY PEDIGREE
MAY SURPRISE YOU.WILL THE CARDIR
WINNING STREAK?
STAY WITH US.
>> GOT HIM.
STRIKES OUT THE SIDE.
>> STRIKES OUT THIS MADE.
[INDISCERNIBLE]
7-0.
>> O'NEILL WITH THE DRIVE.
INTO DEEP CENTER AND GONE.
TYLER O'NEILL IN NEW YORK.
IN -- IT IS A TWO RUN SHOT.
>> WHAT A GREAT MOMENT.
OUT TO DEEP CENTER.
GRAND SLAM FOR THE ROOKIE.
WHAT A MOMENT.
HITTING IT OUT TO DEEP RIGHT.
HE ROBS ALONSO.
♪
>> WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB GAME
OF THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW.
PRESENTED BY JIM BEAM.
ONE OF THE CARDINAL'S BEST
HITTERS IS TYLER O'NEILL.
THE OUTFIELDER IS SITTING OVER
320 -- .320.
ONE OF THE REASON WHY ST. LOUIS
IS NEARING A RECORD YEAR.
JUST NEED THE CHEVY PLAYER OF
THE WEEK, TYLER.
>> THINKING.
IT IS MUCH APPRECIATED.
HOW -- THANK YOU.
IT IS A GOOD FEELING.
A PLAY OF THE WEEK IS PLAY OF
THE WEEK.
I'M JUST TRYING TO DO MY JOB.
KEEPING THINGS SIMPLE.
>> ONE HAS BEEN WORKING SO WELL
FOR YOU, ESPECIALLY -- IT IS
PRETTY GOOD COMPANY TO KEEP.
>> OBVIOUSLY, THEY ARE SUCH GOOD
HITTERS.
TO BE THE GUY HITTING IN BETWEEN
THEM, THINGS LIKE THAT --
>> YOU LOOK PRETTY RIPPED
YOURSELF.
WHO WINS IN AN ARM WRESTLING
COMPETITION?
>> I THINK TERRIE STILL HAS THAT
OLD MAN STRENGTH.
CLOSE ARE YOU GOING TO GO DOWN?
--
>> ARGUES THE ARTISTIC THE
HOMETOWN SIDE.
--
>> IT HAS BEEN EXHILARATING.
>> IT IS A FUN TIME, FOR SURE.
>> WHAT IS YOUR FAVORITE
BALLPARK TO HIT IN?
>> I HAD TO SAY BUSH.
-- HAVE TO SAY BUSH.
IT IS LIKE HITTING AT AMERICAN
FAMILY FIELD.
ANYWAY THAT MAKES THE BALL A
LITTLE EASIER TO SEE.
>> HOPEFULLY YOU ARE FEELING
GOOD ABOUT SAN FRANCISCO OR
L.A..
ALL THIS TALK ABOUT WHAT YOU
HAVE DONE AT THE PLATE.
YOU HAVE TURNED INTO BED -- ONE
OF THE BEST LEFT FIELDERS IN THE
GAME.
CHRIST JUST COMING DOWN TO THE
BASIC FUNDAMENTALS, JUST THE
FOOTWORK.
MAKING THE RIGHT PLAY, WHEN YOU
HAVE TO.
LEARNING THE GAME.
>> TO OFFENSIVE OR HE, YOU HAVE
BEEN HITTING GREAT.
-- YOU HAVE BEEN HITTING GREAT.
HOW HAVE YOU MADE JUMPS
OFFENSIVELY.
-- OFFENSIVELY?
>> LAST YEAR WAS A BIT OF A
CRAZY YEAR.
THE BEGINNING TO BECOME THE
PLAYER -- IT WAS A BIG LEARNING
CURVE THIS YEAR.
JUST HAVE A LOT OF
RESPONSIBILITY.
YOU WANT TO HOLD UP YOUR END OF
THE BARGAIN FOR THE BOYS.
JUST EXCITED TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
>> I WOULD BE REMISS IF I DID
NOT ASK YOU WHAT IS GOING ON
WITH THE TATTOOS.
>> MY FIRST ONE, I DO NOT KNOW
IF YOU CAN SEE IT, IT IS THAT
MAPLE LEAF.
THAT IS THE ROOM OF MY BEDROOM
WINDOW, LOOKING AT THE SUNRISE.
IT HAS SOME WRENCHES LEADING
BACK TO HOME AND A QUOTE
UNDERNEATH.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT I HAVE
LIVED BY FOR A LONG TIME EVER
SINCE I GOT SERIOUS ABOUT
SPORTS.
IT IS ALL A PIECE OF ME.
IT IS NOT COMPLETE YET.
A WORK IN PROGRESS.
>> JUST LIKE YOU.
I LOVE THAT.
I LIKE THE DRAGONS AND THE
TIGERS LIKE FIGHTING EACH OTHER.
CLOSE WE LOVE IT.
YOU WENT FROM 5% ODDS TO AROUND
95%.
BASICALLY A LOCK FOR THE
POSTSEASON.
WHAT HAS IT BEEN LIKE IN THE
CLUBHOUSE DURING THIS STRETCH?
>> WE ALWAYS BELIEVE IN
OURSELVES.
WE ALWAYS HAVE THAT ABILITY.
LATELY, WE HAVE BEEN HITTING
GREAT.
WE ARE KEEPING RUNS OFF THE
BOARD AND PUTTING OUR OWN RUNS
ON THE BOARD.
>> WHO WOULD HAVE THOUGHT?
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
GOOD LUCK OUT THERE TODAY.
>> THANK YOU.
CLOSE WE ALL KNOW WHAT THAT
SILKY JAZZ MEANS.
BOBBY CROSBY THE CREATOR OF THE
CHANNEL DODGER FILMS.
WHAT IS UP?
WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
YOU ARE WILDLY POPULAR WITH OVER
ONE MILLION SUBSCRIBERS.
TELL US ABOUT WHAT KIND OF
CONTENT YOU PUT OUT ON YOUR
CHANNEL AND WHAT WE CAN EXPECT
TO SEE.
>> THE CHANNEL IS MOSTLY JUST ME
PLAYING MLB GAMES COME AWAY I
PLAY SOFTBALL WITH A BIG GROUP
OF FRIENDS, AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
FUN PLAYING SOFTBALL.
A LOT OF PEOPLE LIKE TO WATCH
IT.
>> LOOK AT THOSE GUYS OUT ON THE
FIELD.
>> I AM A DODGER FAN, BUT I
PLAYED AS A GIANT.
>> I DO NOT THINK ANYBODY ON THE
GIANTS IS ACTUALLY 6'10".
IF THE SEASON ENDED TODAY, THEY
WOULD BOTH BE IN THE POSTSEASON.
DO YOU THINK THE CARDINALS HAVE
WHAT IT TAKES?
>> THE CARDINALS HAVE A HISTORY
OF EATING THE DODGERS IN THE
POSTSEASON.
ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN.
I HOPE THAT SOMEHOW THE DODGERS
CAN ECLIPSE AND HAVE A
TIEBREAKER.
>> AS A ROCKIES FAN, I HAD TO
EXPERIENCE THAT A FEW YEARS AGO.
IT WAS NOT GOOD AGAINST
MILWAUKEE.
SPEAKING OF MILWAUKEE, THEY HAVE
THE MOST FEARED BULLPEN.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT
STATEMENT?
>> PROBABLY.
I THINK THE GIANTS AND THE RAYS
HAVE THE BEST NUMBERS, BUT
WILLIAMS AND HADER, I WOULD NOT
WANT TO STEP IN THE BOX AGAINST
EITHER OF THOSE GUYS.
THE BREWERS ARE VERY SCARY.
>> WE KNOW YOU ARE A DODGERS
FAN.
WHO DO YOU THINK POSES THE
BIGGEST THREAT TO THE DODGERS
THIS SEASON?
>> I HAD TO SAY THE GIANTS.
THE DODGERS ARE RIGHT BEHIND
THEM.
IT WOULD BE A VERY SCARY SERIES.
WE WILL ADVANCE AND I THINK THAT
WE WILL ADVANCE.
I ALWAYS SAY THAT THE DODGERS
WILL WIN AT ALL, BUT I AM NOT
TOO SCARED BUT THE GIANTS ARE
THE BIGGEST THREAT.
>> I FEEL LIKE YOU STARTED
BEFORE THE INTERVIEW BEGAN, BUT
THIS IS A MATCH MADE IN HEAVEN.
>> BEFORE WE LET YOU GO, GO
AHEAD AND GIVE US YOUR WORLD
SERIES PREDICTION.
YOU THINK WILL END UP WINNING?
>> DODGERS IN SIX, OVER THE
RAYS.
HOPEFULLY I WILL BE THERE AGAIN
FOR BACK-TO-BACK WORLD SERIES
TITLES FOR THE DODGERS.
>> I LIKE IT.
YOU ARE VERY SPECIFIC WITH THE
PREDICTION.
WE WILL BE SURE TO CHECK OUT
YOUR CHANNEL.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> I LIKE THIS GUY, HEIDI'S NEW
BFF.
LEAVING THE GAME WITH LOWER BACK
IT WAS
BECAUSE HE MADE AN AMAZING
CATCH.
NOLAN ARENADO MAY BE
INSTRUMENTAL IN ACCOMPLISHING
THIS.
♪
>> FASTBALL TO WRITE.
GET UP.
GET OUT OF HERE, GONE.
HE RIPPED IT OUT OF HERE.
A SWING AND A DRIVE.
GO ON, GET OUT OF HERE.
TO LEFT AND DEEP.
GET OUT OF HERE.
GO ON.
AND THE BREWERS HAVE THE LEAD.
>> A CHANCE TO PUT THE BREWERS
ON TOP IN THE EIGHTH.
>> AWAY AS WILL SCORE.
-- REYES WILL SCORE.
>> THIS IS TROUBLE.
>> WHAT A GRAB BY LORENZO CAIN.
NOW IT IS WHERE A BASE HIT COULD
CHANGE THE GAME.
THIS ONE IS OVER.
♪
>> WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB GAME
OF THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW
PRESENTED BY JIM BEAM.
>> TIME FOR PICKS TO CLICK.
ADAM WAINWRIGHT HAS BEEN
FANTASTIC FOR THE CARDINALS.
SHOULD HE BE IN THE CY YOUNG
CONSIDERATION?
HE IS NOT EVEN ON THE BOARD IN
VEGAS.
>> WHAT HE IS DOING IS
IMPRESSIVE, BUT LOOK AT WHAT IS
GOING ON IN L.A.
ZACK WHEELER IS COMING OFF OF AN
AMAZING START.
LET'S NOT FORGET WHO THEY ARE
PLAYING TODAY.
THAT ROTATION IS INSANE.
IT IS NOT EVEN A SOFT NO.
IT IS A HARD NO.
WHAT ABOUT YOU?
>> I'M GOING TO GO YES.
HE SHOULD BE ON THE BOARD AT
LEAST.
91 WITH -- 9-1.
THE CARDINALS HAVE WON 11 OF 12.
IF THAT DOES NOT PUT YOU IN THE
CONVERSATION -- I'M SAYING HE
SHOULD BE IN THE CONVERSATION.
I AM WEARING THIS BOSTON RED SOX
YELLOW BECAUSE IT IS WORKING FOR
THE RED SOX.
THEY ARE GOING TO KEEP WEARING
THE OTHER JERSEYS UNTIL THEY
LOSE A GAME.
>> I THINK YOU ARE ONTO
SOMETHING.
WE ARE SO SUPERSTITIOUS.
I'M WEARING MY PIZZA SHOES.
IF YOU WANT TO TALK RIDICULOUS
--
>> WHO IS YOUR SLEEPER PICK TO
WIN THE WORLD SERIES?
>> I AM GOING WITH TORONTO.
THESE KIDS ARE A LOT OF FUN.
WE KNOW WHAT WE ARE DOING AT THE
PLATE, BUT LET'S LOOK AT WHAT WE
ARE DOING AT THE PLATE.
THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE A GUY BY
THE NAME OF ROBBIE RAY.
TALK ABOUT A CY YOUNG CANDIDATE.
ONE OF THE BEST ROOKIE PITCHERS
IN THE GAME.
I COULD SEE THEM MAKING A RUN.
THAT IS MY SNEAKY PICK.
>> I LIKE YOUR DEDICATION TO
YOUR PICK.
I LIKE TORONTO IN THE WORLD
SERIES AND I LIKE THEM FACING
THE SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS.
A NICE LITTLE CENTRAL VALLEY.
MY TEAM WAS THE SAN FRANCISCO
GIANTS, GROWING UP.
THAT IS WHEN THEY DO THEIR BEST
WORK.
THEY HAVE BEEN THE BEST TEAM IN
BASEBALL THIS YEAR.
THE DODGERS HAVE BEEN ON SUCH A
TEAR LATELY.
IT IS NOT FAIR.
BUT YET, THE DODGERS HAVE BEEN
ON A GREAT RUN.
I HAVE GIANTS AND YOU HAVE BLUE
JAYS.
>> I AM HERE FOR IT.
>> NUMBER THREE PICK TO CLICK,
EIGHT ROUNDS --
WHAT HAVE YOU GOT?
>> I'M GOING TO TAKE THE UNDER.
I THINK IT IS 1.81 E.R.A. OVER
THE PAST MONTH OR SO.
IN THE OPPOSITE DUGOUT, THEY
WILL HAVE A GUY BY THE NAME OF
ADRIAN HOUSER.
HIS LAST GAME AGAINST THESE GUYS
WAS A SHUTOUT.
ALSO, WE KNOW THAT THESE
AFTERNOON GAMES, WE ARE TRAINED
-- TRAINING TO MAKE UP, BUT I DO
NOT FEEL LIKE ANYBODY WILL BE
FIRING ON ALL CYLINDERS.
>> MILWAUKEE IS A GOOD HITTERS
PARK, BUT ADRIAN HOUSER AND ADAM
WAINWRIGHT, YOU CANNOT COUNT IT
AGAINST THEM WITH HOW GOOD THEY
HAVE BEEN LATELY.
I AM TAKING THE UNDER AS WELL.
LET'S GET TO OUR POLL QUESTION,
WHO IS GOING TO WIN THE GAME?
EVERYBODY IS VOTING FOR THEIR
TEAM AND IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
MORE CARDINALS FANS.
THEY LIKE ST. LOUIS OVER THE
BREWERS.
THE BREWERS MAGIC NUMBER IS
THREE.
IF THEY WIN TODAY, THEY WIN
TOMORROW, THEY HAVE LOCKED UP
THE DIVISION, BUT YOU GUYS HAVE
THE CARDINALS WINNING 70%.
>> THAT BALL IS ABSOLUTELY
CRUSHED.
LUIS ROBERT MAKES IT A 2-0 SOX
LEAD.
1-2.
THAT BALL IS ANNIHILATED.
AND ANOTHER CHANCE TO BRING IT
HOME.
3-0 SOX.
IN THE AIR AGAIN, RIGHT FIELD.
AT THE TRACK, HE DID IT AGAIN.
ANDERSON IS WANTING TO IT -- DO
IT ALL ON HIS LONESOME.
>> IF ANYBODY IS GOING TO DO IT
ON THEIR OWN.
THAT IS A FOOTBALL SCORE RIGHT
THERE.
7-0 AND THIS COULD BE IT FOR THE
CHICAGO WHITE SOX.
IT LOOKS LIKE THEY ARE WELL ON
THEIR WAY TO SECURING THAT A.L.
CENTRAL DIVISION TITLE.
CLOSE IT HAS BEEN ON CRUISE
CONTROL, BUT THEY MIGHT BE
POPPING THE BUBBLY IN CLEVELAND.
MAYBE THEY ARE HAVING A NICE
ROUND OF JIM BEAM.
>> I DO NOT THINK IT WOULD STING
AS BADLY AS CHAMPAGNE IN THE
EYES.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT ADRIAN
HOUSER.
IT IS THE BREW CREW AND THE
CARDS.
THE CARDS ARE LOOKING FOR THE
SWEEP.
WE WILL GET YOU OUT TO AMERICAN
FAMILY FIELD.
SCOTT BRAUN, TOM VERDUCCI ON THE
CALL.
>> HERE IS THE PITCH.
>> DRIVES IT DEEP.
>> WHAT A PLAY.
>> ARE YOU KICKING ME?
--KIDDING ME?
>> MID BOSS -- MIDWEST BASEBALL.
A POWER PITCHING TEAM ALONG WITH
THE HOTTEST BALLCLUB IN THE
SPORT.
THAT TALENT IS ON A GLOBAL
STAGE.
LIVE ON YOUTUBE, PRESENTED BY
JIM BEAM.
CONCLUDING A FOUR GAME OR AT
FAMILY FIELD IN WISCONSIN.
THE STANDINGS LOOK LIKE THEY ARE
FORMING INTO A PLAYOFF.
WE STILL HAVE THE DIVISIONS.
EITHER THE GIANTS OR THE DODGERS
WITH THE FLYING CARDINALS, THE
SECOND WILD-CARD SEAT IS THEIRS.
THE BREWERS ARE SITTING ON A
MAGIC NUMBER TO WEAR THAT CROWN.
SCOTT BRAUN ALONGSIDE TOM
VERDUCCI.
THE CARDINALS WON 11 GAMES IN
ROW.
DID ANYBODY SEE THIS COMING?
TOM: THERE IS HOT AND THEN THERE
IS HOT AT THE RIGHT TIME.
HE CLENCHED THE NUMBERS ON THIS.
A PLAYOFF POSSIBILITY.
THINGS ARE NOT LOOKING GOOD AT
ALL.
TALK ABOUT TURNING THINGS AROUND
IN A HURRY.
HOW ABOUT LATELY, 11 WINS IN A
ROW.
THE FIRST CARDINALS TEAM IN
HISTORY TO WIN 11 STRAIGHT IN
SEPTEMBER.
THIS REMINDS ME OF THE 2007
ROCKIES THAT MARCHED TO THE
POSTSEASON.
THE CARDINALS ARE THE HOTTEST
TEAM IN BASEBALL LOOKING REALLY
GOOD AND THE WILD-CARD
STANDINGS.
>> THIS WAS NOT LONG AGO.
SEPTEMBER -- SEPTEMBER 2, THEY
WERE AN AFTERTHOUGHT.
A BIG THREE ON OFFENSE.
>> THE GUY WHO IS HITTING NUMBER
THREE.
I BELIEVE HE IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPROVED PLAYERS IN ALL OF
BASEBALL.
HE HAS RAISED 109 POINTS.
THAT IS THE BIGGEST INCREASE.
IN SEPTEMBER, IT IS ALL COMING
TOGETHER.
MY GOODNESS, EQUALITY
OUTFIELDER.
LOOK AT THE STATCAST NUMBERS.
TALK ABOUT HITTING THE BALL
HARD.
TYLER O'NEILL IS ONE OF THE GUYS
WHO HAS THE HARDEST BAT IN THE
LINEUP.
>> THE EXIT VELOCITY HAS
INCREASED.
HE IS A STRONG DUDE AND IT IS
SHOWING.
FOR THE BREWERS, THEY ARE STILL
IN CONTROL.
THEY LOST FOUR GAMES IN A ROW.
BRANDON WOODRUFF, FREDDY PERALTA
-- YOU ARE LOOKING AT THE LOWEST
STARTER E.R.A. IN THE FRANCHISE
HISTORY.
THEY WILL TELL YOU THIS MIGHT BE
ONE OF THE BEST TEAMS EVER --
MIGHT NOT BE ONE OF THE BEST
TEAMS, BUT IT IS THE BEST
PITCHING STAFF.
IT IS NOT JUST A BIG REACTION.
ERIC HAS BEEN OUTSTANDING FOR
THEM.
SO IS THE MAN ON THE MOUND THIS
AFTERNOON.
IT IS EFFECTIVE.
>> YOU SEE HIS NUMBERS.
CHECK OUT THAT BOTTOM LINE.
23 OUNCE ON THE SINKER.
SHE WILL POUND THAT.
HE WILL ALSO BACKDOOR IT.
HE CONTROLS BOTH SIDES OF THE
PLATE.
TAKE A LOOK INSIDE THIS START.
POWERED BY GOOGLE CLOUD.
A BEVY OF SINKERS.
71 OF THOSE SINKERS.
IT IS SO GOOD THAT YOU KNOW THAT
IT IS COMING BUT IT IS GIVE UP
ON IT BECAUSE IT HAS SO MUCH
MOVEMENT.
JUST AS EFFECTIVE IN A DIFFERENT
WAY.
>> BOTH TEAMS REALLY PICKING IT
ON DEFENSE.
IT WILL NOT BE EASY FOR THE
BREWERS TO WIPE AWAY THAT TASTE.
A BREWERS TEAM THAT HAS SEEN A
LOT OF MOLINA.
WE HAVE MUCH MORE.
>> THE YOUTUBE AUDIENCE WILL
WITNESS SOMETHING THAT CARDINALS
FANS HAVE SEEN MORE THAN 300
TIMES.
THIS RELATIONSHIP GOES ALL THE
WAY BACK TO 2007.
HERE IS WHERE IT RANKS.
MORE THAN 320 TIMES.
OBVIOUSLY, THEY HAVE HAD GREAT
SUCCESS TOGETHER.
ADAM WAINWRIGHT HAS REINVENTED
HIMSELF OVER THE LAST THREE
YEARS.
ALMOST ONE RUN AGAIN BETTER THAN
WITH ANY OTHER CATCHER.
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF SUCCESS.
IF THIS RELATIONSHIP CONTINUES,
ONE NUMBER TO WATCH WILL BE THE
15TH TIME THAT THERE HAS BEEN A
BATTERY FOR A POST SEASON
CARDINALS GAME.
WE WILL COME BACK WITH OUR
STARTING LINEUPS IN MILWAUKEE.
THE BREWERS AND THE CARDINALS.
♪
>> UP THE MIDDLE, BASE HIT.
2-0 ST. LOUIS.
DRIVING IN HIS 83RD.
>> LEFT FIELD AT THE WALL, GONE.
HOME RUN NUMBER 25.
>> THE PITCH IS GROUNDED TO THE
RIGHT SIDE.
A RUNDOWN BETWEEN THIRD AND
HOME.
THEY TAGGED HIM OUT.
A DOUBLE PLAY.
>> THE 1-1 OUT TO LEFT.
IT IS OFF THE WALL.
A DOUBLE FOR PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT.
AT THE WALL, GONE.
PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT, HOME RUN
NUMBER 26.
HITTING IT THE OTHER WAY.
HERE COMES TOMMY EDMAN TO SCORE.
>> HERE COMES TOMMY EDMAN.
HE WILL SCORE 1-0.
>> THIS IS THE MLB GAME OF THE
WEEK, PRESENTED BY JIM BEAM.
SCOTT BRAUN, TOM VERDUCCI AND
BRETT DOLAN.
THE CARDINALS TAKING ON THE
BREWERS.
YOUTUBE.COM/,, LOADED WITH
UNIQUE FEATURES, DUGOUT
INTERVIEWS, PLAYER OF THE GAME
TROPHY AND IT PUTS THE AUDIO IN
YOUR HANDS.
YOU CAN HEAR THE RADIO CALL.
WE WILL RUN THROUGH A
STEP-BY-STEP TUTORIAL, COMING UP
, IF YOU ARE NEW TO THE PARTY.
MIKE SHILDT, SMILING MORE THAN
HE WAS WHEN YOU WORRY CHATTING
WITH HIM EARLIER TODAY.
HIS TEAM HAS WON 11 IN A ROW.
SITTING PRETTY IN THAT SECOND
WILD-CARD SEAT, MATCHING UP
AGAINST ADRIAN HOUSER.
28 YEARS OLD.
HIS E.R.A. IN THE 3.5 RANGE.
YOU BETTER HAVE THE DEFENSE
BEHIND YOU, QUITE ALERT THIS
AFTERNOON.
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT ONE OF
THE BEST SINKERS IN THE GAME.
MID 90'S WITH TREMENDOUS
MOVEMENT.
>> YOU CAN SEE HIS NUMBERS
AGAINST ST. LOUIS THIS SEASON.
THAT INCLUDES THREE WEEKS AGO.
THE FIRST COMPLETE SHUT OUT
2014.
WHAT IS ADRIAN HOUSER ALL ABOUT?
TOM: HE DOES THROW THE PITCHES,
BUT HE COULD BEAT YOU WITH THAT
ONE PITCH.
NORMALLY YOU THINK ABOUT SWINGS
AND MISSES TO FOLLOW HOW
EFFECTIVE A PITCHER IS.
KEEP AN EYE ON HOW MANY CALLED
STRIKE'S.
THERE IS SUPER MOVEMENT ON THAT
SINKER.
14 INNINGS AGAINST ST. LOUIS
THIS YEAR.
NO EARNED RUNS ALLOWED.
>> THIRD TRY FOR THAT LINEUP.
IT IS GOING TO START WITH TOMMY
EDMAN, THEIR LEADOFF MAN.
ALL THE REGULATORS ARE IN THEIR.
THE SWITCHHITTING EDMUND IS
FOLLOWED BY GOLDSCHMIDT, HITTING
350 -- .350.
TYLER O'NEILL IS IN A GOOD
POSITION.
MOLINA IS BACK IN THERE TODAY.
HARRISON BADER IS OUT THERE AND
ADAM WAINWRIGHT IS ON THE MOUND
TODAY FOR THE CARDINALS.
THE ROOF IS CLOSED.
THERE IS RAIN EXPECTED IN THE
FORECAST.
A LITTLE BREEZE WHEN WE ARE
HEADED IN, LOW 60'S.
EDMUND BEST --
WE ARE UNDERWAY ON YOUTUBE.
HAUSER MISSES, LOW.
GOING FOR A 12 CONSECUTIVE W.
FOULED OFF TO THE RIGHT SIDE.
TOM: WHEN YOU PUT TOGETHER A WIN
STREAK AT THIS TIME OF THE YEAR,
GETTING INTO OCTOBER, THAT
COUNTS FOR A LOT.
THE FIRST TEAM IN CARDINALS
HISTORY TO HAVE A WIN STREAK IN
SEPTEMBER.
SCOTT: THEY ARE 15-6 THIS MONTH.
THEY ARE ONE AWAY FROM A 12 GAME
OR THAT THEY PUT TOGETHER IN
1982.
11 AND COUNTING.
>> THIS IS WHERE HAUSER LIKES TO
GO BACKDOOR.
SCOTT: HE GOT HIM IN ON THE
HANDS.
THERE IS CAIN TO PUT AWAY
EDMUND.
CLASE DIFFERENT APPROACH BY THE
CARDINALS.
NOT SHUTOUT, HE HAD 31 CALLED
STRIKES, TIED FOR THE MOST.
HERE IS HIS ARSENAL.
THE CURVEBALL COME EASY
ESPECIALLY FOR LEFT-HANDED
HITTERS.
YOU DO HAVE TO HONOR THAT.
A GOAL AGAIN -- A BALL AGAINST
GOLDSCHMIDT THERE.
SCOTT: HE DID SOME DAMAGE
YESTERDAY.
433 FEET ON A TWO RUN BLAST.
THAT IS A LONG WAYS.
HE IS A FAN OF THIS BALLPARK,
FOR YEARS.
THERE IT IS.
RIGHT IN THE FRONT ROW.
WENT TO GRAB A BEER.
THIS TIME, TURNS ON ONE.
OUT NUMBER TWO.
GOLD GLOVER'S THE FIELD.
CHRISTIAN YELICH WON THE AWARD
AND WE WILL SHOW YOU IN THE NEXT
HALF INNING.
HERE IS THE BIG MAN.
TYLER O'NEILL HAVING QUITE THE
MONTH, ALSO THE PLAYER OF THE
WEEK WINNING THE AWARD FOR THE
FIRST TIME BUT THEY SINKER FROM
HAUSER.
HOW DO YOU PITCH THIS GUY
LATELY?
TOM: IT IS A MUCH MORE DIFFICULT
QUESTION THIS YEAR THAN LAST
YEAR.
BUT HE WATCHES SET UP AT THE
PLATE.
HE HAS DONE A COUPLE THINGS.
HE HAS ALWAYS HAD THAT PUMP WITH
HIS HAND TO GET A LITTLE RHYTHM
GOING, BUT HE HAS PUT A LITTLE
TOE TAP IN THERE.
TAP AND GO.
HE TOLD ME HE REALLY NEEDED TO
ESTABLISH MORE RHYTHM WITH HIS
LOWER HALF.
THAT LITTLE TOE TAP THAT HE HAS,
IT HAS HIM ON TIME.
SEE HOW SIMPLE THAT SWING IS?
POWERFUL, SIMPLE SWING.
WE SAW THAT LAST NIGHT WITH THE
HOME RUN.
THIS GUY HAD A LITTLE BIT OF A
HOLD, BUT HE HAS COVERED THAT
AND A LOT MORE.
SCOTT: THAT WAS HIS 29TH
CAREER-HIGH YESTERDAY.
THAT PITCH FROM YESTERDAY WAS A
CUTTER.
THAT WAS WELL ABOVE THE ZONE.
HE HAS POPPED EIGHT IN
SEPTEMBER.
FIVE WITH DUVALL FOR MOST IN --
TIED WITH DUE BALL FOR MOST IN
THE LEAGUE.
-- ADAM DUVALL FOR MOST IN THE
LEAGUE.
>> A TWO SEAMER.
SCOTT: DOES NOT GET THE CALL.
TOM: THAT WAS A GREAT SEQUENCE.
OPENED UP THE OUTSIDE PART OF
THE PLATE.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT IS A MILE AWAY.
IT JUST MISSED.
SCOTT: THE CARDINALS HAVE SCORED
IN ALL THREE GAMES OF THIS
SERIES.
HAUSER IS ONE STRIKE AWAY.
ALL OVER THE ZONE, ADRIAN HAS.
THE BREWERS WITH A MAGIC NUMBER
OF THREE TO WRAP UP THE
DIVISION.
TOM: HAUSER IS MUCH MORE
COMFORTABLE.
IT COMMANDS IT MUCH BETTER.
SCOTT: ANOTHER GOOD AT THAT FOR
TYLER O'NEILL.
SCOTT: EIGHT PITCHES, MOSTLY
SINKERS IN THIS MATCHUP.
THE PAYOFF.
GOT HIM.
CHALLENGED HIM WITH THE SINKER
AND HAUSER COMES OUT VICTORIOUS,
THREE UP AND THREE DOWN.
FINALLY SILENCING THE CARDINALS.
>> THAT WAS A NASTY LITTLE
BREAKING BALL.
PERALTA'S FIRST STRIKEOUT VICTIM
OF THE NIGHT.
GOT HIM ON THREE PITCHES.
NASTY.
SWUNG ON AND MISSED.
THREE UP AND THREE DOWN FOR
FREDDY PERALTA.
>> HERE IS VICTOR REYES.
>> HE HAS IT GOING.
GOT HIM AGAIN IN THE SAME SPOT.
THAT IS NASTY.
THE 1-2 PITCH.
GOT HIM.
FREDDY PERALTA, WHAT A START.
PERALTA WITH THREE STRIKEOUTS.
A SWING AND A MISS.
PUT IT RIGHT BY HIM.
SWING AND A MISS.
HE STRUCK HIM OUT.
NUMBER EIGHT FOR FREDDY PERALTA.
A 2-2.
GOT HIM.
WENT UPSTAIRS AGAIN AND PICKS UP
STRIKE NUMBER NINE.
SCOTT: KOLTEN WONG WILL START
THINGS OFF FOR THE CARDINALS.
CHRISTIAN YELICH IS THE NUMBER
THREE SPOT TODAY.
LORENZO CAIN STARTING ON
BACK-TO-BACK DAYS.
HAUSER IS IN THE NUMBER NINE
SPOT.
GREAT NUMBERS AGAINST ST. LOUIS.
A GREAT SEASON OFFENSIVELY.
ON THE MOUND IS THE 40-YEAR-OLD.
HE IS 40, BUT HE GETS BETTER
WITH AGE.
>> LOOK AT THE INNINGS.
THAT REALLY JUMPS OUT TO ME.
PRETTY GOOD FOR A 40-YEAR-OLD.
HOW ABOUT THAT LAST LINE?
>> MAJOR MILESTONE SHOULD BE
POPPING UP FOR HIM THIS
AFTERNOON.
HE HAS PITCHED THROUGH THE SIXTH
INNING.
YOU JUST DO NOT SEE THAT VERY
OFTEN THESE DAYS.
STARTERS KEEP GOING SHORTER AND
SHORTER.
FIRST PITCH FROM WAINWRIGHT.
KOLTEN WONG WAS A CARDINAL UP
THROUGH LAST SEASON.
MAKES CONTACT THROUGH THE RIGHT
SIDE, BASE HIT.
THE BREWERS HAVE THEIR LEADOFF
MAN ABOARD.
A LITTLE JIM BEAM BREAKDOWN OF
ADAM WAINWRIGHT'S GREATNESS THIS
YEAR.
WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE?
TOM: IT IS A CLASSIC
COMBINATION.
TALKING ABOUT THE SINKER CUTTER
COMBO.
HE STILL RELIES ON GOOD OLD
UNCLE CHARLIE, THAT GOOD OLD
CURVEBALL.
YOU KNOW YOU HAD A GREAT ONE.
YOU BETTER GET HIM EARLY.
IF YOU BREAK IT INTO THIRDS,
WAINWRIGHT'S E.R.A. GETS BETTER
IN THE THIRD AND EVEN BETTER IN
THE LAST THIRD.
SCOTT: A STRIKE TO ADONIS.
-- ADAMES.
HE IS BACK FROM, DEALING WITH A
STRAIN.
THE BREWERS SHORTSTOP IS ON A
TEAR.
CARLSON WILL MEASURE IT.
OUT NUMBER ONE.
YOU MENTIONED IT.
THE SIGNATURE CURVEBALL IS
THERE.
HE USES IT A TON.
POWERED BY GOOGLE CLOUD.
HE REALLY DO NOT KNOW WHAT YOU
ARE GETTING AND ANY COUNT.
TOM: IT IS ALL ABOUT LOCATION.
YOU WILL SEE CERTAIN TIMES THAT
LEFT-HANDED HITTERS -- THE WAY
THAT HE COMMANDS THE BALL ON THE
EDGES OF THE PLATE, BOTH IN AND
OUT.
THAT SINKER IS A LITTLE ELEVATED
AS WELL.
SCOTT: A MEETING WITH CHRISTIAN
YELICH TO CHECK ON KOLTEN WONG.
CHRISTIAN YELICH IS 0-8 IN THIS
SERIES.
THIS HAS BEEN THEIR GUY FOR
YEARS.
HE IS LOCKED UP, LONG TERM,
M.V.P. CANDIDATE FOR YEARS.
THIS YEAR, HE HAS HIT THE
INJURED LIST A COUPLE TIMES.
JUST HAS NOT LOOKED THE SAME.
TOM: RIGHT THERE HAS BEEN THE
BIGGEST ACHILLES HEEL.
NO HOME RUNS OFF BREAKING
PITCHES THIS YEAR.
20, HE HAD 12.
A LOT MORE ROLLOVER IN HIS GAME.
GROUND BALL RATE HAS GONE WAY UP
THIS YEAR.
SCOTT: TO BALLS AND A STRIKE.
TOM: THERE STILL HAS TO BE
LINGERING EFFECTS.
I DO NOT SEE THE SAME
EXPLOSIVENESS IN THE SWING.
>> HE WAS IN M.V.P..
FOULED OFF ON THE RIGHT SIDE,
BUT YOU ARE SEEING A TON OF
THAT.
WE SAW EARLY IN HIS CAREER AS A
MARLIN.
HE PICKED IT UP AND BECAME A TOP
THREE, TOP FIVE HITTER.
A SPLIT SINCE THEN.
>> THIS IS CLASSIC WAINWRIGHT,
WHERE HE IS GOING IN AND OUT.
COULD GO BACK TO THE CURVEBALL
RIGHT HERE.
THEY DID, IT WAS A GOOD PITCH.
A BETTER TAKE.
I MENTIONED AT THE TOP THAT YOU
WILL NOT FIND MANY.
IF FULL COUNT IS A CURVEBALL,
BUT HE WILL THROW ANYTHING.
HIS CURVEBALL PERCENTAGE
ACTUALLY GOES UP.
LET'S SEE IF HE TRIES TO DOUBLE
UP.
>> IT WOULD BE FUNNY IF IT WAS A
CALLED STRIKE.
LIFTING IT TO LEFT.
O'NEILL DRAGGING -- PUSHING IT
TO THE LINE.
TOM: I CANNOT REMEMBER OFF THE
TOP OF MY HEAD A PITCHER THAT
COULD COMMAND THE CURVEBALL THE
WAY THAT HE DOES.
YOU NEED TO THROW A STRIKE THERE
AND HE IS ABLE TO THROW
CURVEBALLS THAT ARE STILL TOUGH
TO HIT.
THEY WANT TO GET YOU OUT OF THE
ZONE.
HE COULD DO THAT, BUT WHEN HE
HAS TO THROW THE CURVEBALL, HE
HAS THE CONFIDENCE TO COMMAND
IT.
SCOTT: WE USE THE WORD PAINT A
LOT, BUT NOT OFTEN WITH A
CURVEBALL.
NOW HE HAS EDUARDO ESCOBAR,
ACQUIRED BY MILWAUKEE.
CAME OVER FROM THE DIAMONDBACKS.
ICE COLD LATELY, LIKE MANY IN
THE LINEUP.
>> IF YOU THINK HE IS GOING TO
THROW A FIRST PITCH CURVEBALL.
MILWAUKEE IN AN OFFENSE OF RIGHT
LATELY.
--RUT -- RUT LATELY.
TOM: IT WAS A HIT AT THE TOP OF
THE INNING.
SCOTT: KOLTEN WONG LEAD OFF WITH
A SINGLE.
YOU KNOW THAT IS GOING TO BE A
MISS.
HOME PLATE UMPIRE IS CARLO
TORRES TODAY.
LIVE GAME COMMENTARY IS FLOWING
WITH THE YOUTUBE CREATORS.
ONE SAYING THAT WAINWRIGHT MIGHT
BE FATHER TIME.
APPARENTLY NEXT YEAR MIGHT BE
HIS FINAL SEASON.
IT LOOKS LIKE HE HAS A LOT LEFT
IN THE TANK.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
2-0 THE COUNT.
HE GETS BACK IN WITH THE
CURVEBALL.
SCOTT: HE SAYS HE USES THAT
CURVEBALL IN DIFFERENT WAYS, BUT
THE SHAPE HAS BEEN THE SAME
SINCE HE WAS IN LITTLE LEAGUE.
THIS IS A SPOT WHERE HE MIGHT GO
CURVEBALL.
ALMOST NO OTHER PITCHER IN THE
GAME WOULD DO THAT, IN THIS
SITUATION.
>> HE IS CAPABLE OF THROWING
ANYTHING RIGHT HERE.
AS A HITTER, YOU ARE FACING
WAINWRIGHT AND IT IS A CHALLENGE
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO HONOR BOTH
SIDES OF THE PLATE.
THE DIFFERENCE IN VELOCITY IS
EXTREME AS WELL.
AGAIN, NO MATTER WHAT THE COUNT,
A LOT OF PITCHERS NOW.
A LOT IN ON VELOCITY AND
LOCATION, BUT YOU CANNOT DO
EITHER AGAINST WAINWRIGHT.
SCOTT: THE CHANGEUP HAS BEEN A
BIG DIFFERENCE MAKER FRIEND THIS
YEAR.
IT IS EFFECTIVE WHEN HE HAS GONE
TO IT.
RUNNERS ON THE MOVE.
TOM: THAT WAS A CUTTER RIGHT
THERE.
THAT WAS A GOOD HIT.
JUST ENOUGH MOVEMENT TO GET OFF
THE BARREL.
SCOTT: CHRISTIAN YELICH WORKED A
FULL COUNT.
SO DID ESCOBAR.
ANOTHER FOUL BALL.
HERE IS THE MIX.
TOM: THE ONLY PIT YOU HAVE NOT
SEEN YET IS THE FOUR-SEAM
FASTBALL.
ONCE IN A WHILE WANT TO SHOW
THAT TO THE HITTER TO RAISE THE
EYE LEVEL.
SCOTT: THAT WAS TIPPED.
ESCOBAR AND THE RUMOR LOOKING TO
CRACK THE SCOREBOARD FIRST.
MILWAUKEE HAS DROPPED FOUR IN A
ROW, THEIR LONGEST LOSING SKID
SINCE MID JUNE SINCE THEY LOST
FIVE STRAIGHT BUT THEN THEY WON
13 OF 14 AFTER THAT.
TOM: THE OFFENSE HAS REALLY
DRIED UP IN THE LAST WEEK.
LOOKING FOR ANY KIND OF A SPARK.
RIGHT HERE, ESCOBAR IS EXTENDING
THE AT-BAT, WAITING ON A MISTAKE
FROM WAINWRIGHT.
SCOTT: THERE GOES  WONG.
BALL FOUR.
TOM: THAT IS, WAITING AND
AT-BAT.
TOUGH 3-2 CURVEBALLS.
-- WINNING AN AT-BAT.
SCOTT: HERE IS URIAS BACK AT
THIRD BASE AFTER FILLING IN AT
SHORTSTOP YESTERDAY OR ADAMES.
HE HOMERED IN GAME ONE OF THIS
SERIES ON MONDAY AGAINST JON
LESTER, HIS 21ST OF THE SEASON.
HAD A REALLY NICE YEAR AT THE
PLATE.
SOME THROWING ISSUES ON DEFENSE.
HE IS BETTER IN SPOTS BESIDES
SHORTSTOP.
GOING AFTER THE FIRST PITCH.
HE LIKES TO ATTACK EARLY.
THERE IT IS, SINCE AUGUST 1,
URIAS IS LOOKING NORTH OF .500.
TOM: YOU SAW THE AGGRESSIVENESS,
THAT IS A PART OF HIS DNA AS A
HITTER.
WAINWRIGHT IS AN EXPERT AT
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF HITTERS
AGGRESSIVENESS.
SEE IF HE TRIES TO STRETCH THE
STRIKE ZONE RIGHT HERE.
NOW THAT HE IS CONTROLLING THE
COUNT, FIRST PITCH STRIKE.
SCOTT: HE LIKES TO LEAN BACK AND
THEN DIG IN.
0-2.
I THINK HE IS STRETCHING HIS
BACK.
A GOOD WAKE-UP STRETCH, AND THEN
I AM READY.
TOM: IT IS KIND OF THE THING
LATELY IN BASEBALL.
WINKER, RIZZO, ADAMES DOES A
LITTLE BIT AS WELL.
YOU DON'T SEE AS MANY HITTERS IN
TODAY'S GAME IN A SUPER CROUCH
OR HUNCHED OVER.
THAT IS BECAUSE OF THE HIGH
FASTBALL.
HITTERS SEEN MORE UPRIGHT THAN
IN THE PAST, A REMINDER.
STAY TALL IN THE BOX.
SCOTT: THEY ARE MAKING HIM WORK.
22 PITCHES IN THIS FIRST INNING
FROM WAINWRIGHT.
TOM: E.R.A. THROUGH THE FIRST
THREE INNINGS IS 3.71.
MIDDLE INNINGS, 2.34.
FINAL 3, 1 .73.
NOW IS THE TIME.
SCOTT: DID HE PLAYOFFS?
YES, HE DID.
DON LIBKA.
TOM: PART OF THAT, SCOTT, WHEN
YOU ARE A PITCHER LIKE ADAM
WAINWRIGHT, YOU HAVE SO MANY
PITCHES, SO MANY THAT RELY ON
TOUCHING DEAL AND COMMAND, IT
CAN TAKE A WHILE TO LOCK IN.
WHAT IS WORKING TODAY, WHAT THE
STRIKE ZONE IS.
HE IS WORKING HIS WAY THROUGH
THIS INNING.
SEE IF HE GOES BACK TO THE
CURVEBALL, TWO STRIKE COUNT.
GOOD TAKE ON THE CUTTER.
SCOTT: AND ANOTHER FULL BOAT.
THREE BREWERS IN A ROW WORKING
IT TO 3-2.
PITCHING COACH MIKE MADDUX.
LET'S TALK THROUGH IT.
TOM: THIS COULD ALSO BE CHANGING
SIGNS.
WONG SECOND BASE, THEIR FORMER
TEAMMATE, HAS NOW SEEN FIVE
PITCHES FROM SECOND BASE.
URIAS HAS DONE A NICE JOB
SPITTING ON SOME PITCHES OFF THE
PLATE.
THIS IS A SITUATION IF YOU ARE
YADI, WHAT DO YOU WANT TO THROW?
NOW YOU DON'T HAVE TO PUT A SIGN
DOWN.
YOU HAVE AGREED TO WHAT THE
PITCH IS.
IF THERE IS ANY THOUGHT THAT THE
RUNNER ON SECOND BASE IS GETTING
THE SEQUENCE, YOU ARE NOT
GETTING A SIGNED, OR IF YOU ARE,
YOU ARE GETTING A DUMMY SIGN.
THEY HAVE TALKED ABOUT THE
PITCH, THEY KNOW WHAT HE WANTS
TO THROW.
SCOTT: WONG SINGLED, ESCOBAR
WALKED.
TWO OUTS, TWO ON.
AND HE WALKS ANOTHER.
BALANCED THAT ONE AND LOADS OF
THE BASES -- BOUNCED THAT ONE
AND LOADS THE BASES.
TOM: THAT IS UNUSUAL TO SEE
WAINWRIGHT OUTS THAT CURVEBALL
ON A FULL STRIKE, FULL COUNT.
SCOTT: IT IS UP TO TYRONE
TAYLOR, SECOND START FOR HIM IN
THIS SERIES, 10 HOME RUNS ON THE
YEAR.
ADDED SOME MUSCLE THIS YEAR, AND
IT IS PAYING OFF.
TOM: LAST PITCH A LITTLE BIT
HARDER THAN NORMAL ON THE
SINKER, 91.
TYPICALLY AT 89.
SCOTT: GRAND SLAM IN HIS CAREER
EXACTLY TWO MONTHS AGO AGAINST
THE WHITE SOX, HERE AT HOME.
AND HE SOX THE 1-0 DEEP CENTER,
BADER GIVING IT A LOOK, AND
FORGET ABOUT IT?TYRONE TAYLOR
MUSCLES UP
.
HIS SECOND GRAND SLAM OF THE
SEASON.
THE BREWERS HANG FOUR RON
WAINWRIGHT IN THE FIRST! -- ON
WAINWRIGHT IN THE FIRST!
TOM: SCOTT, IT WAS ONE PITCH, A
CUTTER THAT DID NOT, SAT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE PLATE.
IT WAS REALLY THE EFFECT OF THE
26 PITCHES BEFORE THAT, AND THE
QUALITY AT-BAT'S THAT THE
BREWERS STRUNG TOGETHER AGAINST
WAINWRIGHT TO GET TO THAT POINT.
SCOTT: WHAT A MOMENT FOR TYRONE
TAYLOR.
LORENZO CAIN WITH A SPINNER.
THAT WILL SIT DOWN THE SIDE.
THERE IS CARLSON.
THE BREWERS STRIKE BIG.
TYRONE TAYLOR WITH HIS 11TH HOME
RUN OF THE SEASON, SECOND GRAND
SLAM OF THE YEAR.
THE 27-YEAR-OLD, HIS THIRD YEAR
IN THE BIGS, JUST CAME BACK A
FEW DAYS AGO.
MORE POP IN THE BAT THIS YEAR,
AND IT PAYS OFF.
THE BREWERS ARE LOOKING TO
SALVAGE A GAME IN THE SERIES.
OFF TO A FINE START.
♪
>> EDMAN, GOLDY, O'NEILL,
ARENADO.
SINCE SEPTEMBER 8, THEY ALONE
AVERAGING FOUR RUNS.
INTO DEEP LEFT.
IT IS GONE!
2-0, CARDINALS.
R.B.I.'S NUMBER 100 AND 101.
AND HE DOES IT IN STYLE.
2-0, ST. LOUIS.
THE FIRST SINCE MATT HOLLIDAY
100 OR MORE DRIVEN IN.
>> YADIER MOLINA HAS GROUNDED
INTO A FIELDER'S CHOICE AND
STRUCK OUT0-2 TONIGHT.
BOUNCER THROUGH THE HOLE.
THE LEFT SIDE, HERE COMES
O'NEILL.
'S THROW IS NOT IN TIME.
>> IN THE AIR, LEFT CENTER,
THERE IS BADER.
JON LESTER THROUGH SIX.
IF THE CARDINALS CAN HOLD ON, IT
WILL BE WIN NUMBER 200 AND HIS
OUTSTANDING CAREER.
>> GARCIA GETS THE NINTH INNING
FOR ST. LOUIS.
GROUND BALL, RIGHT SIDE.
WIN NUMBER 200 IN THE CAREER OF
JON LESTER.
SCOTT: TYRONE TAYLOR GRAND SLAM
IN THE FIRST.
MILWAUKEE IS UP BIG.
WE ARE LOOKING AT BETTERING
PITCHERS WHO ARE LIKELY
POSTSEASON BOUND.
GREINKE MORE THAN SCHERZER OR
WAINWRIGHT.
YOU HAVE TO BE AT LEAST 37 YEARS
OLD.
WAINO IS THE SENIOR MEMBER.
HAUSER STARTS NOLAN ARENADO A
PITCH INSIDE.
OUR FIRST U2 POLL QUESTION IS
LIVE.
WHICH A VETERAN OF THESE FOUR
WILL BE MOST IMPORTANT TO THEIR
TEAM IN OCTOBER?
WAINWRIGHT IS ON THE LIST.
WHO IS TOPS ON YOUR LIST AMONG
THESE FOUR ARE, WHO IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT?
TOM: I KNOW HE IS SURROUNDED BY
WALKER BUEHLER, BUT I AM SAYING
MAX SCHERZER, THE WAY HE IS
THROWING THE BASEBALL.
SCOTT: WHAT A SECOND HALF FOR
MAX SCHERZER.
TOM: I THINK SOME OF THE BEST
BASEBALL OF HIS CAREER.
SCOTT: WHAT IS IT WITH THESE
GUYS?
WAINWRIGHT, I KNOW THE BLIP IN
THE FIRST INNING, BUT HE HAS
BEEN AS GOOD AS EVER SINCE THE
ALL-STAR BREAK.
TOM: WE ARE SEEING WITH THESE
OLDER PITCHERS, DURABILITY THIS
YEAR.
MAY BE THE SHORT SEASON LAST
YEAR, 60-GAME SEASON, MAYBE THAT
PLAYS MORE IN FAVOR OF THE OLDER
PITCHERS, GIVING THEM A BREAK IN
TERMS OF WORKLOAD.
SCOTT: DOWN BROADWAY TO DYLAN
CARLSON.
THOSE ARE GUYS, AT THIS POINT,
THAT KNOW HOW TO TAKE CARE OF
THEIR BODY AND PREPARE
THEMSELVES FOR A LONGER SEASON
COMING OFF OF THE ABRIDGED
VERSION IN 2020.
TOM: WAINWRIGHT REALLY IS
OLD-SCHOOL, LOVES TAKING THE
BALL ON THE FIFTH DAY.
FFOUR DAYS OF REST.
HIS FIFTH START DOING THAT.
SCOTT: WE SO, THEN SAY, EVERY
FIFTH DAY, BUT IT IS ACTUALLY
EVERY SIXTH DAY.
TOM: PITCHERS HAVE FIVE DAYS OF
REST OR MORE.
SCOTT: CARLSON'S BAT IS ALL OVER
THE IN IL BUT IT TURNS INTO A
SINGLE.
TOM: CLEAN UP, I'LL NINE --
AISLE NINE.
THAT IS THE TURBO SINKER.
MOVEMENT PLUS VELOCITY.
SEE IT RUN AWAY FROM CARLSON.
NATURAL ARM SIDE MOVEMENT.
SCOTT: A ONE-OUT BASE RUNNER FOR
THE REDBIRDS.
HERE IS YADI.
TOM: YOU TALK ABOUT OLD-SCHOOL.
DON'T USE THE WORDS LOAD
MANAGEMENT AROUND YADI MOLINA.
IN SEPTEMBER, DAY GAME AFTER A
NIGHT GAME, HE IS NOT ONLY IN
THE LINEUP, HE WAS OUT EARLY
TAKING GROUND BALLS AT SECOND
BASE.
ONLY A COUPLE OF THE EXTRAS FOR
THE CARGOES TOOK BATTING
PRACTICE, PLUS YADI WAS TAKING
PRACTICE.
THERE IS ANOTHER GROUND FROM
HAUSER.
SCOTT: EASY FOR THE BREWERS TO
DOUBLE HIM UP AND SIT DOWN THE
SIDE.
YOU ARE RIGHT, YADI HAS CAUGHT
ALL OF ONE OF WAINO'S STARTS,
AND FOR THAT ONE HE WAS ON THE
INJURED LIST.
CARDINALS HAVE WORK TO DO,
TRAILING 4-0.
URIAS FIRING UP THE 5-4-3,
FIRING UP ADRIAN HOUSER.
>> THE CARDINALS IN THE LAST
FIVE GAMES REALLY HAVE SET THE
TONE.
15 FIRST INNING RUNS IN THOSE
FIVE GAMES.
O'NEILL SENDS IT OUT TO CENTER.
TAYLOR WITH THE CATCH.
EDMUND WITH THE TAG.
CARDINALS WITH THE LEAD IN THE
FIRST INNING.
>> YOU MENTIONED HOW THE TEAM
HAS BEEN FIGURE OUT WAYS TO GET
THEMSELVES ON THE BOARD.
>> WOULD ROCK BACK ON THE MOUND
TO START THE SIXTH, 0-2.
CALLED STRIKE THREE.
WOODRUFF WITH 10 K'S.
>> TOMMY EDMAN.
THAT IS A BASE HIT, HERE COMES
NOOTBAAR.
BACK IN SAFELY, 2-0, ST. LOUIS.
>> THEY ARE GOING TO
INTENTIONALLY WALK YELICH.
THAT BELOW THE BASES AND PUT THE
WINNING RUN AT SECOND BASE.
>> IT IS A GUTSY MOVE TO PUT THE
WINNING RUN IN SCORING POSITION.
>> THEY GOT HIM!
THEY STRAND THE BASES LOADED.
FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE THE
2001 SEASON, THE CARDINALS HAVE
WON 10 IN A ROW.
>> I SEE THE BALL GOING INTO THE
SECOND DECK.
>> OH!
WHOO!
YEAH!
ATTA BOY, T!
ATTA BOY!
SCOTT: PSION CANDIDATE CORBIN
BURNES MIC'D UP FOR US ON
YOUTUBE.
SOME GUYS WILL SAY, I CALLED
THAT.
IT IS DOCUMENTED.
TOM: STAY HOT, CORBIN BURNES.
SCOTT: WHAT A SEASON FOR HIM,
EVERYTHING IS CLICKING.
HERE COMES THE BREWERS OFFENSE.
FIVE RUNS IN THE FIRST THREE
AGAINST ST. LOUIS, FOUR IN THE
FIRST INNING THANKS TO TYRONE
TAYLOR THANKS TO THAT GRAND
SLAM.
NOW IT IS MANNY PINA.
TOM: A COUPLE OF GOOD TAKES.
WAINWRIGHT ON THE EDGE OF THE
ZONE, NOT GETTING CALLED
STRIKES, NOT GETTING SWINGS.
SCOTT: FOR A GAME PLAN TO BE
EXECUTED CORRECTLY FOR A COMMAND
PITCHER LIKE WAINWRIGHT WHO HAS
TWO STRIKES NOW ON PINA -- THAT
WAS CALLED OFF THE PLATE?
TOM: YOU DON'T SEE A CATCHER
TURNAROUND OFTEN BUT I CAN
UNDERSTAND WHY HE DID.
HE BACKHANDED THE BALL BUT THAT
GOT PLENTY OF PLATE.
WOW.
SCOTT: 3-1.
FOUL BALL.
THAT WAS A TOUGH ONE BEFORE.
TWO PITCHES AGO, SORRY.
THAT IS ONE OF THOSE PITCHES, I
DON'T EVEN LOOK AT THE UMP'S
CALL, ASSUMED IT WAS A STRIKE.
TOM: MORE EVIDENCE THAT UMPIRES
CAN BE INFLUENCED BY THE CATCHER
CATCHING THE BALL, EXCEPT OR
JUST WALKING IN ON THE PLATE.
SCOTT: ANOTHER 3-2 COUNT FROM A
BREWER BAT TODAY.
CONNECTED INTO LEFT.
THERE IS O'NEILL.
TOM: WHEN ADAM WAINWRIGHT IS
RIGHT, HE OWNS BOTH SIDES OF THE
PLATE, THE CLASSIC COMBINATION.
CUTTER MOVES FROM RIGHT TO LEFT.
NOW THE SINKER IS MOVING LEFT TO
RIGHT.
THAT IS CALLED CARVING AN EXXON
THE PLATE.
HE CAN DO THAT ON BOTH SIDES, SO
AS A HITTER, YOU ARE NOT QUITE
SURE WHICH WAY THE BALL IS GOING
TO MOVE.
IS THE BALL GOING TO GO LEFT,
RIGHT?
THAT IS WHAT HE DOES, CARVES X'S
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE PLATE FOR
RIGHT-HANDED AND LEFT-HANDED
HITTERS.
RARELY IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
PLATE BUT THAT IS WHAT HAPPENED
ON TAYLOR'S HOME RUN.
SCOTT: MATT ANTONELLI ON THE GAM
CAM AND TERRIE.
HE SAID THAT CUTTER JUST SAT
THERE, TALKING ABOUT TYRONE
TAYLOR'S BIG AT-BAT.
BY THE WAY, ADRIAN HOUSER.
TWO LONG BALLS THIS YEAR.
TOM: WAINWRIGHT JUST THREW HIM A
CHANGEUP 1-0.
ADAM WALKED BEHIND THE MOUND AND
HAD A CONFERENCE WITH HIMSELF.
WAINWRIGHT THROWS VERY FEW
CHANGEUPS ESPECIALLY TO
RIGHT-HANDED HITTERS.
SCOTT: THE ONLY THING I CAN
THINK OF IS IF YOU ARE TRYING TO
INCORPORATE ANOTHER PITCH, DO
YOU TRY TO WORK IT ON ANOTHER
PITCHER BE WHAT YOU GET INTO THE
LINEUP AGAIN?
SEE IF YOU HAVE IT.
THAT IS CLEANED UP BY EDMAN.
TOM: THAT WORKS EVEN BETTER, GO
RIGHT AFTER HIM WITH YOUR
SINKER, RIGHT ON THE HANDS.
KOLTEN WONG IS THE ONE WHO GOT
THAT TRIPLE STARTED FROM
WAINWRIGHT IN THAT LEADOFF
SINGLE.
THAT WAS OFF OF THE BREAKING
BALL.
THAT GOT WAINWRIGHT IMMEDIATELY
IN THE STRETCH.
ONE QUALITY AT-BAT AFTER ANOTHER
FOLLOWED.
SCOTT: ONE GROUND BALL OUT FIRST
TIME THROUGH THE ORDER FOR
WAINWRIGHT.
NO STRIKEOUTS TODAY.
LOOKING FOR THE BIG NUMBER 2000.
TOM: YOU HAVE TO GET THE BALL IN
THE PLATE TODAY.
ON THE EDGE IS NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
50/50 BALLS ARE GOING HITTERS
WAY.
BETTER CHANGEUP FROM WAINWRIGHT,
ALONG WITH YET ANOTHER GOOD TAKE
BY A MILWAUKEE HITTER.
SCOTT: THERE IT IS.
TOM: SOME REALLY NASTY MOVEMENT
ON THE CUTTER.
THE BEST CUTTER HE HAS THROWN SO
FAR.
CUT ALL THE WAY ACROSS THE
PLATE.
THAT WAS A GOOD EXAMPLE OF THE
COMBINATION WE JUST TALKED
ABOUT, CUTTER-SINKER.
PICK YOUR POISON IF YOU ARE THE
HITTER.
TOUGH TO GUARD AGAINST BOTH OF
THOSE PITCHES IN.
NOW COULD GO AWAY.
SCOTT: 2-2.
YOU CAN SEE HIM FRUSTRATED WITH
HIS CURVEBALL COMMAND.
TOM: JUST DOES NOT HAVE IT
LOCKED IN YET, A COUPLE WE HAVE
SEEN BOUNCE.
THAT WAS NOT TEMPTING ENOUGH YET
FOR WONG.
ANOTHER FULL COUNT.
MILWAUKEE IS A VERY AGGRESSIVE
HITTING TEAM, A LOT OF SWING AND
MISS IN THE LINEUP.
NOT A GREAT OFFENSIVE TEAM BUT
GOOD ENOUGH WITH THE PITCHING
STAFF THEY HAVE.
AS IF SOMEBODY DECIDED TODAY, WE
ARE GOING TO GRIND.
NOTHING EASY FOR WAINWRIGHT
TODAY.
VERY FEW CHASE SWINGS.
SCOTT: THE GAME PLAN IS WORKING,
THE ZONE IS TIGHT.
BREWERS HAVE FOUR.
KOLTEN WONG IS STILL IN THERE.
TOM: YOU SEE THE PITCH COUNT AT
46, HAS PROBABLY THROWN 20 ON A
FULL COUNT TRYING TO GET
STRIKEOUT NUMBER 2000 FOUR HIS
CAREER 20 OR 22 TIMES.
SCOTT: WONG SOCKS IT TO RIGHT.
CARLSON WILL LINE IT UP RECOVERY
INNING FOR ADAM WAINWRIGHT.
HE SITS DOWN THREE IN A ROW.
THE BATS HAVE WORK TO DO AFTER
TWO.
4-0 FOR FIRST PLACE MILWAUKEE.
FOR FIRST PLACE MILWAUKEE.
>> TYLER O'NEILL COMING UP.
INTO DEEP LEFT.
2-0, ST. LOUIS!
YET AGAIN, TYLER O'NEILL.
>> GREAT SPEED ON THE BASES FOR
TOMMY EDMAN.
>> DEEP RIGHT CENTER, CAIN BACK
WITH THE CATCH.
BOTH RUNNERS TAGGING UP.
HERE COMES MANN, HERE COMES
ANOTHER.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
SPEED KILLS.
TWO RUNS SCORE.
>> FOUR IN A ROW FOR MIKOLAS.
>> WHAT A PLAY, NOLAN ARENADO!
HE HOLDS ON, WENT OVER THE TARP,
BACK TO THE INFIELD, AND A
BASKET CATCH FROM A NOLAN.
.
>> TOMMY EDMAN TO SECOND BASE.
GOLD HE HITS IT OUT TO DEEP
LEFT.
HOW FAR?
IT IS A 10-2 ST. LOUIS LEAD.
>> THE CARDINALS ARE ONE OUT
AWAY FROM THEIR 11TH CONSECUTIVE
WIN >> >>.
>> 11 STRAIGHT FOR THE ST. LOUIS
CARDINALS.
SCOTT: LET'S POLISH OFF OUR
FIRST BOWL OF THE DAY ON
YOUTUBE.
WHICH VETERAN PITCHER WILL BE
MOST IMPORTANT TO THEIR TEAM IN
OCTOBER?
MAX SCHERZER TAKES IT OVER ADAM
WAINWRIGHT.
BOTH SOLID CANDIDATES.
TOM: I GET THE FEELING YOU DON'T
AGREE WITH ME.
SCOTT: I DON'T HAVE TIME NOW,
ONLY BECAUSE THERE IS SO MUCH
DEPTH IN THAT ROTATION.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THAT MATCH
LATER BECAUSE THEY WILL GO UP
AGAINST EACH OTHER IN A
WILD-CARD GAME.
RIGHT NOW, OUR ATTENTION IS ON
MILES DOUGLAS, JIM BEAM DUGOUT
INTERVIEW.
QUESTIONS FOR MILES, HE WILL
ANSWER THEM.
I WILL HANDPICK THEM.
HOW ARE YOU DOING TODAY?
>> IT IS A GOOD DAY.
I THOUGHT THE ROOF WOULD BE OPEN
BECAUSE WE HAVE GREAT WEATHER.
SCOTT: WE TALKED ABOUT THAT A
LOT BEFORE THE GAME BEGAN.
I DID HEAR THERE IS
PRECIPITATION IN THE FORECAST.
THAT IS APPARENTLY LEGIT.
WHEN I WALKED IN, I THOUGHT THIS
WAS PERFECT BASEBALL WEATHER.
>> IT DOESN'T TAKE LONG TO CLOSE
THE ROOF.
THEY COULD HAVE WAITED IT OUT, I
THINK.
TOM: I AM WITH YOU.
IT LOOKED GORGEOUS DURING BPD, A
LITTLE DISAPPOINTED, BUT
APPARENTLY RIGHT AROUND NOW,
RAIN IN THE FORECAST.
SCOTT: THERE IS A STRIKEOUT FOR
HOUSER.
LET'S DIVE INTO IT, MILES.
GREAT GAME YESTERDAY.
SEVEN STRONG FOR YOUR CARDINALS
IN A 10-2 WIN.
WHAT IS WORKING WELL FOR YOU
RIGHT NOW?
YOU ARE HITTING A GROOVE THE
LAST COUPLE OF STARTS.
>> FANTASTIC.
>>JUST KEEPING THE BALL DOWN.
IF I CAN GET GROUND AND LET THIS
DEFENSE WORK, KEEP GUYS OFF
BALANCE.
KIND OF PITCHING 101.
WE HAVE A GREAT DEFENSE.
IF I CAN KEEP THE CONTACT WEAK,
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE PLAYS AND
GET A LOT OF OUTS.
TOM: THE CARDINALS DEFENSE IS
ONE OF THE BEST IN BASEBALL.
GIVE ME A WINDOW INTO HOW THE
PITCHER THINKS OUT THERE.
YOUR STAFF GENERALLY PITCHES TO
CONTACT, NOT AS MUCH SWING AND
MISS AS MILWAUKEE.
YOU ARE ON THE MOUND, PHILOSOPHY
OF THE DEFENSE BEHIND YOU?
>> I AM TRYING TO GET OUTS WITH
THE FIRST PITCH.
YOU LOOK AROUND THE LEAGUE ,
THEY ARE TRYING TO GETTHEIR
A-SWING OFF.
YOU CAN MAKE A LOT OF QUICK OUTS
AND GO DEEPER INTO GAMES.
A LOT OF GUYS GOING FIVE
INNINGS, 10 STRIKEOUTS.
I WOULD RATHER GO SEVEN OR EIGHT
90 SOMETHING WITH A HANDFUL OF
STRIKEOUTS, IF I CAN GET DEEPER
INTO THE GAME, TAKES SOME OF THE
LOAD OFF OF THE BULLPEN.
BEAT IT OUT.
CLOSE.
SCOTT: DO THEY CHALLENGE IT OR
LEAVE IT ALONE?
>> SOMETIMES I CANNOT TELL FROM
ALL THE WAY OVER IN THE DUGOUT.
WE ARE LOOKING INTO IT.
SCOTT: UNDER INVESTIGATION.
URIAS.
TOM: LOOKS LIKE THEY GOT HIM BUT
WE CAN TAKE ANOTHER LOOK.
BARELY.
SCOTT: ONE MORE PEEK.
BY A STEP.
THERE IS TWO.
LET ME SNEAK IN A FEW QUESTIONS
FROM OUR YOUTUBE CREATORS.
AUSTIN.
HELLO, MILES.
WHAT INSPIRED THAT EPIC
MUSTACHE?
>> EVER SEEN THE MOVIE "MR.
BASEBALL?"
TOM SELLECK HAS A GREAT
MUSTACHE.
THAT HAD TO HURT.
CATCHERS TAKE A BEATING.
IT IS A GOOD BASEBALL LOOK,
CLASSIC BASEBALL LOOK.
WHEN I GO HOME FOR THE
OFF-SEASON, I SHAVE IT.
JUST REGULAR MILES, I GUESS.
DURING THE SEASON, IT HELPS WITH
THE ON-FIELD PERSONA, KIND OF
SEPARATE YOUR BASEBALL FROM YOUR
REGULAR SELF, I GUESS, IF YOU
ARE TRYING TO HYPE YOURSELF UP
AND PLAY INTO WHAT YOUR JOB IS.
GOOD BASEBALL LOOK, THE FANS
SEEM TO LIKE IT.
I JUST ROLL WITH IT.
SCOTT: I AGREE, YOUR SEASON
VERSUS OFF-SEASON LOOK.
WE ARE LOOKING AT MANNY PINA,
BOUNCED RIGHT OFF OF THE LEFT
KNEECAP.
ONLY ONE OTHER CATCHER ON THE
ROSTER FOR MILWAUKEE.
AT THIS POINT IN THE SEASON,
SOME HAVE THREE.
WE WILL SEE IF PINA CAN STAY IN
THE GAME.
.
>> CATCHERS ARE ALL TOUGH.
I THINK HE WILL BE ALL RIGHT.
NOT A THANKLESS JOB, BUT I DON'T
THINK THEY GET ENOUGH CREDIT FOR
BEING ON THE CONTACT END OF WHAT
PEOPLE DON'T CONSIDER A CONTACT
SPORT.
TELL THAT TO ANY CATCHER.
THESE GUYS GET AS BEAT UP AS
ANYBODY.
SCOTT: YOU WORK WITH YADI,
KNIZNER.
YADI IS AN IRONMAN.
IT DOES LOOK LIKE PINA IS GOING
TO SHAKE IT OFF.
LET ME GET ANOTHER ONE.
WHO WINS A FOOT RACE BETWEEN YOU
AND THE OTHER CARDINALS
PITCHERS?
>> I LIKE MY CHANCES WITH
EVERYBODY RIGHT NOW.
AS SOON WHERE TO HE COMES BACK,
HE SCOOTS.
I HAVE NO CHANCE THERE.
AGAINST LESTER, WAINO, HAPP, IT
IS CLOSE.
LESTER AND WAINO ARE A LOT OF
BIT OLDER.
I LIKE MY CHANCES.
I AM A CONFIDENT GUY, PROBABLY
OVERCONFIDENT, SO I THINK I WIN.
WITH THE FIVE WE HAVE RIGHT NOW,
I WIN.
IT IS A LONGER DISTANCE SPIRIT,
I THINK I HAVE THAT EASY.
MAYBE EVEN A TIME TO MILE.
SCOTT: ARE YOU A RUNNER?
>> I LIKE TO EXERCISE, SO I AM
IN PRETTY GOOD SHAPE.
RUNNING AROUND AFTER KIDS KEEPS
YOU IN SHAPE.
SCOTT: GOOD POINT.
HERE IS A GUY THAT I THINK YOU
WOULD BE IT A RACE.
THE GREAT ADAM WAINWRIGHT AT THE
PLATE RIGHT NOW.
ARE YOU AMAZED AT WHAT HE HAS
DONE THIS YEAR OR NOT REALLY
BECAUSE OF WHAT HE HAS BEEN
BRINGING TO THE TABLE?
BROKEN BAT.
>> I HAVE HAD THE BENEFIT OF
SEEING IT SINCE 2018, SO I'M NOT
SURPRISED AS MOST, BUT WHAT HE
DOES IS INCREDIBLE.
YOU WATCH HIM DAY IN AND DAY
OUT, THE WAY HE TAKES CARE OF
HIS BODY, HIS PREPARATION,
SCOUTING REPORTS GOING INTO A
GAME, EVERYTHING THAT HE DOES.
YOU LOOK UP THE WORD
"PROFESSIONAL" IN THE DICTIONARY
AND IT IS A PITCHER OF HIM NEXT
TO YADI.
SCOTT: YOU HAVE SOME GOOD
TEAMMATES.
I WISH IT WAS LONGER.
WE WILL TALK SOON.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
MILES MIKOLAS WITH THE DUGOUT
INTERVIEW PRESENTED BY JIM BEAM.
BREWERS ARE UP4-0.
>> FASTBALL TO RIGHT AND DEEP.
GET OUT OF HERE, GONE!
HE RIPPED IT OUT OF HERE.
>> SWING AND A DRIVE, RIGHT
CENTER AND DEEP.
GET UP, GET OUT OF HERE, GONE!
MANNY PINA.
GET UP, STAY FAIR.
GET OUT OF HERE, GONE, MANNY
PINA!
THE BREWERS HAVE THE LEAD.
>> HERE COMES KOLTEN WONG WITH A
CHANCE TO PUT THE BREWERS ON TOP
HERE IN THE EIGHTH.
>> CENTER FIELD BASE HIT.
RADIOS WILL SCORE, CAIN WILL
SCORE.
KOLTEN WONG DELIVERS IN THE
CLUTCH.
>> RIGHT CENTER, THIS IS
TROUBLE.
LEAPING AND CAUGHT BY CAIN!
WHAT A GRAB BY LORENZO CAIN.
NOW IT IS WISDOM.
A BASE IT COULD TIE THE GAME.
HERE HE COMES.
STRUCK HIM OUT SWINGING!
THIS ONE IS OVER!
SCOTT: WE WILL GET TO THE
BREWERS HAVE OF THE THIRD INNING
AND WILLY ADAMES WILL LEADOFF
THE FRAME.
WHAT HAS CHANGED FOR HIM SINCE
HE CHANGE UNIFORMS?
TOM: I TALK ABOUT HITTERS BEING
A LITTLE BIT TALLER, HE IS DOING
THATB.
AT ANGLE IS DIFFERENT.
MORE UP AND DOWN LAST YEAR.
LOOK AT THE ANGLE OF HIS
SHOULDERS.
MUCH MORE UPHILL LAST YEAR.
LATELY, HE HAS GOTTEN BACK TO
BEING BIGGER, MORE UPHILL.
HE HAS MADE THAT ADJUSTMENT.
YOU WILL SEE HIM IN THE BOX,
THAT LEAN BACK TO REMIND
YOURSELF TO STAY TALLER IN THE
SETUP.
GET THE HANDS IN THE ZONE A
LITTLE HIGHER AND FLATTEN OUT
THE BATH PAT -- BAT PATH A
LITTLE MORE.
THAT HAS WORKED WONDERS FOR
ADAMES.
HE ADMITTED HE HAD A LOT OF
TROUBLE HITTING INSIDE SAINT
PETE.
THE LIGHTING CHANGED A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO, HAD A TOUGH TIME
SEEING IT, THAT IS A PART OF IT,
BUT THE ADJUSTMENTS HE HAS MADE
HERE HAVE MADE HIM A MUCH BETTER
HITTER.
SCOTT: HE ADJUSTED THEIR
OFFENSE.
MILWAUKEE WAS 21-23, AND THEN HE
JOINED THE PARTY AND THEY HAVE
TAKEN OFF.
TOM: LOOK AT THE STRIKEOUT
PERCENTAGE, WAY DOWN SINCE HE
LEFT TAMPA BAY.
REMINDS ME YEARS AGO WHEN THE
GIANTS PICKED UP MARCO SCUTARO.
IT WAS LIKE NOBODY HAD PAID
ATTENTION TO THE DEAL AND HE
WOUND UP BEING THE GUY WHO
EARNED THE NAME "BLOCKBUSTER."
THAT IS WILLY ADAMES.
NICE.
HAS THERE BEEN ANYBODY MORE
VALUABLE ON THE BREWERS OR WILLY
ADAMES?
SCOTT: YOU COULD MAKE THE CASE
FOR SCHERZER AND TURNER.
THOSE ARE BIG TIME NAMES FOR
YEARS, WHERE ADAMES REALLY
BLOSSOMED NOW, PULLS BACK ON HIS
BUNT ATTEMPT, RIGHT DOWN THE
PIKE FROM WAINWRIGHT IN THE
THIRD INNING, BUT HE IS STILL
YOUNG.
JUST TURNED 26 YEARS OLD THIS
MONTH.
TOM: THAT LEANED BACK IS MORE
UPRIGHT.
YOU DON'T SEE GUYS BEND OVER THE
WAY HE HAD BEEN.
SCOTT: NOLAN ARENADO, HE IS
AMAZING OVER THERE AT THE HOT
CORNER.
GROUND BALL OUT FOR WAINWRIGHT.
JUST THE SECOND OF THE GAME FOR
WAINO.
TOM: HE IS AS GOOD AS THERE IS
THROWING ON THE RUN.
HE TAKES AN EXTRA STEP HERE.
THAT IS TIMING.
HE KNEW HOW MUCH TIME HE HAD,
THE WAY HE CIRCLED BASEBALL,
SETS HIMSELF, THROWS A STRIKE.
MOST SHORTSTOPS THROW BETTER ON
THE RUN.
THAT IS A THIRD BASEMAN WHO
THROWS BETTER ON THE RUN.
SCOTT: NOW, CHRISTIAN YELICH.
HE IS POPULAR FOR WHAT HE HAS
DONE ON THE FIELD FOR THE
BREWERS OVER THE YEARS.
YOU CAN MAKE SOME EXTRA FRIENDS
WHEN YOU HOOK UP 10,000 FANS
WITH FREE TICKETS FOR THIS
SERIES, AND THAT IS WHAT YELICH
DID.
HE BOUGHT HIM, SAID WHO WANTS
THEM?
HAD TO GRAB THEM ONLINE.
I LOVE THE GESTURE.
THAT IS A WIN FOR EVERYONE.
PHILIP THE PARK AGAINST A RIVAL
-- FILL UP THE PARK AGAINST A
RIVAL.
TOM: DEFINITION OF A FRANCHISE
PLAYER.
SIGNING AN EXTENSION BEFORE
HITTING THE FREE MARKET.
SAYING I WANT TO BE HERE.
VERY INVOLVED IN THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY.
YOU MENTION HE IS A .292 HITTER
AGAINST WAINWRIGHT, BUT I GO BY
RECENCY.
THIS YEAR, WAINWRIGHT HAS OWNED
HIM.
SIX OUTS ON FIVE DIFFERENT
PITCHES.
PAY ATTENTION NOT ONLY TO THE
DIFFERENT PITCHES, BUT LOOK AT
THE LOCATION OF THESE PITCHES.
THIS IS ADAM AT HIS BEST.
CHANGING SPEEDS AND LIVING ON
THE EDGES OF THE PLATE, INSIDE
AND OUT.
WHAT DO YOU SEE HERE, CHRISTIAN?
SCOTT: HE HAS GOT ONE TO THE
LEFT SIDE.
ARENADO WILL MAKE IT TWO DOWN,
HERE IN THE THIRD.
TOM: A GOOD EXAMPLE, WHEN WE
LOOK AT CAREER NUMBERS, AND THEY
HAVE FACED EACH OTHER A LOT.
THIS YEAR ESPECIALLY, THE
NUMBERS ARE MUCH BETTER AGAINST
CHRISTIAN YELICH.
SCOTT: TWO GROUND BALL OUTS IN
THE INNING.
HERE IS ESCOBAR.
TOM: DO YOU KNOW WHAT HITTER
ADAM WAINWRIGHT HAS FACED MORE
THAN ANY OTHER HITTER IN HIS
CAREER?
SCOTT: FOR THE SAKE OF TIME.
RYAN BRAUN?
TOM: YES, 102 TIMES.
SCOTT: RECENTLY OFFICIALLY
RETIRED.
A BALL AND TWO STRIKES.
ABI GOING TO GET THE MILESTONE
HERE?
I AM CALLING IT HERE.
I WILL TRY MY BEST TO BE CORBIN
BURNES FOR ONE AT-BAT.
NOT THERE.
TOM: STRIKE THREE HAS BEEN HARD
TO COME BY.
A LOT OF TWO-STRIKE PITCHES.
SCOTT: 1999 CAREER STRIKEOUTS.
TOM: NOT TODAY.
NOT ON THAT CALL.
YADI CANNOT BELIEVE IT.
CARLOS TORRES HAS BEEN
CONSISTENT.
NOW, HERE COMES THE 10TH PITCH
THAT WAINWRIGHT WILL THROW ON A
FULL COUNT.
.
SCOTT: 60 TOSSES INTO HIS OUTING
ALREADY.
ESCOBAR WALKED THE FIRST TIME
AROUND.
AND THIS TIME, LAZY FLY BALL TO
CENTER.
BADER HAS GOT IT, INNING OVER.
AFTER THE GRAND SLAM IN THE
FIRST, WAINWRIGHT HAS SAT DOWN
SIX IN A ROW IN INNINGS NUMBER
TWO AND THREE.
>> 1-2 PITCH BY ALEX REYES.
GOT HIM!
STRIKES OUT THE SIDE IN THE
EIGHTH.
STRIKES OUT THE SIDE HERE IN THE
NINTH.
THE CARDINALS WIN IT BY THE
FINAL OF 7-0.
>> O'NEILL WITH A DRIVE INTO
DEEP CENTER AND GONE!
TYLER O'NEILL.
>> 2-2.
O'NEILL WITH A DRIVE OUT TO
LEFT.
IT IS GONE!
HE DID IT, IT IS A TWO-RUN SHOT
>>.
>>WHAT A GREAT MOMENT.
>> CARLSON SENDS A DEEP FLY BALL
TO CENTER.
IT IS AT THE WALL, GRAND
SLAMMER!
GRAND SLAM FOR THE ROOKIE.
WHAT A MOMENT HERE AT BUSCH.
>> ALONSO HITS IT OUT TO DEEP
RIGHT.
NOOTBAAR BACK AND HAS IT.
LARS NOOTBAAR ROBS ALONSO.
>> THIS IS OUR FOURTH YOUTUBE
GAME.
I THINK WE HAVE WON EVERY
YOUTUBE GAME WE HAVE BEEN ON.
AT LEAST A COUPLE.
TYLER HAS GOOD NUMBERS AGAINST
THE CARDS THIS YEAR.
ATTA BOY!
SINKER IS NASTY.
SCOTT: CORBIN BURNES TALKING FOR
US TODAY.
HE ISMIC'D UP ON YOUTUBE.
QUITE A FEW BREWERS GAMES THIS
YEAR, AND WHY NOT, ONE OF THE
BEST TEAMS IN THE SPORT.
I WOULD SAY THE BIG THREE IN THE
ROTATION AND DIEKMAN -- BULLPEN.
TOMMY EDMAN TAKES THE PITCH LOW
FROM ADRIAN HOUSER.
YES, HIS SINKER HAS BEEN MOSTLY
ON POINT SO FAR.
THE VICTORY IN THE ROTATION,
BURNS, PERALTA, BRANDON
WOODRUFF.
BACK IN THE BULLPEN, EVANS AND
JOSH HADER.
ANOTHER YOUNG MAN HAS EMERGED,
JAKE COUSINS.
WOULD YOU CALL HIM THE SEVENTH
INNING GUY?
I KNOW THEY ARE NOT CONVENTIONAL
IN THE WAY THEY DO THINGS BUT HE
IS PROBABLY THEIR NUMBER THREE
RELIEVER.
TOM: OUT GETTERS.
A WAY THAT CRAIG COUNSELL RUNS A
GAME, I LOVE IT.
SQUEEZES EVERY OUNCE OF THE
BALLGAME.
COUSINS WOULD BE NEXT IN LINE
BEHIND HADER AND WILLIAMS.
UNBELIEVABLE SLIDER.
HITTERS ARE HITTING0.90 AGAINST
THAT SLIDER.
IF THERE IS A POINT IN THE GAME
THAT LOOKS LIKE A SWING POINT,
HE WILL BRING IN HIS BEST ARM IN
THAT SITUATION.
CRAIG COUNSELL DOES NOT WAIT,
INCLUDING USING GUYS OFF THE
BENCH.
THERE IS COUNSEL RIGHT THERE.
SCOTT: YOU MIGHT SEE ALL OF THEM
TODAY IF IT HOLDS UP.
TOM: BEEN A WHILE SINCE THEY HAD
A LEAD TO PROTECT LATE.
SCOTT: YOU DON'T WANT TO GET
SWEPT BY THE CARDINALS.
LOST 10-2, THE LARGEST MARGIN OF
VICTORY FOR THE CARDINALS IN
ERROR 11 IN A ROW.
2-2 ON EDMAN.
TOM: THAT WAS A GOOD CHANGEUP
THAT HE THREW.
BETTER TAKE BY EDMAN.
SCOTT: ANOTHER TAKE AND A
LEADOFF BASE RUNNER.
LET'S STAY ON THE BREWERS WITH
OUR NEXT FULL QUESTION.
IF YOU ARE NEW TO THE PARTY,
LET'S GET YOU INVOLVED.
POST ON YOUR COMPUTER SCREEN,
MOBILE DEVICE, HOWEVER YOU ARE
WATCHING.
FOUR REGULAR SEASON M.V.P.
CANDIDATES FOR MILWAUKEE.
NICE AND SIMPLE HERE.
THE TEAM IS CLOSE TO TAKING THE
DIVISION CROWN.
WHO IS THE REGULAR SEASON TEAM
M.V.P. FOR MILWAUKEE THIS YEAR?
ONE ON FOR GOLDSCHMIDT.
TOM: I DON'T THINK THAT IS
SIMPLE.
TOUGH QUESTION.
REALLY TOUGH.
POSITION PLAYER AGAINST A
STARTING PITCHER, CLOSER.
SCOTT: GOLDSCHMIDT'S BAT IS
BROKEN, AND HE IS DOUBLED UP.
TOM: YOU WANT TO KNOW HOW WELL
HAUSER'S BALL IS MOVING NOW?
HE HAS ALLOWED ONE HIT AND
BROKEN THREE BATS.
YOU CAN TALK ALL YOU WANT ABOUT
STRIKEOUT AND WALKS RATIO.
THE HIT TO BROKEN BAT RATIO
RIGHT NOW IS REALLY GOOD.
SCOTT: 17 DOUBLE PLAYS BEHIND
HAUSER THIS YEAR, HE LEADS THEM
MILWAUKEE PITCHING STAFF.
HELPS TO HAVE KOLTEN WONG, ONE
OF THE BEST IN THE BIZ AT THE
KEYSTONE.
TYLER O'NEILL WITH THE FIRST
PITCH IN FOUL GROUND.
IT WAS THERE FOR EDUARDO
ESCOBAR.
ON HIS SIDE OF THE NETTING.
COULD NOT GET TO IT.
TOM: NOT A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
THERE.
THAT IS A DIFFICULT PLAY WHEN
YOU DON'T HAVE A LOT OF REPS.
TOUGH ANGLE, RIGHT OVER YOUR
HEAD.
HE SAYS I GOT IT, BUT NOT
REALLY.
SCOTT: HE IS PLAYING FIRST BASE
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN THE BIG'S
THIS YEAR.
TWO STRIKES ON TYLER O'NEILL.
IF THIS INNING ENDS QUICK, I
WILL NEED YOUR ANSWER AS
EVERYONE IS VOTING ON YOUTUBE.
WHO IS THE M.V.P. FOR THE
BREWERS?
TOM: I WOULD SAY ADAMES.
HE CHANGES THE TEAM.
EVERY DAY SHORTSTOP.
SCOTT: I AM WITH YOU ON THAT
ONE.
IT IS TOUGH NOT TO GO BURNES, CY
YOUNG CANDIDATE, PROBABLY GOING
TO FINISH ONE OR TWO TOM: TOM:.
HADER IS ONE OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT TO HIT IN BASEBALL.
SCOTT: ADRIAN HOUSER PICKS UP
ANOTHER STRIKEOUT, HIS THIRD OF
THE DAY.
HE IS IN CRUISE CONTROL FOR
MILWAUKEE.
4-0 LEAD THAT WILL CARRY INTO
THE HOME FOURTH.
>> IN THE SPAN OF 23 DAYS IN THE
SUMMER OF 2016, ALEX REYES HAD A
DOCTOR AND MADE HIS MAJOR LEAGUE
DEBUT.
HE WAS ON TOP OF THE WORLD UNTIL
HE WASN'T.
>> SHE JUST HAPPENED TO GET A
LITTLE SICK, COLD, AND MY DOCTOR
WAS NOT EVEN ONE AT THE TIME,
HAS TO PUT UP THIS HUGE FIGHT.
>> THAT WINTER, SHE STARTED
CANCER TREATMENTS.
THAT WINTER, REYES HAD TOMMY
JOHN SURGERY.
>> WATCHING HER FIGHT FOR HER
LIFE DEFINITELY HELPED ME FIGHT
FOR MY CAREER.
>> REYES FOUND COMFORT IN
CONVINCING HIMSELF THAT GOD HAS
A PLAN.
TODAY, THAT'S BEEN UP PART OF
HIS INSTAGRAM BIO AND HE OF
LIFE.
>> THERE WILL BE OBSTACLES THAT
I HAVE TO OVERCOME, BUT THERE IS
LIGHT AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL.
>> IF GOD DID HAVE A PLAN FOR
REYES, IT PROBABLY WOULD LOOK A
LOT LIKE TODAY, NOW A FATHER OF
TWO, A PITCHER WITH PERSPECTIVE.
>> NOT EVERY SITUATION IS THE
WORST SITUATION.
ALWAYS SOMETHING FOR YOU TO
LEARN AND TAKE WHAT IS EVER
THERE TO LEARN FROM THE
EXPERIENCE.
SCOTT: 4-0, BREWERS, BOTTOM FOUR
ARE.
IF YOU ARE WATCHING THE GAME OF
THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE, YOUR
CHOICE OF LISTENING EXPERIENCES
ARE AVAILABLE.
YOU CAN CLICK THE GEAR ICON IN
YOUR PLAYER, CHOOSE AUDIO
TRACKS.
YOU HAVE THE PRIMARY BROADCAST
WITH MYSELF ANTON, BRETT DOLAN.
HOME AND AWAY, RADIO.
YOU WILL NOT MISS A MINUTE OF
THE ACTION.
YOU CAN GO BACK AND FORTH, DO
WHATEVER YOU WANT.
WE ARE AT AMERICAN FAMILY FIELD
FOR A 4-0 GAME THANKS TO TYRONE
TAYLOR'S GRAND SLAM.
TOM: HOW ABOUT CORBIN BURNES'
RADIO?
IS THAT ON THE PRIMARY?
SCOTT: STICK WITH US AND WE WILL
GIVE YOU A LOT OF CORBIN BURNES
CONTENT.
HE CALLED THAT TYRONE TAYLOR
GRAND SLAM.
HE SAID SECOND DECK.
KIND OF.
IT WENT TO THE DECK RIGHT ABOVE
THE BULLPEN.
CLOSE ENOUGH.
TAYLOR IS ON DECK.
THERE IS A CURVEBALL IN THE ZONE
FROM WAINWRIGHT TO URIAS.
TOM: THE LAST OUT IN THE LAST
INNING BEFORE THE BALL LANDED,
WALKED DIRECTLY TO CARLOS TORRES
AND HAD A LONG CONVERSATION WITH
HIM ABOUT THE STRIKE ZONE.
HE STARTS THIS INNING WITH TWO
PITCHES ON THE EDGE OF THE
PLATE, THIS TIME BOTH CALLED
STRIKES.
YADI MOLINA WAS IN ON THAT
CONVERSATION AS WELL.
SCOTT: THAT IS WHERE THE
BASEBALL GOES FOR URIAS.
THEY PLAY HIM STRAIGHT UP.
HORIZONTALLY, YOU ARE NOT
GETTING THAT TODAY.
TOM: A LITTLE LOW.
I GIVE MILWAUKEE A LOT OF
CREDIT.
I TALKED ABOUT HOW AGGRESSIVE
THEY ARE.
THEY SEE A LOT OF PITCHES.
AS A BATTER AND PITCHER, ALL YOU
WANT IS CONSISTENCY WITH THE
STRIKE ZONE.
I THINK WE HAVE HAD THAT
TONIGHT.
SCOTT: SINCE THAT TAYLOR GRAND
SLAM, WAINWRIGHT HAS SAT DOWN
SEVEN IN A ROW.
22 BATTERS SINCE WAINWRIGHT'S
LAST STRIKEOUT.
I THINK MANY ARE ON THE EDGE OF
THEIR SEAT WAITING FOR THAT BIG
NUMBER TO EMERGE.
2-2.
TOM: A GOOD CASE THEY ARE OF
GUYS WORKING TOGETHER, MOLINA
AND WAINWRIGHT, MORE THAN 300
STARTS.
YOU SAW ADAM SHAKE MOLINA.
IT HAPPENS.
SCOTT: I THOUGHT YOU WERE NOT
ALLOWED?
TOM: WHEN YOU ARE A YOUNG
PITCHER.
WHEN YOU HAVE SO MANY OPTIONS
LIKE WAINWRIGHT DOES.
SINKER AWAY.
GOOD EXAMPLE OF THE COMMAND
TODAY OF ADAM WAINWRIGHT.
MISSED CLEARLY ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE PLATE.
SCOTT: HE HAS BUILT UP THAT
COMMAND, COMFORTABLE IN HIS OWN
SKIN.
HE SAYS IT IS COOL TO SAY THAT I
AM ALMOST 40 STINKING YEARS OLD
AND DOING THIS.
AND THAT.
WELCOME TO THE CLUB.
2000 CAREER STRIKEOUTS FOR ADAM
WAINWRIGHT.
AND HE HAS A SEAT NEXT TO BOB
GIBSON AS THE ONLY TWO PITCHERS
IN CARDINALS HISTORY TO PUNCH
OUT 2000.
TOM: AND FITTINGLY, IT WAS UNCLE
CHARLIE, THE CURVEBALL FOR
CAREER STRIKEOUT NUMBER 2000.
HE PROBABLY COULD THROW THAT
BLINDFOLDED.
SCOTT: NOW THE MATCHUP WITH
TAYLOR.
FIRST K OF THE DAY FOR
WAINWRIGHT IS A MAJOR MILESTONE.
AUTHENTICATE THAT.
TAYLOR GETS ANOTHER GOOD RIP.
TYRONE TAYLOR HAS ANOTHER!
WHAT A DAY!
IS THERE A HOME RUN CYCLE,
BECAUSE HE HAS A GRAND SLAM AND
SOLO SHOT IN HIS FIRST TWO
A.B.'S.
5-0, MILWAUKEE.
TOM: GREAT EXAMPLE OF SITTING ON
THAT CURVEBALL, SAT BACK, AND HE
ABSOLUTELY HAMMERED IT.
EXIT VELOCITY THERE AT 103.
SCOTT: THAT WAS OFF LORENZO
CAIN'S FOOT.
LOOKED LIKE IT HURT.
TYRONE TAYLOR WITH HIS SECOND
CAREER MULTI-HOMER GAME.
I MENTIONED A FEW INNINGS AGO,
IT HAS TAKEN SOME TIME TO
DEVELOP, BUT THE BAT HAS BEEN
IMPACTFUL WHEN HE IS IN THERE
FOR MILWAUKEE THIS YEAR.
TOM: STRUCK OUT 2000 WAS ON A
TERRIFIC CURVEBALL, BUT DOWN AND
OUT OF THE ZONE.
THAT WAS JUST A HANGER.
SCOTT: SECOND ROUND PICK BACK IN
2012, TYRONE TAYLOR.
ON A FIVE-GAME REHAB ASSIGNMENT,
NURSING AND OBLIQUE INJURY, IN
TRIPLE-A, HIT SIX 418.
THEY SAID, ALL RIGHT, LET'S
BRING THAT HOT BACK TO THE BIG
LEAGUES.
BACK IN THE LINEUP TODAY AND HE
IS CASHING IN BIG.
ALL FIVE R.B.I.'S ARE HIS.
TOM: THAT GRAND SLAM HE HIT,
ONLY THE FOURTH ALLOWED IN ADAM
WAINWRIGHT'S CAREER.
170 PLATE APPEARANCES.
BASES LOADED.
HAVE A DAY, BY THE FOURTH
INNING.
SCOTT: THE BREWERS ARE FINE IN
THE STANDINGS.
CRAIG COUNSELL REALLY WANTED TO
PICK ME UP.
I AM SWINGING THE BATS WELL.
ONE MAN IS.
CAIN UP THE MIDDLE, TOUGH PLAY
FOR ADMIN.
CAN HE GET HIM?
CAIN IS SAFE.
ADMIN IS VERY SMOOTH AT SECOND,
DID EVERYTHING HE IS SUPPOSED TO
DO, BUT CAIN LEGS OUT A BASE
HIT.
TOM: DID THAT HIT THE BASE?
I DIDN'T THINK HE HAD ANY CHANCE
OF GETTING CAIN, BUT THAT WAS
CLOSE.
IT DID.
BACK TO TAYLOR, I WAS A LITTLE
SURPRISED THAT GARCIA WAS NOT IN
THE STARTING LINEUP TODAY.
HE IS HAVING A GREAT YEAR.
CRAIG COUNSEL EXPLAINED, BACK,
HAMSTRING BARKING ON HIM A
LITTLE BIT, BEING JUDICIOUS WITH
HIS PLAYING TIME.
A CHANCE FOR TAYLOR TO GET IN
THERE.
SCOTT: FIRST PITCH, MANNY PINA.
ADMIN WILL WAIT FOR IT, AND ONE
OF THE EASIER DOUBLE PLAYS TO
TURN.
TYRONE TAYLOR STRIKES AGAIN.
CRAIG COUNSELL CAN SAY I MEANT
TO DO THAT.
I WAS FEELING TYRONE TAYLOR IN
THE LINEUP.
HANGING CURVEBALL.
HE DEPOSITS IT INTO LEFT FOR HIS
SECOND HOME RUN OF THE DAY,
MAKING IT 5-0, BREW CREW.
♪
>> 7-5, COLUMNS, BOTTOM OF THET
NIGHT.
TWO DOWN.
HERE IS THE PITCH.
SWUNG ON FLY BALL, LEFT FIELD.
BRANT BROWN DROPS THE BALL.
PICKS UP THE BALL.
THREE RUNS WILL SCORE.
AND THE BREWERS HAVE BEATEN THE
CUBS.
>> TWO ON, ONE OUT.
SWING AND A DRIVE, CENTER AND
DEEP.
WAY BACK.
GET UP AND GET OUT OF HERE,
GONE!
RYAN BRAUN!
AND THE BREWERS HAVE THE LEAD!
>> ONE BALL, TWO STRIKES ON
PETERSON.
SWING AND A MISS, BALLGAME.
THE BREWERS A MAGIC NUMBER OF
ONE.
THE DIVISION TITLE IS RIGHT IN
FRONT OF THEM.
SCOTT: THE FIFTH.
5-0, MILWAUKEE.
HE IS A BIG DEAL ON YOUTUBE.
HE BEGAN THIS BACK IN 2008.
HE IS HANGING OUT WITH EVERYONE
IN THE LIVE GAME COMMENTARY
SECTION.
C DOES A GREAT JOB POSTING
CONTENT EVERY DAY.
WHICH PLAYER IS THE BREWERS
REGULAR SEASON M.V.P.?
THE WINNER WAS CORBIN BURNES.
WERE YOU SURPRISED THAT ADAMES
DIDN'T GET MORE LOVE?
>> THEY ARE ALL GOOD CHOICES.
IF HE IS GOING TO LEAD OFF EVERY
TIME HE COMES TO THE PLATE, I
WILL TAKE THE OVER.
SCOTT: ADRIAN HOUSER HAS FACED
THE MINIMUM TODAY.
THERE IS ONE MORE OUT.
HE IS HAVING A MAGNIFICENT
AFTERNOON.
TOM:
THEY LOVE HIM AS A LOSING
STREAK STOPPER.
THE SINKER IS DESIGNED TO PITCH
TO CONTACT.
GENERALLY THE BALL IS GOING TO
BE IN PLAY.
IN TODAY'S GAME, THESE ARE THE
TOUGHEST SINKERS TO HIT.
SCOTT: THAT IS A FAIR BALL.
HE IS HEADING FOR TWO, NOW
HEADING FOR THREE.
A ONE-OUT TRIPLE.
TOM: THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN THE
SLIDER THAT JUST KIND OF HUNG IN
THERE.
YOU CAN SEE IT OUT OF THE BOX
RIGHT HERE.
THAT IS ONE OF THE UNDERREPORTED
ASPECTS OF BASEBALL.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DO NOT PAY
ATTENTION TO THAT.
KNOWING HOW THE DEFENSE IS SET
UP.
I'M GOING TO SERVE IT OUT TO
RIGHT FIELD.
AND TAKE WHAT YOU GIVE ME.
THERE IS A LOT OF R.B.I.'S TO BE
HAD THAT WAY.
SCOTT: 18 INNINGS FOR HOUSER
AGAINST THE CARDINALS THIS YEAR,
THAT WAS THE FIRST EARNED RUN
GIVEN UP.
ONLY 55 PITCHES SO FAR TODAY.
HE HAS BEEN ECONOMICAL.
A CHECK OVER TO FIRST AND THEY
GOT HIM.
HEADS UP PLAY.
TOM: HE THOUGHT MAYBE HE WAS
GETTING AWAY.
SCOTT: THAT HIT SOSA.
TOM: THIS GUY GETS HIT BY A LOT
OF PITCHES.
THAT KEPT TARGETING HIM.
SCOTT: 16TH TIME THIS YEAR.
JUST THAT LITTLE SECONDARY READ,
THAT IS ENOUGH TO GET HIM.
HE SAID THAT WAS ONE OF THE BEST
EXTENSIONS.
THE RULE OF THUMB IN BASEBALL
USED TO BE THAT YOU ARE NOT
GETTING A THIRD AT-BAT.
IT HAS BECOME DIFFERENT.
GOOD TAKE BY BADER.
TOM: FULL COUNT.
YOU KNOW WHAT IS COMING HERE.
SCOTT: IT IS A MONEY PITCH
ESPECIALLY TO RIGHT-HANDED
HITTERS.
HE HAS BEEN ON A GREAT RUN WITH
THAT PITCH.
HE IS GOING TO THROW A FASTBALL
ABOUT 70% OF THE TIME.
THEY HAVE SEEN A TON OF THOSE.
THAT ACTUALLY WOUND UP OUT OF
THE ZONE.
SCOTT: THAT WILL BE THE END OF
THE DAY FOR ADAM WAINWRIGHT.
WE WILL HAVE A PINCH IN MATT
CARPENTER.
TOM: HE FOUGHT OFF TO GET TO
THAT ONE.
NICE JOB.
NOW WE HAVE THE OBLIGATORY MOUND
VISIT BECAUSE THERE IS A PINCH
HITTER.
WE REALLY DO NEED TO FIX THESE
RULES.
THESE DO NOT COUNT TO OFFICIAL
LIMIT.
INEVITABLY IT DOES BRING OUT THE
PITCHING COACH.
SCOTT: WHY DOESN'T THE COUNT?
TOM: I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S A LEFTY BAT OFF THE BENCH.
BACK TO THE ACTION.
IT IS BEEN A DOWN SEASON FOR THE
LONGTIME CARDINAL.
ONE OF HIS KNOCKS CAME IN HIS
LAST START.
HE CAME THROUGH WITH A DOUBLE.
TOM: THEY HAVE REALLY ADJUSTED
THEIR DEFENSIVE PHILOSOPHY.
THIS SINKER IS DESIGNED TO GET
CONTACT.
SHIFTS ARE DESIGNED TO DEFEND
HARD-HIT BASEBALLS.
HOUSER IS GOING TO GET A LOT OF
SOFTLY HIT BASEBALLS.
THE NEED FOR A SHIFT IS NOT AS
PREVALENT.
SCOTT: YOU DON'T SEE THAT
EVERYDAY.
THEY ALSO HAVE KOLTEN WONG ON
THE RIGHT SIDE.
TOM: THE OTHER GUYS ALL THROW
MID 90'S.
IT IS A LOT HARDER TO DO.
DID NOT WORK OUT FOR HIM TODAY.
SCOTT: THAT IS WHAT MAKES ADAM
WAINWRIGHT SO AMAZING THIS YEAR.
A BIG SPOT FOR CARPENTER.
THREE HITS AND A RUN IN FOR THE
CARDINALS IN THE DEATH.
THAT IS GOING TO GO TO THE
SEATS.
TOM: IS NOT A BAD IDEA TO RUN
BADER AT FIRST BASE.
YOU COULD TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
AND MAYBE GET A BAG.
I THINK THE BREWERS ARE
DEFENDING THE STOLEN BASE RIGHT
HERE.
HERE WE GO.
NOW IT IS A FULL COUNT.
IF YOU DON'T GET THE RUNNER AT
SECOND, IT COULD COST YOU A RUN.
NOW HE WILL BE OFF AND RUNNING.
SHOULDN'T BE A MYSTERY WHAT IS
COMING HERE.
SCOTT: THAT IS BALL FOUR.
MATT CARPENTER WILL HEAD TO
FIRST.
THE CARDINALS LOAD UP THE BASES.
IN THE PAST ADRIAN HOUSER WOULD
CRUISE AND THEN GET HIT BY ONE
WOBBLY INNING.
MOST OF THAT DAMAGE CAME IN THE
FOURTH INNING.
TOM: THIS IS WHAT I MEAN BY THE
WAY HE MANAGES A GAME.
THE GAME STARTS TO GET A LITTLE
BIT WOBBLY.
YOU HAVE NO SUCH THING AS A
SEVENTH-INNING GUY.
WHO IS MY BEST ARM OTHER THAN MY
CLOSER TO GET OUT OF A JAM?
SCOTT: HE HAS OPTIONS.
THEY PROVIDE VERY UNIQUE LOOKS.
AND A COLLECTIVE BULLPEN IS WHAT
IT IS ALL ABOUT THESE DAYS.
THAT IS CERTAINLY WHAT YOU ARE
LOOKING AT.
THEY ARE ALL AVAILABLE.
HOUSER HAD FACED THE MINIMUM UP
UNTIL THIS INNING.
ANOTHER HIGH PITCH THAT TOMMY
EDMAN CAN'T PLAYOFFS.
HE IS REALLY GOOD WITH TWO
STRIKES.
AND WITH THE BASES LOADED.
TOM: I THINK YOU HAVE TO STAY
WITH THE ELEVATED FASTBALL RIGHT
HERE.
JUST A LITTLE BIT HIGHER.
SCOTT: THE CARGO STRAND THE
BASES LOADED.
THEY DO TAG ON ONE RUN, THEIR
FIRST OF THE DAY.
5-1, MILWAUKEE.
>> HE CRUSHES ONE-OUT TO DEEP
RIGHT.
GONE.
PINCH-HIT TO RUN BOMB.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE HE SMASHED IT.
>> A HIGH FLY BALL OUT TO RIGHT.
HE CAUGHT IT.
HE SAVES THE DAY.
>> HITS IT OUT TO DEEP RIGHT.
LARS NOOTBAAR WITH THE CATCH.
HE ROBS PETE ALONSO.
THE ROOKIE COMES THROUGH.
YOU THINK THOSE GUYS ARE HAVING
A LITTLE FUN?
SCOTT: THE CARDINALS YOUTUBE
PAGES THE BEST PLACE TO GO
BEHIND THE SCENES WITH THE
CARDINALS.
NEVER MISS A VIDEO.
THE ROOF IS CLOSED TODAY IN
MILWAUKEE.
A LITTLE RAIN OUT THERE.
HANGING OUT WITH YOU ON YOUTUBE
AND WE ARE READY FOR A NEW
PITCHER FOR ST. LOUIS.
KIM IN THE GAME.
HE HAS BEEN A RELIEF PITCHER
LATELY.
HE STARTS WITH A PITCH DOWN LOW
TO ADRIAN HOUSER.
HE GROUNDED OUT IN THE SECOND.
GOING RIGHT AFTER HIM.
KIM LAST APPEARED ON SEPTEMBER
14.
HE PICKED UP A SAVE.
HE HAS MADE 21 STARTS THIS YEAR.
HE IS A STRIKE THROWER.
TOM:'S FASTBALL IS A COUPLE OF
TICS UP.
THAT IS TYPICALLY WHAT WE WOULD
SEE FROM HIM.
SCOTT: CLOCKED AT AN AVERAGE OF
89.
THE BREWERS AND THEIR FULL
COUNTS TODAY.
ALL FOUR, A LEADOFF WALK TO THE
PITCHER.
TOM: LET'S GO BACK TO THIS
AT-BAT.
A GREAT JOB OF READING THE
SWINGS.
NEVER GETTING OFF THE
FOUR-SEAMER.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY TIMES THIS
YEAR HE HAS THROWN THAT MANY
FASTBALLS.
THERE IS NO REASON TO GO TO
ANOTHER PITCH.
THAT IS GREAT BASEBALL I.Q.
SCOTT: THERE ARE VERY FEW
SUPERSTARS TO SET YOU UP.
THERE IS A STRIKE.
TOM: HE IS NOT GOING TO THROW
THAT MANY FOUR-SEAM FASTBALLS.
MAYBE A DOZEN.
SCOTT: 2-2.
TOM: THAT IS HIS BEST PITCH,
THAT SLIDER RIGHT THERE.
BREWERS ARE JUST NOT GOING AWAY
TODAY.
THERE HAVE BEEN NO EASY OUTS IN
THIS MILWAUKEE LINEUP.
SCOTT: EVEN THOUGH IT HAS BEEN A
ONE-MAN SHOW.
THESE FEEL LIKE PLAYOFF AT-BATS.
THERE IS ONE.
>> HIS NAME MAY HAVE POPPED ON
YOUR TELEVISION SCREEN THIS WEEK
.
IT WAS A SIMILAR PATH FOR HIM.
HE WAS A STARTING OUTFIELDER ON
A WORLD SERIES TEAM.
A COUPLE OF YEARS LATER HE WAS
IN THE MINORS.
SCOTT: THERE IS A BASE HIT FOR
WILLY ADAMES.
>> IN 2014 HE GOT CALLED UP BY
THE PADRES.
HE WAS 37 YEARS OLD.
HE WAS SEVEN YEARS REMOVED FROM
THE BIG LEAGUES.
MAYBE WE DON'T APPRECIATE HOW
TOUGH IT IS TO GET TO THE
MAJORS.
WE SHOULD ALL APPRECIATE HOW
TOUGH IT IS TO GET BACK SEVEN
YEARS LATER.
SCOTT: I KNOW WHO POPPED BACK UP
IN THE BIG LEAGUES AFTER
SPENDING SOME TIME AS AN
OUTFIELDER AREA HE IS NOW I
BULLPEN MEMBER.
FIRING OVER 100 REGULARLY.
HE TOOK A LOT OF TIME TO DEVELOP
AS A PITCHER.
TOM: HE HAS PRESSURE ON HIM
RIGHT NOW.
THE PITCHER IS AT SECOND BASE.
SCOTT: YELICH IS HITLESS INTO
TRIPS TODAY.
TOM: HE HAS REALLY STRUGGLED ON
BREAKING PITCHES THIS YEAR.
SCOTT: HE HIT IN THE FIVE SPOT
ON MONDAY FOR THE FIRST TIME
THIS SEASON.
THE FIRST TIME BELOW CLEANUP IN
THE ORDER SINCE 2015.
HE IS BACK AT THREE TODAY.
VERY SLOW.
TOM: IT IS HARD TO FATHOM.
WHEN HE IS RIGHT, HE HAS SOME OF
THE BEST BALANCE I HAVE SEEN AT
THE PLATE.
SCOTT: ARE WE USUALLY LOOKING AT
THE TIMING ON A FASTBALL?
TOM: IT COULD BE A LOT OF
THINGS.
I DON'T SEE THE EXPLOSIVENESS.
SCOTT: NOW MAKE IT THREE ON FOR
MILWAUKEE.
TOM: YOU HAD THE GUYS SET UP FOR
IT.
YOU ALWAYS HAVE TO BE CAREFUL IN
THESE SITUATIONS.
STRUGGLING TO THROW A STRIKE.
AS A PITCH RIGHT HERE.
SCOTT: HE IS ONE OF THE BEST AT
LIFTING THE BASEBALL.
HE WALKED AND SCORED IN THE
FIRST.
NOW IN THE FIFTH, LICKING HIS
CHOPS.
NOW BEHIND 0-2.
EDUARDO ESCOBAR A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO HAD 35 HOME RUNS
AND118 RUNS BATTED IN WITH
ARIZONA.
HE THOUGHT ABOUT IT.
1-2.
HE ALSO HAS HIS GAME FACE ON
RIGHT NOW.
NOT A TOUGH CALL FOR THE THIRD
BASE COACH.
THAT WAS RIGHT IN THAT MEDIUM
ZONE.
TOM: NO CHANCE AT ALL WITH THE
PITCHER AT THIRD BASE.
SCOTT: URIAS LOVES THE BASES
LOADED THIS YEAR.
BREWERS WERE ICE COLD IN THE
FIRST THREE IN THIS SERIES.
WHAT YOU SAW RIGHT THERE IS WHAT
THEY ARE DOING BEST TONIGHT.
THAT IS AS GOOD AS IT GETS.
TOM: THAT IS EXCEPTIONAL.
HITTING WITH THE BASES LOADED IS
ABOUT UNDERSTANDING.
MAKE THE PITCHER COME INTO THE
ZONE.
SCOTT: A HALF SWING.
KIM EXTINGUISHES THE THREAT
WITHOUT GIVING OF ANY DAMAGE.
>> HANG ONTO THE ROOF.
>> A FLY BALL.
DEEP LEFT FIELD.
THAT IS GONE!
WILLY ADAMES GOES OPPOSITE FIELD
IN THE NINTH.
BREWERS PLEADED IN COLORADO --
LEAD IT IN COLORADO.
>> SWINGING A DRIVE, DEEP LEFT
FIELD, WE ARE TIED!
WILLY ADAMES STRIKES AGAIN
AGAINST COLORADO.
>> IN THE AIR, RIGHT CENTER.
IT IS UP AND OUT, A GRAND SLAM.
THE FIRST OF THE YEAR 40 BREWERS
.
THIS BALL PARK IS LIT UP.
>> WE DON'T HAVE A GUY THERE.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: CORBIN BURNES WITH HIS
OWN PLAY-BY-PLAY.
TOM: I REMEMBER THE TIME THEY
MADE THE TRADE.
HE COULD POSSIBLY PLAY FIRST.
THEY SAID HE IS A GOOD ATHLETE.
WE WILL FIGURE IT OUT.
SCOTT: ANOTHER POLL QUESTION
COMING AT YOU.
THE M.V.P. IN THE REGULAR SEASON
FOR THE CARDINALS IS?
GOOD LUCK.
TOM VERDUCCI ALWAYS HAS THAT
IMPORTANT JOB.
TOM: I AM NOT SURE ABOUT THIS.
SCOTT: HE HAS BEEN ON A TEAR
RECENTLY.
SCOTT: I CAN SEE YOUR BRAIN
TURNING AS YOU ARE TALKING.
TOM: I WILL GO WITH TYLER
O'NEILL.
YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT TURNED THE
SEASON AROUND.
SCOTT: IT GIVES THEM THREE
INTIMIDATING FORCES IN THE
LINEUP.
TOM: THEY HAVE BEEN RELIABLE.
TOP THREE IN SLUGGING
PERCENTAGE.
SCOTT: GOLDSCHMIDT HAS HIMSELF A
SINGLE.
MILWAUKEE HAD A HISTORIC DAY NOT
TOO LONG AGO.
>> THEY HAD THE COMBINED
NO-HITTER IN CLEVELAND.
THEY WERE HONORED IN FRONT OF
THE HOMETOWN FANS.
THE GLOVE HAS BEEN GREAT.
THAT IS HIS GUIDE.
YELICH RUNS IT DOWN.
I MENTIONED'S FIRST STEP.
HE HAS NOT BEEN MOVING AS WELL.
A GOOD JUMP ON THIS BALL.
DYLAN CARLSON HAS BEEN THE BEST
BAT TODAY FOR ST. LOUIS.
A SINGLE AND A TRIPLE.
HE HAS BEEN SOMEWHAT OF A MENTOR
FOR HIM.
YELICH RIGHT IN FRONT OF THE
TRACK WILL END THIS INNING.
SOME HARD CONTACT.
♪
SCOTT: I THINK NOW IS THE TIME
TO BRING THIS TO YOU.
ALL SEASON LONG WE HAVE GIVEN
YOU THE OPTION AND THE POWER TO
VOTE ON WHO IS THE PLAY OF THE
GAME.
WE WILL HAND OUT THE HARDWARE
RIGHT AFTER THE GAME COMES TO A
CLOSE.
STEPPING INTO LEADOFF THE HOME
SIX IS TYRONE TAYLOR WITH TWO
HOME RUNS IN HIS POCKET.
GARCIA IS GETTING OFF OF HIS
FEET.
TOM: IS THIS KIND OF LIKE THE
BRITISH OPEN?
THIS ONE STATED THE PARK.
SCOTT: HE FLIES OUT ON THE FIRST
PITCH.
TYRONE TAYLOR IS THE LEADER OF
THE PACK FOR NOW.
HE DID SOME DAMAGE TO A COUPLE
OF BASEBALLS EARLIER TODAY.
TOM: ONE ON A CUTTER, ANOTHER ON
A CURVEBALL.
A HANGER RIGHT THERE.
THAT WAS UP THERE FOR A WHILE.
SCOTT: THIS IS HIS THIRD YEAR
THE BIGS.
HE WAS DRAFTED BACK IN 2012.
THE BAT HAS REALLY COME ALONG.
HE DOES A NICE JOB IN ALL THREE
OUTFIELD SPOTS FOR THIS GAME.
TAYLOR WILL BE ON THE PLAYOFF
ROSTER.
2-2.
KIM RINGS HIM UP.
TOM: HE CANNOT BELIEVE IT.
STRIKE.
SCOTT: DIFFERENT PITCH.
TOM: IT WAS NOT THAT HIGH.
THAT IS IN THE AIR TO RIGHT.
IT IS A FAIR BALL.
HE PICKS UP A DOUBLE.
HE HAS HAD A HOT MONTH AND THAT
CONTINUES.
TOM: REALLY NICE JOB TAKING THIS
BALL THE OTHER WAY.
HE LOOKED LIKE HE MIGHT'VE HAD A
CHANCE FOR IT BUT JUST RAN OUT
OF ROOM.
IT IS SO IMPORTANT WHEN YOU ARE
HITTING IN THE NATIONAL LEAGUE.
YOU EXPECT THE BREWERS TO
PINCH-HIT RIGHT HERE.
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR ANOTHER
RUN.
A CHANCE FOR GARCIA TO HIT
AGAINST THE LEFT-HANDER.
SCOTT: A GOOD DAYS WORK FOR
ADRIAN HOUSER.
81 PITCHES.
SIX INNINGS, ONE RUN.
THREE STRIKEOUTS, TWO WALKS.
HE IS PITCHING IN IMPORTANT
SPOT.
MAYBE WE SEE HIM MAKE SOME
STARTS IN OCTOBER FOR MILWAUKEE.
TOM: I THINK HE WOULD HAVE
HOUSER IN THE BULLPEN AVAILABLE
FOR THE FIRST COUPLE OF GAMES.
AND THEN FIGURE OUT WHERE YOU
ARE IF YOU GET TO A GAME FOUR.
HE WOULD HAVE NO PROBLEM GOING
TO HOUSER.
HE PITCHED SO WELL AGAINST ST.
LOUIS THIS YEAR.
A GOOD EXAMPLE OF WHY HE IS IN
ATTACK MODE.
CONTROLLING COUNTS.
SCOTT: THROWING THE BASEBALL
WITH A LOT OF CONFIDENCE LATELY.
HE DID MISS SOME TIME.
LOWER BACK SPASMS.
HE CAME BACK ON MONDAY.
TOM: ANOTHER GUY WHOSE POWER HAS
PLAYED UP THIS YEAR.
HE HAS MADE SOME ADJUSTMENTS TO
GET SOME MORE BACKSPIN ON THE
BASEBALL.
HE DOES NOT TURN OVER THROUGH
CONTACT.
SCOTT: ON THE GROUND, EDMAN WILL
HANDLE IT.
GARCIA HAD BEEN A CARDINAL
PRESSURE -- CRUSHER.
THE SIXTH INNING IS OVER.
>> IT HAS NEVER BEEN DONE BEFORE
WHERE A CLUB HAS FALLEN BEHIND
IN THE FIRST TWO GAMES BUT THEN
CAME BACK TO WIN IT.
>> THE STADIUM WAS ROCKING THAT
NIGHT.
>> THE AMERICAN LEAGUE
CHAMPIONSHIP ON THE LINE.
>> GOT THE BASES LOADED.
CECIL COOPER HITTING.
>> OPPORTUNITY STARING HIM IN
THE FACE.
>> BASE HIT TO LEFT FIELD.
ONE RUN HOME.
HE IS SAFE.
BREWERS LEAD 4-3.
>> WITHOUT QUESTION, THE BIGGEST
MOMENT IN MY LIFE.
>> AND SO IT CAME DOWN TO A
FUTURE HALL OF FAMER AGAINST A
NEWLY CHRISTENED CLOSER.
WHAT A POETIC WAY TO REACH THE
WORLD SERIES.
>> IT IS OVER!
THE BREWERS HAVE WON THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE PENNANT.
SCOTT: SEASON TWO IS LIVE ON
YOUTUBE WITH NEW EPISODES EVERY
WEEK.
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE GAME YOU
LOVE.
MLB CELEBRATES HISPANIC HERITAGE
MONTH BY RECOGNIZING THE
CONTRIBUTIONS MADE TO OUR GAME.
SOME SUNSHINE PEEKING IN THROUGH
A CLOSED UP BALLPARK.
WE ARE CLOSING UP OUR THIRD POLL
QUESTION.
THE CARDINALS REGULAR SEASON
M.V.P. ACCORDING TO THE PEOPLE
IS ARENADO.
THE NEW MEMBER, THE BIG
OFF-SEASON ADD.
HE BEATS OUT GOLDIE, WAINWRIGHT,
AND O'NEILL.
ARENADO SOLIDIFIES THE DEFENSE.
GIVES THEM ANOTHER AIRCRAFT
CARRIER IN THE LINEUP.
THERE IS A NEW PITCHER IN THE
GAME FOR MILWAUKEE.
SOME WARM-UP TOSSES FOR JAKE
COUSINS.
NOW A MEETING AND A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE GLOVE.
TOM: IT MIGHT BE THE COLOR OF
THE GLOVE.
SCOTT: IS IT TO LIGHT -- TOO
LIGHT?
TOM: YES, IT IS VERY LIGHT.
YOU TYPICALLY WOULD NOT SEE A
WHITE GLOVE.
IT CAN BE A DISTRACTION.
SO THE GLOVE GOT EJECTED.
SCOTT: YOU ARE OUT OF HERE.
YOU LOOK TOO MUCH LIKE THE
BASEBALL.
TOM: THAT WILL WORK.
HOW ABOUT CORBIN BURNES?
EQUIPMENT MANAGER.
SCOTT: THERE IS AN ADVANTAGE FOR
A BASEBALL IS COMING OUT OF THE
WHITE GLOVE.
YOU WATCH WHAT JAKE COUSINS HAS
BEEN DOING GREATLY -- LATELY.
TOM: I WOULD NOT CALL IT
GAMESMANSHIP.
WE HAVE RULES AGAINST THOSE
THINGS.
THIS GLOVE LOOKS A LOT SMALLER.
SCOTT: HE HAS BEEN USING THAT
OTHER GLOVE ALL YEAR.
HE USED IT LAST NIGHT.
YOU KNOW SOMETHING THAT SEEMS
LITTLE LIKE THAT IS GOING TO
FIRE UP THE BREWERS, ESPECIALLY
THE PITCHING STAFF.
WHEN YOU HAVE BEEN ROCKING THE
SAME GLOVE.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE IS
SUPERSTITIOUS.
HE HAS MADE A BIG-TIME COMEBACK
IN HIS CAREER.
THAT LOOKS LIKE THE SAME
SUSPECT.
TOM: THE CARDINALS WERE LIKE,
THIS GUY IS TOO DIFFICULT TO
HIT.
LET'S SEE IF SOMETHING ELSE
WORKS.
I DON'T THINK CHANGING GLOVES IS
GOING TO BOTHER HIM.
THIS WAS A 20TH ROUND DRAFT PICK
BY THE WASHINGTON NATIONALS.
A COUPLE OF YEARS LATER, AFTER A
BUNCH OF ARM INJURIES, THEY
RELEASED HIM.
HE WANTED TO QUIT BASEBALL.
STILL A YOUNG MAN BUT HE WAS
BEATEN DOWN BY INJURIES.
IT WAS HIS FAMILY WHO BASICALLY
SAID LET'S GIVE IT ONE MORE
SHOT.
ONE OF THE PIECES OF ADVICE HE
GOT WAS FROM HIS COUSIN, KIRK
COUSINS.
HE BASICALLY SAID 20 YEARS FROM
NOW YOU WILL SAY YOU WISH YOU
QUIT BASEBALL SOONER.
THAT WHIFF RATE IS ALMOST
ENTIRELY BUILT ON A NASTY
SLIDER.
SCOTT: THAT IS WHY THERE IS NOW
A BIG THREE IN THIS BULLPEN.
CATCHES THE CORNER.
TOM: YOU SEE WHERE HE SETS UP ON
THE RUBBER.
IT ALL SEEMS TO BE COMING FROM
BEHIND YOUR BACK.
SCOTT: 96.
HE CHALLENGES MOLINA AND WINS
IT.
TOM: THAT IS JUST FILTHY.
ESPECIALLY TO RIGHT-HANDED
HITTERS.
CREATING THAT ANGLE BY THE WAY
HE POSITIONS HIMSELF ON THE
RUBBER.
THAT IS 96.
MOST OF THE FOOTPRINTS ON THE
MOUND ARE A DIRECT LINE TO HOME
LATE.
HE STEPS IN A PLACE THAT IS
FRESH DIRT.
SCOTT: SOSA, FIRST PITCH, TAKES
A HOT PASS.
A ONE-OUT SINGLE.
TOM: HE WAS NOT BOTHERED BY THAT
ANGLE AT ALL.
GOT THE FIRST PITCH SLIDER AND
DID NOT WAIT AROUND RID YOU SEE
WHERE ADONIS -- ADAMES IS
PLAYING.
SCOTT: CLASSY GUY OVER THERE AT
SHORT.
HARRISON BADER WITH ONE ON.
TOM: I SHOULD ADD THAT WHEN HE
DECIDED TO KEEP PITCHING, HE HAD
TO GO TO COMPETITIVE BALL.
THAT WAS HIS WAY BACK TO THE BIG
LEAGUES.
SCOTT: WHAT A PATH.
WHAT A MOTIVATIONAL SPEAKER TO
HAVE.
AN NFL QUARTERBACK AS YOUR
COUSIN.
SETTING YOU UP WITH SOME
BIG-LEAGUE ADVICE.
27 YEARS OLD IN HIS ROOKIE
SEASON.
IT HASN'T HAPPENED YET, BUT THE
BREWERS SHOULD BE ON THEIR WAY
TO CLENCHING THEIR SECOND
DIVISION TITLE IN THE PAST FOUR
YEARS.
THEY HAVE SECURED A FOURTH
CONSECUTIVE POSTSEASON.
ONE OF THE BEST STRATEGISTS.
A BASE ON BALLS FOR HARRISON
BADER.
LET ME TAKE YOU BACK TO
YESTERDAY.
YOU DON'T SEE THIS EVERY DAY,
BUT YOU APPRECIATE IT.
THIS IS HARD HIT OFF THE BAT OF
O'NEILL.
GREAT CATCH BY LORENZO CAIN BUT
HE FALLS, TOOK TOSS TO GARCIA TO
TRY AND GET BADER AT NOT THIRD,
BUT SECOND.
HE SCORES ON A SAC FLY.
TWO R.B.I. SAC FLY FOR THE
CARDINALS YESTERDAY, AND CLASSIC
ST. LOUIS CARDINALS OFFENSE.
TOM: DOESN'T GET A LOT OF
ATTENTION, BUT THIS CARDINAL
TEAM IS EXCELLENT AT
BASERUNNING.
TOMMY EDMAN, THE BEST IN
BASEBALL GOING FIRST TO THIRD.
I LOOK AT GOLDSCHMIDT AND NOLAN
ARENADO, TWO SUPERSTARS, WHO ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY EXPERT BASE
RUNNERS.
YOU WATCH THAT WAY THEY REACT,
THE WAY THEY CUT THE CORNERS ON
THE BASES, TEXTBOOK.
THIS IS SOMETHING WHERE YOU HAVE
TO PAY ATTENTION TO BASERUNNING.
IT HAS TO BE A PRIORITY.
SCOTT: PILE ON FOR US.
BRETT: I LOVE THAT LINE AS FAR
AS THE SPECIAL OF BASEBALL
DEFENSE AND BASERUNNING.
WENT ON TO SAY, WHEN YOU HAVE
GUYS THAT LOVE TO COMPETE, THEY
WANT TO BE GOOD AT THE LITTLE
THINGS.
THE OTHER LINE I LOVE WAS KEEP
THE ROUTINES FRESH.
THEY TRY AND SPRINKLE THEM UP.
THESE GUYS LOVE TO PLAY THE GAME
AND IT CERTAINLY SHOWS.
SCOTT: THERE ARE SOME EXCELLENT,
WISE EXAMPLE SETTERS OUT THERE
AS WELL.
IF MOLINA IS OUT THERE THE DAY
AFTER A NIGHT GAME TAKING GROUND
BALLS AT SECOND ON THE FIELD
EARLY.
TOM: BEFORE THIS WORD EXISTENT
-- EXISTED, I LEARNED ABOUT THE
POWER OF THE WORD INFLUENCERS.
NOT ON YOUTUBE, BUT IN BASEBALL.
I GO BACK TO THE MINNESOTA TWINS
, 1980'S.
KIRBY PUCKETT RAN HARD EVERY
TIME.
BEST PLAYER ON THE TEAM.
YOU BETTER BE DOING THE SAME
THING THE BEST PLAYER ON THE
TEAM IS DOING.
THAT HAPPENS IN ST. LOUIS WITH
NOLAN ARENADO AND GOLDSCHMIDT.
IT JUST BECOMES A PRIORITY.
I DON'T EVEN THINK MIKE SHILDT
HAS TO REMIND HIS PLAYERS ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF BASERUNNING AT
THIS POINT.
IT IS PART OF THEIR DNA SCOTT:.
THIS BUNCH IS LOCKED INTO THE
GAME ON A DAILY BASIS.
THEY HAVE WON 11 IN A ROW.
IT IS A BIG CHANCE FOR THEM TO
CAPITALIZE AS YOU FIGURE DEVIN
WILLIAMS IN THE EIGHTH, JOSH
HADER IN THE NINTH.
THAT HAS BEEN THE SCRIPT THIS
YEAR.
TOM: IF YOU LOOK IN THE DUGOUT
AND SEE HOW MANY GUYS ARE IN THE
FRONT ROW, I LOVE TO SEE THAT.
5-1 BALLGAME, THEY ARE IN IT.
SCOTT: AND ANOTHER WALK.
BASES FULL OF CARDINALS WITH
JUST ONE OUT IN THE SEVENTH.
HERE COMES CRAIG COUNSELL.
THAT WILL BE BRAD BOXBERGER.
THE INNING STARTED OFF NICELY
FOR JAKE COUSINS.
HE FOOLED YADI MOLINA.
SOSA WENT AFTER THE FIRST PITCH
FOR A SINGLE, THEN BACK-TO-BACK
WALKS AND THE DAY IS DONE FOR
THE ROOKIE.
VETERAN BRAD BOXBERGER, FORMER
CLOSER, WILL ENTER THE MIX.
A BIG SPOT FOR ST. LOUIS TO KEEP
THAT 11 GAME ARE ALIVE.
>> MILWAUKEE THE SAME FOR GAME
THREE IN THE 1982 WORLD SERIES
AND THE FIFTH INNING OF THE
SCORELESS TIE.
HIT HIGH AND DEEP TO RIGHT
FIELD.
>> HOME RUN, WILLIE MCGEE.
>> THE CARDINALS JUMP IN FRONT,
3-0.
THAT IS TWO FOR MCGEE, ANOTHER
HOMER.
WE GO TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
SEVENTH INNING.
5-1 ST. LOUIS.
>> BASE HIT, RIGHT FIELD.
ONE RUN IS IN, TWO RUNS ARE IN.
BASE HIT.
THE BREWERS WILL TAKE THE LEAD.
>> AND THEY ARE WILD IN
MILWAUKEE.
>> 7-5 FINAL SCORE AND ALL EVEN
AT TWO APIECE.
>> MOLITOR GETS ONE OUT IN THE
AIR, DOUBLE PLAY.
>> TO RIGHT CENTER, WHAT AN
OUTSTANDING PLAY.
WELL HIT RIGHT, HOME RUN.
LEFT FIELD, THIS COULD BE IT.
THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS TAKE THE
LEAD AND WE GO BACK TO ST.
LOUIS.
>> IT'S THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
LIVE ON YOUTUBE PRESENTED BY JIM
BEAM.
SCOTT BRAUN, TOM VERDUCCI, BRETT
OWN IN MILWAUKEE FOR THE
CARDINALS AND THE BREWERS.
THE ROBERTO CLEMENTE AWARD
RECOGNIZES ONE PLAYER WHO BEST
REPRESENTS THE GAME THROUGH
POSITIVE CONTRIBUTIONS ON AND
OFF THE FIELD.
GO TO MLB.COM/CLEMENTE 21.
TOP OF THE ORDER, IT IS EDWIN
WITH GOLDSCHMIDT ON DECK AND THE
BASES ARE FULL OF CARDINALS HERE
IN THE SEVENTH.
BREWERS FIVE, ST. LOUIS ONE,
BRAD BOXBERGER IN THE GAME.
HE HAS HAD A NICE SEASON FOR
MILWAUKEE.
BIG STRIKEOUT NUMBERS.
I WANT TO POINT OUT ONE MORE
TIME, JAKE COUSINS WALKED A
COUPLE IN A ROW.
THEY HAD THE GLOVE SWITCH.
SOCIAL MEDIA IS BUZZING A LITTLE
BIT.
MAYBE THREW HIM OFF HIS GAME A
LITTLE BIT?
TOM: I WOULDN'T GO THAT FAR.
BOXBERGER IS IN BECAUSE LAST
TIME HAUSER GOT EDMUND OUT ON
THE FOUR-SEAM FASTBALLS UP.
BOXBERGER ALSO HAS A SLIDER AND
CHANGEUP, BUT I WOULD EXPECT
ELEVATED FOUR-SEAMERS.
HE IS NOT A GROUND BALL PITCHER.
CHANGEUP RIGHT THERE TO START.
HE'S THINKING ABOUT A DOUBLE
PLAY.
HE'S THROWN ONLY ONE DOUBLE PLAY
BALL THIS YEAR.
IN THE MAJOR LEAGUES, YOU HAVE
AN 11% CHANCE OF GETTING A
DOUBLE PLAY IN ORDER.
TWO PERCENT FOR BOXBERGER THIS
YEAR.
SCOTT: FLY BALL PITCHER ON THE
MOUND.
GOT TWO STRIKES ON ADMIN.
I CAN'T TALK YOU INTO THESE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
TOM: I'M NOT BIG ON THOSE.
I DID NOT SEE COUSINS PROTEST AT
ALL, I DID NOT SEE ANY AUDIO
LANGUAGE THAT TOLD ME HE WAS OUT
OF SORTS.
HE DID PUNCH OUT THE FIRST
BATTER.
SCOTT:.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
I TRIED.
CONTACT, RIGHT SIDE.
THERE IS ONE AT SECOND.
BACK TO FIRST AND SAFE.
A RUN IS IN AND IT IS 5-2.
SOSA WILL STEP ON HOME PLATE ONE
MORE TIME TO MAKE SURE HE'S GOT
IT, AND THE INNING STAYS ALIVE.
R.B.I. GROUND OUT FOR ADMIN, HIS
TREAT -- HIS TEAM TRAILS BY
THREE.
TOM: YOU SAW HIM FLATTEN OUT THE
STROKE.
IT WAS THE FOUR-SEAM FASTBALL.
HE RUNS SO WELL.
IT IS HARD TO TURN TO ON THIS
BALL UNLESS IT IS DIRECTLY OUT
OF MIDDLE INFIELD.
THE BREWERS MADE IT CLOSE.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
[LAUGHTER]
I SAW SOSA.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER HE MISSED
THE FIRST TIME, BUT HE WENT BACK
TO TOUCH IT.
HE WAS WATCHING LIKE THE REST OF
US AT FIRST.
SCOTT: IT IS THE JUST IN CASE
TAP.
TOM: I KIND OF LIKE WHEN YOU
HAVE THE REMOTE CONTROL IN YOUR
CAR DOOR AND YOU PARK IT AND
LOCK IT AND FIVE SECONDS LATER,
DID I LOCK IT?
HIT IT AGAIN.
JUST IN CASE.
SCOTT: I AM BIG ON THAT.
THE SUN IS SHINING BRIGHT
THROUGH THE WINDOW PANELS HERE
AT AMERICAN FAMILY FIELD.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT WILL PHASE
PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT.
GOLDIE AND ARENADO HAVE
VIDEOGAME NUMBERS IN THIS
BALLPARK.
TOM: RIGHT NOW, THE LIGHTING FOR
THE HITTER SHOULD BE OK.
WHEN YOU GET THE SHADOWS, GOING
DARK TO LIGHT OR VICE VERSA, IT
CREATES DIFFICULTY.
THE SUN JUST APPARENTLY WENT
BEHIND A CLOUD NOW.
SCOTT: THE SON HEARD US.
TOM: EITHER THAT OR THE ROOF
OPENS AND CLOSES FASTER THAN I
THOUGHT.
SCOTT: THAT WOULD BE REALLY
QUICKLY.
TWO ON FOR GOLDIE.
POPPED BACK.
HE SENT ONE VERY FAR IN THE
OTHER DIRECTION LAST NIGHT.
STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE
CLOUD.
433 FEET, THE SEVENTH LONGEST
HOME RUN FOR HIM THIS SEASON.
LOOK AT THE DISTANCE.
YOU DON'T SEE BASEBALLS GO THAT
FAR VERY OFTEN IN THIS BALLPARK.
GOLDIE LOOKING FOR A
SPONSORSHIP.
TOM: HE'S HITTING THE BALL HARD
THIS YEAR.
HIS EXIT VELO BEEN THE HIGHEST
THIS YEAR SINCE 2015.
THE SEVENTH BIGGEST JUMP, THE
JUMP IN EXIT VELO.
SCOTT: IT WAS MILLER TIME LAST
NIGHT FOR GOLDIE.
HE LOVES THIS BALLPARK, TOO.
TOM: THERE YOU GO, THOSE ARE THE
NUMBERS TO PROVE IT.
TWO CARDINALS IN THE TOP FOUR OF
ALL TIME O.P.S. RIGHT HERE IN
MILWAUKEE.
LET'S SEE IF BOXBERGER STICKS
WITH THE SLIDER.
I THINK HE WOULD.
MUCH BETTER FASTBALL AND
OFFSPEED HITTER THAN HE IS ON
THE BREAKING BALL.
CLICK TO THE CHANGEUP.
SCOTT: INSTEAD, A TRY AT FIRST
AND A RUN COMES IN!
.
ADMIN HOPS TO SECOND AND THE
TEAM KNOWN FOR ITS BASERUNNING
CREATES A RUN JUST FROM THAT.
TOM: THAT'S A GOOD CALL.
IF YOU ARE BOXBERGER, TWO OUTS,
TWO STRIKES, CONTROLLING THE
COUNT, WHY ARE YOU EVEN THROWING
TO FIRST BASE?
THAT IS NOT CALLED FOR.
BUT IF YOU WORRY ABOUT THE
CARDINALS RUNNING GAME, YOU MAKE
A THROW YOU SHOULDN'T MAKE.
SCOTT: THAT KICKED OFF ADMIN.
IT WAS WELL OFF THE MARK.
ONE IN NOW AND ONE ON.
2-2 IS THE COUNT TO GOLDSCHMIDT.
TWO RUNS COMING IN FOR THE
CARDINALS.
TOM: I WOULD BE CAREFUL ON
FASTBALLS HERE.
GOLDSCHMIDT IS A GREAT FASTBALL
HITTER THE OTHER WAY.
SCOTT: HE'S GOING TO LEFT
CENTER.
GOLDSCHMIDT WALLOPED THAT ONE!
AND WE ARE TIED.
NUMBER 28 ON THE SEASON, THEY
HAVE COME STORMING BACK.
THIS TEAM IS DANGEROUS.
PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT POWERS UP FOR
TWO AND THE CARDINALS EVEN THE
SCORE AT 5-5.
TOM:TOM: I JUST WASN'T IN LOVE
WITH THE SEQUENCE THROWING BACK
TO FIRST BASE.
GOLDSCHMIDT IS A POINT TO 19
HITTER AGAINST BREAKING BALLS,
MUCH MORE POWER AND DANGER
AGAINST FASTBALLS.
YOU CAN STAY WITH THAT PITCH,
STILL 2-2.
THAT FASTBALL GOT TOO MUCH OF
THE PLATE.
THERE ARE CERTAIN HITTERS THAT
NEVER COME OFF THE FASTBALL,
GOLDSCHMIDT IS ONE OF THEM.
SCOTT: THIS TEAM IS FEELING IT.
UNFAZED, FIVE UNANSWERED RUNS.
GOLDIE HAS DONE THAT 16 TIMES IN
THIS BALLPARK.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN MANY OF THOSE
SWINGS FROM TYLER O'NEILL.
TOM: I WAS THINKING THE SAME
THING.
HE JUST DID NOT TRACK THAT
SLIDER.
HE HAS DEFINITELY COME BACK WITH
IT AGAIN.
SCOTT: THE SUNSHINE IS BACK.
TOM:.
THE PREVIOUS ONE JUST LOOKS LIKE
HE DID NOT TRACK AT ALL.
SCOTT: O'NEILL, 1-3 TODAY WITH A
COUPLE STRIKEOUTS.
EVEN COUNT.
TOM: HE'S THINKING ONE MORE
BATTER PROBABLY RIGHT HERE.
SCOTT: A BOTTLE -- BATTLE IN THE
SEVENTH.
PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT THE RESCUE.
A FOUR RUN SEVENTH FOR ST.
LOUIS.
THIS WAS 5-0 MILWAUKEE AT ONE
POINT.
TYRONE TAYLOR WITH TWO HOME
RUNS.
GOLDIE HAS ONE, A TWO RUN SHOT
AND A 5-5 CONTEST ON YOUTUBE IN
MILWAUKEE BETWEEN TWO OF THE
BEST IN BASEBALL.
>> BUSCH STADIUM IN ST. LOUIS.
THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS JUST ONE
GAME AWAY FROM THE CHAMPIONSHIP.
>> DIV -- DRIVEN TO DEEP RIGHT
FIELD.
MCGEE IS AROUND THIRD.
>> THERE IS DARRELL PORTER.
ONE BALL, ONE STRIKE AND A HIGH
DRIVE, DEEP RIGHT.
>> ST. LOUIS CARDINALS ARE ALIVE
AND WELL.
>> THE WORLD SERIES IS TIED AT
3-3.
THEY ARE READY AND ST. LOUIS FOR
GAME SEVEN AND NOW IT CULMINATES
FOR BASEBALL'S CHAMPIONSHIP.
BOTTOM OF THE SIXTH INNING OF
THIS WORLD SERIES.
>> HIT TO RIGHT CENTER, BASE
HIT.
THE GAME IS TIED.
LINED INTO RIGHT FIELD, 4-3 ST.
LOUIS.
>> THE WHOLE CITY OF ST. LOUIS
COLLECTIVELY HOLDING ITS BREATH.
>> THAT IS A WINNER.
A WORLD SERIES WINNER FOR THE
CARDINALS.
TOM: CHECK OUT THE BREWERS
YOUTUBE PLAYS -- PAGE.
SUBSCRIBE SO YOU NEVER MISS A
VIDEO.
AND GOOGLE CLOUD IS HELPING
POWER STATCAST WITH MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF DATA POINTS TO REVEAL
NEW INSIGHTS TAKING YOU DEEPER
INTO THE GAME.
THE OFFICIAL CLOUD TECHNOLOGY OF
MAJOR LEAGUE TIED AT 5-5.
FINISHING UP A FOUR GAME SET
BETWEEN THE BREWERS AND
CARDINALS.
THESE TEAMS MATCHING UP 10 TIMES
THIS MONTH.
THEY WILL HAVE THREE MORE IN ST.
LOUIS TO FINISH UP THE SERIES.
T.J. MCFARLAND IS IN THE GAME
FOR ST. LOUIS.
ONE OF THE BIG MONEY PICKUPS.
AS YOU CAN SEE, THE NUMBERS HAVE
BEEN MAGNIFICENT FOR HIM THIS
YEAR AND HE RELIES ON HIS
DEFENSE.
THE CARDINALS HAVE THE BEST
DEFENSE IN BASEBALL, SO THAT
WORKS.
TOM: ONLY SIX WALKS AS WELL SO
IN NICE LITTLE POCKET RIGHT
HERE.
YELICH, LEFT-HANDED.
DUE UP THIRD.
SCOTT: THAT IS TAILOR-MADE FOR
TOMMY EDMAN.
ON TO ADAMES.
TYRONE TAYLOR HAS HAD A HUGE
GAME.
HE HELPED THIS TEAM GET UP TO A
5-0 START BUT THE REST OF THE
OFFENSE HAS BEEN ICE COLD.
THEY HAVE DROPPED THE FIRST
THREE GAMES AGAINST ST. LOUIS.
IF NOT FOR TYRONE TAYLOR, THAT
WOULD BE THE STORY.
TOM: YOU HAVE TO APPLAUD THEIR
APPROACH TONIGHT, I THINK THE
BATS HAVE BEEN BETTER.
A COUPLE WALKS PRECEDED THE
GRAND SLAM.
SCOTT: STILL NOT A TON OF HARD
CONTACT, THOUGH.
TOM: NO.
I JUST KNOW IF I AM AN
INFIELDER, I WOULD LOVE TO PLAY
FOR THE CARDINALS.
THEY DON'T SHIFT A LOT AND THE
PITCHERS DON'T STRIKEOUT A LOT
OF BATTERS.
THE BALL IS IN PLAY.
WE ARE SEEING THAT TODAY.
YOU ARE ON YOUR TOES IF YOU ARE
A CARDINALS INFIELDER.
SEE WHERE WILLY ADAMES HITS THE
BALL.
SCOTT: AND YOU ARE LIKELY
STANDING NEXT TO A GOLD GLOVER.
OR PERHAPS A FUTURE GOLD GLOVER.
THEY ARE LOADED IN THAT
CATEGORY.
TOM: TO DRIVE HOME THE POINT, I
LIKE TO LOOK AT BATTING AVERAGE
ON BALLS IN PLAY, ESPECIALLY THE
SEASON.
CARDINALS NUMBER TWO IN
BASEBALL.
THE DODGERS ARE NUMBER ONE.
SCOTT: ADAMES UP THE MIDDLE,
BASE HIT.
HE LIKES THE 1-2 PITCH, AND HE
IS ABOARD.
TOM: THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT
TO HAVE GOOD BALANCE IN YOUR
LINEUP.
HAD A GOOD SWING AT THAT SINKER.
SCOTT: LEFTY ON 112.5 OFF THE
BAT FOR ADAMES.
I THINK HE HEARD THAT LOUD
CONTACT LINE.
CARDINALS ARE BEST AN AVERAGE
DEFENSIVE RUNS SAVED AND ALL OF
THOSE METRICS.
THEY ARE NUMBER ONE AS A TEAM.
NICE PITCH FOR MCFARLANE.
TOM: FIRST PITCH SINKER FOR A
STRIKE.
HE'S THINKING, I SEE THE
BREAKING BALL, LEFT ON LEFT.
GOOD WAY TO JUMP AHEAD IN THE
COUNT.
SCOTT: EXTRA PAUSE FROM YADI.
[LAUGHTER]
WE SEE YOU.
THERE ARE VERY FEW ON THE PLANET
THAT LOVE BASEBALL LIKE YADI
MOLINA.
PERHAPS A LITTLE INNER RANGE.
GOOD WITH FROM YELICH.
TOM: I WOULD EXPECT ANOTHER
BREAKING BALL HERE.
THE CARDINALS DON'T SHIFT A LOT.
THEY ARE 25TH AND THE PERCENTAGE
OF SHIFTS THEY USE.
THEY ARE SHIFTING ON CHRISTIAN
YELICH.
SCOTT: HE HAS ROLLED OVER MANY
BREAKING BALLS.
TOM: EXACTLY.
HE STRUGGLED AGAINST THEM THIS
YEAR AND THAT IS PART OF IT, THE
ROLLOVERS, BEING OUT FRONT ON
THE BREAKING BALLS.
SCOTT: THAT MEANS GROUND BALL
RIGHT SIDE.
HE IS PULLING IT.
THAT IS HOW THE CARDINALS SET
HIM UP.
CHRISTIAN DOESN'T SUGARCOAT
THINGS.
HE KNOWS THIS HAS NOT BEEN HIS
BEST YEAR.
AT THE END OF LAST SEASON, HE
SAID "ALL AROUND TERRIBLE" WHEN
HE WAS SUMMING UP WHAT HE DID AT
THE PLATE.
THIS HAS NOT COME AROUND FOR HIM
YET.
DIFFICULT PAST COUPLE OF SEASONS
FOR HIM NOW.
TOM: LAST YEAR WAS DIFFICULT FOR
A LOT OF REALLY GOOD HITTERS.
BECAUSE OF THE SHORT NATURE, THE
WEIRD NATURE OF SPRING TRAINING.
BUT THIS YEAR, JUST NEVER GOT ON
TRACK.
SCOTT: AND LOOK AT WHERE HIS
TEAM IS WITHOUT HIM BEING M.V.P.
TOM: THAT SINKER NEVER ON THE
PLATE, CHASED SWING WITH TWO
STRIKES, NOT A GOOD PASS AT THE
BASEBALL.
ALMOST AN EMERGENCY SWING TO
PROTECT ON A PITCH THAT IS
REALLY NOT THAT CLOSE.
THREE FOR HIS LAST 37.
SCOTT: WE WILL SEE WHAT ESCOBAR
CAN DO.
HITLESS TODAY, HE WALKED AND
SCORED.
WHAT A TURNAROUND IN THIS ONE,
AFTER A GRAND SLAM FROM TYRONE
TAYLOR IN THE FIRST INNING OFF
ADAM WAINWRIGHT.
SMALL SAMPLE, BUT GOOD RESULTS
FOR ESCOBAR AGAINST MCFARLAND.
TOM: TWO OUTS, TIE GAME,
DEFENDING A RUNNER AT FIRST WITH
A CARDINALS OUTFIELD.
BADER AT CENTER FIELD PLAYS ONE
OF THE MOST SHALLOW CENTER
FIELD'S.
THEY DON'T GIVE UP A SINGLE
DEFENDING THE RUNNER ON FIRST.
SCOTT: ESCOBAR GOES TO BADER.
FANCY FOOTWORK, MOVING OVER LIKE
AN AGILITY DRILL.
I'M SURE HE CAN CATCH A
FOOTBALL.
5-5 THROUGH SEVEN.
>> FRESH BIRD DOING A LITTLE
FISHING TODAY IN BIG MAC LAND.
HAS HE FORGOTTEN ALL HIS ANIMAL
INSTINCTS?
DID I TELL YOU ABOUT THE GIFT
FRED BYRD GAVE ME A COUPLE YEARS
BACK?
>> NO.
>> HE SOWED ME A NICE SWEATER.
LIKE THE CHRISTMAS ONES THAT
HAVE REINDEER ALL OVER?
IT'S LIKE THAT BUT WITH FRED
BYRD.
>> WHAT WILL HE DO TODAY?
HE'S VACUUMING THE CARDBOARD
CUTOUTS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> HE FIGURED, I HAVE TO GET MY
CHORES DONE.
>> LAST NIGHT, IT WAS THE
IRONING BOARD AND TONIGHT HE IS
BIRDWATCHING.
CLICKS HE'S A BIRDER.
WHO WOULD'VE THOUGHT IT?
>> HE'S GOT SOMETHING NEW EVERY
GAME AND TONIGHT, APPARENTLY HE
IS BACK TO SCHOOL AND IT LOOKS
LIKE HE IS VIRTUALLY LEARNING.
AND YES, THAT IS FRED BYRD, AND
I DO BELIEVE THAT IS TIGER KING.
[LAUGHTER]
VERY APPROPRIATE.
>> THAT MIGHT BE HIS BEST ONE
YET.
TOM: LET'S GO BACK TO THE
SEVENTH INNING.
HOW CLOSE STOOD MILWAUKEE COME
TO GETTING THE LEAD?
THIS TIME, THEY THOUGHT THEY
MIGHT GET TOMMY EDMAN ON THE
DOUBLE PLAY, BUT NO.
JUST BARELY BEAT IT OUT.
SETTING UP THE PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT
WHO HAMMERED THIS FASTBALL.
SO CLOSE THAT GETTING OUT OF
THAT JAM.
INSTEAD, WE SIT TIED IN THE
EIGHTH INNING.
TALK ABOUT THE OVER-UNDER ON
NOLAN ARENADO.
I SAID I DIDN'T LIKE HIS CHANCES
IF HE LET OFF EVERY TIME UP.
SCOTT: THAT'S WHAT HE'S DOING.
HE'S LEADING OFF FOR THE EIGHTH
INNING.
[LAUGHTER]
SO FAR 0-3, NO R.B.I.S.
BETMGM WITH THE ODDS ON HIM
CONTRIBUTING AN R.B.I..
HERE COMES ERIN ASHBY.
THE BREWERS HAVE BEEN A PITCHING
FACTORY.
HERE'S THE LATEST TO COME OUT OF
IT.
BIG-TIME STUFF.
THE NUMBERS ARE FINE, .277.
HIS FIRST OUTING WAS MESSY.
AFTER THAT, HE'S BEEN ELITE ON
THE MOUND.
.2 77 EARNED RUN AVERAGE.
HE POPPED UP ON THE 17TH IN
MILWAUKEE HIS LAST APPEARANCE,
THREE SCORELESS AND FIVE
STRIKEOUTS, NO WALKS.
HE'S PICKING UP STEAM AND
LOOKING LIKE HE WILL BE ANOTHER
TALENTED ARM OUT OF THE
MILWAUKEE BULLPEN DURING PLAYOFF
TIME.
TOM: OBVIOUSLY CRAIG COUNSELL
TRUSTS HIM BECAUSE OF THAT PITCH
WITH THE SLIDER.
THAT IS HIS ELITE PITCH.
IT'S ALSO TOUGH BECAUSE HE HIDES
THE BALL SO WELL.
SCOTT: THAT IS HIS PRIMARY
PITCH.
HE USES THE SLIDER A BIT MORE.
>> AS A HITTER, YOU WANT TO TRY
AND PICK UP THE BASEBALL AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE, CERTAINLY BEFORE
THE RELEASE POINT.
ASHBY KEEPS HIS ARM BEHIND HIM,
BEHIND HIS BODY SO YOU CAN'T SEE
IT.
HE THROWS THAT GLOVE AT YOU LIKE
ANDY PETTITTE.
THEN, ALL OF A SUDDEN, THE
BASEBALL APPEARS.
THE LONGER A HITTER CAN SEE A
BASEBALL, INCLUDING BEFORE THE
RELEASE, THE BETTER OFF HE IS.
SCOTT: HE'S 23, A FOURTH ROUND
PICK OUT OF MILWAUKEE, THE SAME
ALMA MATER AS UNCLE ANDY WHO
PITCHED IN THE BIG LEAGUES FOR
PARTS OF 14 SEASONS.
BALL FOUR, RENATO IS THE LEADOFF
MAN ABOARD.
CARDINALS HAD A BASE RUNNER TO
START THE EIGHTH.
TOM: WE SAW THE MILWAUKEE BENCH
ALERTING THE POSSIBILITY OF A
BUNT RIGHT HERE.
I WOULD LET CARLSON HIT, BUT THE
WAY THE CARDINALS PLAY, YOU HAVE
TO DEFEND AGAINST THE
POSSIBILITY.
SCOTT: SAYING -- SEEING THE BALL
WELL TODAY AS WELL, SINGLE,
TRIPLE AND A FLY OUT.
TOM: BETTER FROM THE SIDE OF THE
PLATE AS WELL.
SCOTT: .340 EIGHT AGAINST
LEFTIES.
AND THERE HE GOES.
RIGHT SIDE AND OFF TO THE RACES.
ARENADO IS HEADFIRST.
NICE CHUCK FROM TAYLOR IN RIGHT
FIELD.
HE FELL ON THE THROW.
TOM: I DISAGREE WITH YOU ON
THAT.
THE CARDINALS ARE A GREAT
BASERUNNING TEAM AND YOU LOOK AT
CARLSON AT SECOND.
HE DID NOT THINK HE HAD A SHOT.
CARLSON READS THE THROW OUT OF
THE HAND AS HIGH.
THAT IS AN EASY READ.
THE BALL IS NOT CREDIBLE.
CARDINALS ARE IN BUSINESS,
SECOND AND THIRD, NOBODY OUT.
SPECIAL TEAMS FOR THE CARDINALS
COMING THROUGH AGAIN WITH
BASERUNNING.
MILWAUKEE WILL HAVE TO BRING THE
INFIELD IN.
WE'VE SEEN IT ALREADY TODAY,
YADI MOLINA IN SCORING POSITION,
LOVES TO ATTACK THE FIRST PITCH.
SCOTT: ARENADO WALKED, HEADS TO
THIRD ON THE CARLSON BASE HIT.
ADVANCES TO SECOND ON THE THROW.
TWO AND SCORING POSITION.
YADI DOESN'T GO AFTER THE FIRST
PITCH BUT IT SKIPS AWAY, AND THE
CARDINALS GRAB THE LEAD.
IT IS 6-5.
TOM: IT WILL BE INTERESTING HOW
THEY SCORE IT.
I'M NOT SURE THIS WAS TRACKED
WELL, FASTBALL AT 99.
LOOKS LIKE IT HANDCUFFED HIM A
LITTLE BIT.
JUST DIDN'T REALLY REACT IN
TIME.
IF YOU COULD READ LIPS, ONE
PITCH AT A TIME, TRYING TO SLOW
HIM DOWN.
THE GAME IS SPEEDING UP ON
ASHBY.
NOT THAT THAT PITCH WAS REALLY
HIS FULL.
-- HIS FAULT.
HE HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO LAND
THAT SLIDER SO FAR.
SCOTT: FASTBALL.
NOW 2-0 TO MOLINA.
AND MOLINA, BACK AT THE WALL,
HE'S GOT IT.
JUST ENOUGH SPACE BUT IT IS GOOD
FOR A SAC FLY OFF OF YADI MOLINA
TO MAKE IT 7-5 ST. LOUIS.
CARLSON COMES IN TO MAKE IT
SEVEN UNANSWERED RUNS FROM THE
HOTTEST TEAM IN BASEBALL LOOKING
FOR A 12TH CONSECUTIVE WIN AND
NOW A TWO RUN CUSHION.
TOM: THEY PLAYED GREAT
FUNDAMENTAL BASEBALL AND YADI
MOLINA IS PART OF THAT.
HE WANTS TO USE THE BIG PART OF
THE FIELD.
THAT IS A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
SWING THEN WE SAW EARLIER.
THIS IS DESIGNED TO HIT TO THE
BIG PART OF THE FIELD IN THE
AIR.
AS A HITTER, YOU KEEP THE BALL
AWAY FROM THE CORNERS AND STAY
AWAY FROM THE ROLLOVER.
HE ALMOST GOT A LITTLE MORE THAN
THE OUT AS WELL.
SCOTT: CAIN TRACKED IT WELL
AGAINST THE WALL.
SOSA GOING TO WRITE.
GOOD MUSTARD ON THAT ONE, IF IT
STAYS FAIR.
IT IS FOUL.
TWO RUNS KNOCKED IN BY YADI
MOLINA TODAY.
TOM: HE KNOWS HE HAD A CHANCE.
HE THOUGHT MAYBE HE HAD IT.
ALMOST.
WE WILL SEE IF THE CARDINALS
WANT A REPLAY ON THIS THING.
THEY WILL.
SCOTT: LET'S SEE WHERE THAT
BASEBALL ENDED UP.
TOM: THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THEY
ARE DOING IN NEW YORK RIGHT NOW.
THE BOLDED BOUNCE IN THE STANDS
RIGHT?
-- THE BALL DID BOUNCE IN THE
STANDS, RIGHT?
AT A MINIMUM THEY MIGHT HAVE TO
TURN IT OVER.
SCOTT: IT IS A BLIND CORNER OF
THE STADIUM.
WE HAVE THE SAME VIEWS THAT NEW
YORK CITY DOES.
I DON'T THINK IT WILL BE ENOUGH
EVIDENCE.
YES, A FOUL BALL.
THEY NEEDED THE CAMERA FROM THE
SKY ON THAT ONE, RIGHT?
[LAUGHTER]
TOM: ROOF CAM.
I BEST SEE YOU ARE WONDERING
ABOUT WILLIAMS AND THE
POSSIBILITY OF USING HIM.
SCOTT: MAY BE STARTING.
MIGHT HAVE TO DO THAT IN THE
NEXT HALF.
SOSA IS RETIRED.
TOM: IT IS CERTAINLY AN OPTION.
TIE GAME DURING THIS LOSING
STREAK.
YOU ARE AT HOME.
ASHBY DOES HAVE REVERSE SPLITS.
THE SLIDER GOES REALLY WELL.
HE DID TURN CARLSON OVER TO HIS
BETTER SIDE.
ARENADO, RIGHT-HANDED LEADING
OFF.
SPOKE TO THE CONFIDENCE OF ASHBY
GETTING RIGHT-HANDED HITTERS
OUT.
SCOTT: THESE ARE BIG MOMENTS
FROM SOME UNPROVEN RELIEVERS OUT
OF THE PEN.
TOM: IT'S FUNNY, I SORT OF
ANTICIPATED THIS BECAUSE I ASKED
CRAIG COUNSELL IF HE HAD RELIEF
PITCHERS.
TODAY, HE REALLY WANTED TO GET
IN THE GAME.
A LOT OF TIMES IN A LOSING
STREAK AND I CALLED THEM WINNING
PIECES, THE PITCHERS HE WOULD
LIKE TO USE, SOMETIMES YOU JUST
WANT TO GET THEM OUT THERE.
THE ONE GUY HE MENTIONED WAS
ASHBY.
I THOUGHT MAYBE HE WANTED TO
SCOTT:, TALKING ABOUT ASHBY.
A VERY SHORT DAY FOR BRETT
ANDERSON ON HIS RETURN FROM THE
INJURED LIST.
YESTERDAY, REMOVED WITH THE
SECOND.
CARDINALS POUNCED.
UNDERWATER SWING FROM BADER.
INNING OVER.
TWO MORE FOR THE CARDINALS.
SEVEN RUNS IN A ROW AGAINST
MILWAUKEE.
THEY LEAD BY TWO.
MID-EIGHT, WE WILL SEE IF THE
BREWERS BATS HAVE MORE.
>> ON JULY 7, 2008, THE BREWERS
MADE ONE OF THE BIGGEST TRADES
IN FRANCHISE HISTORY WHEN THEY
ACQUIRED REIGNING CY YOUNG
WINNER CC SABATHIA FROM
CLEVELAND.
THEY MADE THE MOVE WITH ONE GOAL
IN MIND, MAKE THE POSTSEASON FOR
THE FIRST TIME SINCE 1982.
>> WE FELT BEFORE WE GOT CC THAT
WE WERE A GOOD CLUB, BUT WHAT HE
DID WAS GIVE US INCREDIBLE DEPTH
.
>> CC SABATHIA WITH A FIVE HIT
SHUTOUT.
>> WHEN WE GOT CC SABATHIA, WE
MADE IT LOUD AND CLEAR, WE WILL
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO BRING
THE FANS POSTSEASON BASEBALL.
>> SABATHIA GOES ALL THE WAY.
WHAT A MASTERPIECE.
>> SABATHIA, PITCHING ON THREE
DAYS REST IN THREE CONSECUTIVE
STARTS DOWN THE STRETCH.
>> THE BREWERS WIN AGAIN AND CC
SABATHIA, HIS THIRD STRAIGHT
COMPLETE GAME.
>> AND ON THAT FINAL DAY OF THE
2008 SEASON, HE DELIVERED HIS
MOST CLUTCH PERFORMANCE OF THE
YEAR, LEADING THE BREWERS TO
THEIR FIRST POSTSEASON IN
NEARLY TWO AND A HALF DECADES.
>> THE BREWERS ARE GOING TO THE
PLAYOFFS!
>> CC SABATHIA, WHAT A PICKUP.
TOM: BACK IN WISCONSIN FOR THE
BREWERS AND CARDINALS, CARDINALS
GOING FOR THE SUPER SWEEP.
THE BREWERS ARE GOING FOR THEIR
FIRST WORLD SERIES TITLE IN
FRANCHISE HISTORY.
THEY MADE IT IN 1982 TO THE FALL
CLASSIC BUT SINCE THE FRANCHISE
WAS BORN IN 1969, THEY HAVE NOT
PICKED UP A CROWN.
SAME WITH THE RANGERS, PADRES,
MARINERS, ROCKIES AND RAYS.
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF SUCCESS
FOR MILWAUKEE LATELY.
BUT I SPY DEVIN WILLIAMS BEHIND
CRAIG COUNSELL.
WE WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT
PONDERING WHY HE WOULD NOT BE IN
THE GAME.
HE'S IN THE DUGOUT.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
TOM: NOT AVAILABLE.
THAT IS ONE THING FOR A RELIEF
PITCHER TO BE THERE IN THE FIRST
OR SECOND INNING.
SCOTT: SEE IF ANYONE ASKS CRAIG
COUNSELL ABOUT THAT POST GAME.
ONE OF THE BEST IN THE BUSINESS,
DEVIN WILLIAMS.
LUIS GARCIA, THE 34-YEAR-OLD,
WHO HAS HAD MASSIVE CONTROL
ISSUES EXCEPT FOR THIS ONE.
YOU TOM: ARE TOM: ON YOUR TOES
BECAUSE HE HAS THAT POWER
SINKER.
RIGHT ON RIGHT, BE CAREFUL.
SCOTT: IT'S DOWN.
1-1.
THE BREWERS HAVE DONE THE
COMEBACK EFFORT QUITE OFTEN THIS
YEAR, 38 COMEBACK WINS, SECOND
MOST IN THE NATIONAL LEAGUE.
THE CARDINALS BULLPEN WAS REALLY
SOLIDIFIED WITH SNEAKY PICKUPS
LIKE LUIS GARCIA, WHO HAS FOUND
IT AT 34 YEARS OLD.
THERE WERE STRIKE THROWING
ISSUES FOR THE STAFF AS A WHOLE
IF YOU LOOKED AT THE NUMBERS,
BUT THAT WAS FIXED.
WE SPOKE THIS MORNING TO MIKE
SHILDT ABOUT IT.
IT WAS NOT A PHILOSOPHICAL
CHANGE, IT WAS A TRANSACTIONAL
CHANGE.
THEY PICKED UP PITCHERS THAT
KNEW HOW TO FIND THE ZONE.
URIAS BROKE HIS BAT, A LITTLE
FLOATER.
NO PROBLEM FOR O'NEILL.
THOSE BAT COMPANIES TODAY.
[LAUGHTER]
THEY ARE WATCHING.
TOM: I'M JUST THINKING ABOUT THE
TOP OF THIS INNING.
BASEBALL REALLY IS A GAME PLAYED
IN 90 FOOT INCREMENTS.
YOU CAN'T GIVE 90 FEET AWAY FOR
FREE.
THAT IS WHAT THE BREWERS DID
STARTING WITH A LEADOFF WALK.
GOES TO SECOND ON A SINGLE ON A
HIGH THROW THAT'S NOT CREDIBLE.
RUN SCORES ON THE PASSED BALL.
ANOTHER FREEBASE THAT WINDS UP
COSTING THE EXTRA RUN ON THE SAC
FLY BY MOLINA.
IS STRESS TOO MANY FREE BASES IN
ANY KIND OF THE GAME, ESPECIALLY
TIE GAME IN THE EIGHTH INNING.
SCOTT: WE ARE SEEING SMALL
THINGS OVERLOOKED IN HIGHLIGHTS
POPPING UP A LOT LATELY FOR THE
CARDINALS.
TAYLOR IS THE HOT HAND.
TWO HOME RUNS TODAY, GRAND SLAM
IN THE FIRST.
ONE MORE ON HIS HOMER IN THE
FOURTH.
THAT IS IT FOR MILWAUKEE TODAY.
GARCIA GOT HIM.
TOM: YADI DOUBLE CLUTCHED.
HE KNEW IT
A STRIKE BUT DID NOT GET THE
CALL RIGHT AWAY.
SCOTT: YADI HAS BEEN CLOSE IN
THE ZONE TODAY, TO THROW ANOTHER
CONSPIRACY THEORY AT YOU.
YOU GOT IT THIS TIME, STRIKE
THREE.
I WILL MAKE YOU WAIT FOR IT.
WHAT A STORY, LUIS GARCIA PICKED
UP BY THE CARDINALS ON JULY 9.
WAS CUT BY THE YANKEES.
HE WAS A TRIPLE-A CLOSER.
THAT LOOKS LIKE GOOD STUFF.
100 TOM:.
YOU HIT ON IT.
THE ABILITY TO THROW STRIKES.
YOU CAN'T PUT SOMEONE OUT THERE
WHO HAS THROWN A LOT OF WALKS
AND HAS CONTROL ISSUES IN THE
EIGHTH INNING.
MIKE SHILDT HAS TRUST IN GARCIA.
SCOTT: LOADS OF WALKS IN HIS
LIFETIME BUT IT HAS ALL COME
TOGETHER.
CAIN HELD BACK.
ONE BALL, TWO STRIKES.
TWO DOWN IN THE EIGHTH.
WE ARE GETTING TO THE POINT FOR
ST. LOUIS WHERE WE CAN START
PREVIEWING PLAYOFF MATCHUPS.
SECOND WILD-CARD LOOKS LIKE IT
WILL BE THEIRS.
WILL IT BE AGAINST THE GIANTS OR
THE DODGERS?
WE WILL SEE.
IF IT IS L.A., MIGHT BE A
CLASSIC SHOWDOWN BETWEEN MAX
SCHERZER AND ADAM WAINWRIGHT.
CAIN TO LEFT, AND A FOUL BALL.
HERE IS THE X FACTOR.
TOMORROW, MAKING ONE OF THE
STARTS.
TOMORROW, JACK FLAHERTY IS
MAKING ONE OF THE STARTS IN THE
DOUBLEHEADER DAY.
HE WILL NOT BE GOING ALONE,
MIGHT BE AN INNING OR TWO.
BUT JACK IS BACK.
CAIN, PAST SHORT.
TWO OUTS AND ONE ON FOR THE
BREWERS AFTER THE CAIN SINGLE.
LET'S GO TO BRETT FOR A LITTLE
MORE ON WHAT COULD BE A HUGE
DEAL FOR THE CARDINALS TOMORROW.
BRETT: IT CERTAINLY IS, GETTING
CLARITY BACK WOULD BE A NICE
BOOST.
THEY COULD USE THE ARMS.
FLAHERTY WAS HAVING A NICE
SEASON, MIKE SHILDT DIDN'T
COMMIT TO HOW MANY PITCHES HE
WOULD THROW, MAY BE MORE OF AN
OPENER SITUATION.
HE ALSO HAS DAKOTA HUDSON.
WAS SUPPOSED TO PITCH YESTERDAY
ON A REHAB WITH MEMPHIS, THEY
DID NOT GO THROUGH WITH IT.
HE MIGHT END UP HAVING THAT
REHAB OR IF THEY REALLY NEED
HIM, THEY CAN BRING HIM UP
BASICALLY ONE YEAR REMOVED FROM
TOMMY JOHN.
SCOTT: AND THOSE ARE TALENTED
ARMS.
TWO OF THE BETTER ARMS ON THE
ROSTER WHEN THEY ARE FEELING
GOOD.
MANNY PINA DOUBLED LAST TIME UP.
TOM: WE SAID JACK IS BACK, BUT
WE DON'T KNOW IN WHAT FORM YET.
IF HE'S CLOSE TO HIS USUAL FORM,
HE DOES BECOME AN OPTION EVEN
WITHOUT LENGTH.
THE ONE RUN GAME, YOU CAN SEE
THE DEPTH OF THE ST. LOUIS
BULLPEN.
I THINK HE COULD PUT HIMSELF IN
PLAY AT LEAST AS AN OPTION.
SCOTT: PIÑA TO ARENADO, HE WILL
GET HIM OUT.
CARDINALS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
SCORE RUNS EARLY IN GAMES.
THE BULLPEN HAS BEEN GREAT.
BIG COMEBACK DAY FOR THEM SO
FAR, ON TO THE NINTH.
>> COME ON BACK.
STRIKE ONE.
GOOD BALL.
A LOT OF WIND.
>> CUT BACK.
CUT BACK.
THAT WASN'T GOOD.
SIT, BALL.
PRETTY GOOD.
>> WHAT A PLEASURE.
THAT WAS FUN.
WE HAVE TO PLAY IN ST. LOUIS.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME OUT.
SCOTT: YOU ARE WATCHING THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK ON YOUTUBE
PRESENTED BY JIM BEAM.
LAST DAY ON THE YOUTUBE SLATE.
WHAT A YEAR IT HAS BEEN.
WHAT A GAME TODAY.
WHO HAD NUMBER FIVE?
PROBABLY CORBIN BURNES.
HE PREDICTED THE GRAND SLAM IN
THE FIRST INNING, BUT AFTER
JUMPING OUT TO A 5-0 LEAD, THE
CARDINALS SCURRY BACK AND RUSH
THE BREWERS.
IT IS 7-5 AND WE ARE IN THE
NINTH AND ST. LOUIS IS TRYING TO
PUT TOGETHER A 12TH CONSECUTIVE
WIN AND A CHANCE TO ADD ON RUNS
AGAINST AARON ASHBY.
TOM: BY THE WAY, THANKS TO
CORBIN BURNES FOR WEARING THAT.
THE MICROPHONE.
I LOVE HEARINGS THE PLAYERS.
ALL THE GUYS, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'M SURE THE FANS WOULD SAY THE
SAME.
SCOTT: AND YOU CAN HEAR MUCH
MORE OF IT ON PLAY LOUD, THE HIT
YOUTUBE SHOW.
JOSE RONDON BELTS ONE.
ADAMES GOING HOME AND SLIDES BUT
HE IS NOT THERE.
TOM: I RAN ALL THIS WAY, I MIGHT
AS WELL CATCH THE DARN THING.
HE TRIED TO SELL IT.
[LAUGHTER]
SCOTT: HE'S GREAT.
HE'S ENTERTAINING.
TOM: HE IS JUST A PLEASURE TO BE
AROUND.
HIGH-ENERGY.
SCOTT: THAT IS WHY WHEN ADAMES
HAS MISSED TIME LATELY, HE'S A
HANDFUL IN THE DUGOUT, WATCHING
GAMES.
NONSTOP CHATTER.
CRAIG COUNSELL SET AT ONE POINT,
HE WAS ANNOYING JUST IN THE WAY
HE WANTED TO GET BACK ON THE
FIELD.
TOM: LIKE A KID ON A RAINY DAY,
CAN'T GO OUTSIDE AND PLAY,
DRIVING MOM AND DAD CRAZY.
SCOTT: HE CAME BACK FROM THE IL
MONDAY AND HE SAID HE COULDN'T
SLEEP ON SUNDAY.
THAT WAS THE EXCITEMENT.
IT IS LIKE OPENING DAY, FIRST
DAY OF THE POSTSEASON
EXCITEMENT.
RONDON PINCH-HITTING.
WE SAW GARCIA HANDLE THE EIGHTH.
SHOULD BE GALLEGOS IN THE NINTH
FOR THE CARDINALS.
POP UP, ANOTHER CHANCE.
EDUARDO ESCOBAR OVER THE
SHOULDER, NO IN RIGHT FIELD!
IT IS TYRONE TAYLOR TO THE
RESCUE.
TOM: WOW.
REMEMBER EARLIER WE HAD CORBIN
BURNES ON A POP UP IN THAT
DIRECTION SAYING, WE HAVE A GUY
THERE?
MAYBE NOT.
YOU DON'T FIGURE THE RIGHT
FIELDER WILL GET THERE.
TAYLOR COMES OUT OF NOWHERE WITH
A SPECTACULAR DIVING CATCH.
YOU SEE THE LAST LOOK HE HAD.
THAT IS THE WAY YOU DO IT.
I DON'T WANT TO SAY HE MADE THAT
LOOK EASY, BUT THAT IS A VERY
DIFFICULT PLAY HE JUST PULLED
OFF.
SCOTT: THAT IS A SPECIAL ROLE
PLAYER FOR THE BREW CREW.
ESCOBAR KIND OF STOPPED.
I WAS LOOKING DURING THE REPLAY.
I WAS LOOKING TO SEE IF HIS
MOUTH MOVED TO SEE IF HE WAS
CALLING FOR IT.
TOM: ESCOBAR WAS LIKE, A LITTLE
HELP WITH THE SUN, PLEASE?
THESE TEAMS ARE A PLEASURE TO
WATCH ON DEFENSE.
THEY GET AFTER IT.
IT'S THE RANGE THEY SHOW.
WE TALKED ABOUT HOW THEY ARE
AMONG THE TEAMS THAT SHIFT THE
LEAST.
I TRULY BELIEVE THAT IF GOING
FORWARD, TALK ABOUT NEXT YEAR,
BASEBALL IS ABLE TO PUT A
GOVERNOR ON SHIFTS.
.
IT ACTUALLY HIGHLIGHTS THE
ATHLETICISM AND RANGE OF THE
PLAYERS MORE.
TALK ABOUT LIMITING IT TO SAY
INFIELDERS ON EACH SIDE OF THE
BASE.
THAT DID NOT GET THE PAD.
IT GOT THE FOOT.
SCOTT: EXTRA MINUTE TO WALK IT
OFF AND CLIMB BACK IN.
YOU ARE RIGHT, THERE WOULD BE
MORE GROUND TO COVER.
IF THE SHIFTS ARE LIMITED.
TOM: I SPOKE TO FRANCISCO LINDOR
ABOUT THAT AND HE'S IN FAVOR OF
THAT.
FOR THAT VERY REASON.
LET US SHOW OFF OUR ATHLETIC
ABILITY.
SCOTT: ASHBY GETS THROUGH ADMIN
AND IT IS PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT'S
TURN.
STATCAST POWERED BY GOOGLE CLOUD
.
HE DID IT AGAIN.
TOM: HE DID.
100 6.6 EXIT VELO.
TALKED ABOUT HOW BOXBERGER DID
NOT EXECUTE THE SLIDER.
BACK TO ULTIMATE STRENGTH ON THE
FASTBALL.
SCOTT: HE'S A STRONG CANDIDATE
FOR THAT TROPHY.
GAME DECIDING HOMER AT THE
MOMENT FOR GOLDIE.
HE SCORED FOUR RUNS YESTERDAY.
TOM: IT SEEMS AT THE END OF THE
YEAR, THE NUMBERS ALWAYS LOOK
VERY SIMILAR.
SCOTT: SENT TO LEFT CENTER.
ALL THE OUTFIELDERS ARE JUST
GOING TO WATCH IT GO.
PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT HAS A TWO HOME
RUN DAY AND IT IS 8-5.
THE CARDINALS ARE CLICKING ON
ALL CYLINDERS RIGHT NOW, THEY
ARE A FORCE.
TOM: WHEN HE HIT THAT BALL, I
WATCHED CAIN AND YELICH, NEITHER
ONE FLINCHED.
THAT WAS SO LOUD, THE SOUND OF
CONTACT.
A LITTLE WAGNER FROM
GOLDSCHMIDT.
WATCH THE OUTFIELDERS.
MY GOODNESS.
THAT HAMMERED.
SCOTT: THE SOUND TOLD THE STORY,
TOO MUCH LIFT ON THIS ONE.
ANOTHER RUN FOR ST. LOUIS.
PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT BOOSTED HIS
TEAM IN FRONT WITH HIS TWO RUN
SHOT IN THE SEVENTH.
ENCORE?
YES, PLEASE.
8-5 CARDINALS, GOING FOR THE
SUPER SWEEP.
THAT ENDS AT 12 CONSECUTIVE WIN
IF THEY CAN PICK UP THREE MORE
OUTS.
THE CONCLUSION, COMING UP.
>> 3-2 DELIVERY.
SWING AND A HIGH DRIVE TO CENTER
FIELD.
GET UP.
OH, YEAH.
IN THIS GAME IS TIED!
3-3 WITH A WALKOFF HOME RUN HERE
IN THE BOTTOM OF THE 11TH
INNING.
THE CARDINALS WIN 10-9,
PHENOMENAL.
JUST FANTASTIC.
THIS ONE WILL GO DOWN IN
HISTORY.
UNBELIEVABLE.
LEADOFF HOME RUN, HE TIED IT
WITH A TWO RUN TRIPLE AND HE
WINS IT HERE IN THE 11TH.
BRETT: WELCOME BACK TO
MILWAUKEE, THE CARDINALS TRYING
TO EXTEND THEIR WINNING STREAK
TO 12 STRAIGHT GAMES.
MIKE SHILDT AND HIS TEAM WILL
HAVE BEEN IN THE POSTSEASON 15
TIMES SINCE 2000.
THE YANKEES HAVE BEEN THERE 17
TIMES AND THE CARDINALS WILL BE
15.
DODGERS 13, BRAVES 12.
MAYBE WHEN THEY WERE 69-68 THIS
MONTH, IT DIDN'T LOOK LIKE A
POSSIBILITY.
THEY HAVE LOST JUST ONCE SINCE.
SCOTT: IT IS AN INCREDIBLE RUN
BY THE CARDINALS AND IT
CONTINUES.
THERE ARE SO MANY REASONS TO .2.
GALLEGOS HAS TAKEN OVER AS THE
CLOSER AND HE HAS SHINED IN THIS
SPOT.
TOM: I LIKE WHAT MIKE SHILDT DID
THE OTHER NIGHT, HE WALKED
YELICH INTENTIONALLY TO LOAD THE
BASES.
HE HAD THAT MUCH CONFIDENCE IN
GALLEGOS NOT JUST TO CLOSE THE
GAME, BUT TO THROW STRIKES.
AND HE DID.
SCOTT: THAT WAS ONE OF THE CLOSE
ONES.
A 2-1 WIN TUESDAY.
YESTERDAY, 10-2.
RIGHT NOW, 7-5 WITH PINCH HITTER
DANIEL VOGELBACH STEPPING IN.
YOU CAN POINT BACK TO
VOGELBACH'S GRAND SLAM, WALKOFF
DOWN.
NOW IT HAS BEEN GALLEGOS IN THE
NINTH.
IT IS JUST ONE OF THE
TURNAROUNDS BECAUSE THE
CARDINALS HAVE PLAYED
SENSATIONAL BASEBALL SINCE THEN.
MANY TEAMS WOULD HAVE BEEN
HEARTBROKEN AFTER THAT PLAY.
AND LOOKING UP IN THE STANDINGS,
TEAMS TO PUSH PAST, IT LOOKED
INCREDIBLY BLEAK FOR ST. LOUIS.
SOME VETERANS FILLED IN INNINGS
LIKE JON LESTER AND J.A. HAPP.
TOM: BUT I DO SEE THAT VETERAN
PRESENTS PLAYING A ROLE IN THAT
TURNED, EVEN IF IT IS NOT
DIRECT, THE INDIRECT GUYS WHO
HAVE BEEN THERE, MOLINA,
WAINWRIGHT, ARENADO,
GOLDSCHMIDT.
SO MUCH EXPERIENCE HERE.
KNOWING THERE WAS STILL TIME AND
THEY BUILT THIS, ONE WIN, ONE
GAME AT A TIME.
THIS MIGHT BE THE BEST STREAK,
DOWN FIVE RUNS.
EIGHT UNANSWERED SO FAR.
I WAS LOOKING AT THIS TODAY.
12 WINS IN A ROW.
THAT ALONE IS GREAT.
IN SEPTEMBER.
IT HAS ONLY BEEN DONE EIGHT
TIMES IN BASEBALL HISTORY.
LAST TIME WAS IN 1999 BY THE
ASTROS.
THAT IS SOMETHING SPECIAL THEY
ARE DOING HERE.
SCOTT: A STRIKE TO VOGELBACH,
2-2.
TOM: I KNOW WE THINK OF THE 2007
ROCKIES.
IT DOESN'T MATTER, POSTSEASON
HIS MOMENTUM, DOESN'T MATTER IF
YOU PLAY WELL OR POORLY, THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING TO THE
POSTSEASON IS WHERE YOU ARE
HEALTHWISE, ESPECIALLY WITH
PITCHERS.
SCOTT:SCOTT: UP IN THE ZONE,
GALLEGOS WITH A K.
ONE DOWN IN THE NINTH.
TOM: WOULD YOU RATHER BE PLAYING
GOING INTO THE POSTSEASON?
OF COURSE BUT HISTORY TELLS US
THERE IS NOT A STATISTICAL OR
PROBABILITY ADVANTAGE.
IF YOU ARE THE CARDINALS, YOU
COULD RUN THE TABLE HERE BUT IT
STILL COMES DOWN TO ONE GAME,
WIN OR GO HOME.
ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN IN THAT
SHORT SAMPLE.
SCOTT: AND A CHANCE TO BE, I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE ULTIMATE
UNDERDOG, BUT WHEN YOU LOOK OUT
WEST TO WHAT THE GIANTS AND
DODGERS HAVE DONE, IF THEY ARE
ABLE TO PULL OFF A WIN, IT WOULD
BE EPIC AND HISTORIC.
THE SECOND BEST RECORD IN
BASEBALL MIGHT BELONG TO A TEAM
THAT HAS ONE GAME WITH ITS
SEASON ON THE LINE TO START THE
POSTSEASON.
TOM: I DO AGREE THE PRESSURE IS
ON FOR THE OTHER TEAM IN THE
WEST, THE WILD-CARD GAME.
THAT COULD BE TO THE CARDINALS'
ADVANTAGE TO USE THAT IN THEIR
FAVOR.
THEN YOU REALLY HAVE MOMENTUM.
YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT THE
NATIONALS DUE TO THE BREWERS IN
THE WILD-CARD GAME, THE ROYALS
TO THE A'S.
THE SEASON STARTS LIKE THAT.
YOU FEEL INVINCIBLE.
SCOTT: AND THEY ARE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO SET THEMSELVES UP FOR
THAT.
THEY ARE NOT FIGHTING TO THE
FINISH LINE AT THIS POINT.
ST. LOUIS IS CLOSE TO WRAPPING
UP THE SECOND WILD-CARD SEAT
WITH THIS RUN THEREON AND THAT
WILL LET THEM SET UP WHOEVER
THEY WANT FOR THAT GAME.
ADAM WAINWRIGHT, BASED ON HIS
SCHEDULE, YOU WILL NOT NEED HIM
MOST LIKELY SO YOU CAN SAVE HIM
FOR THE WILD-CARD GAME.
WE SAW A SHOT OF JACK FLAHERTY
COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
HE MIGHT POP UP IN THAT GAME.
AND IN THIS GAME, WHO STANDS
OUT?
THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME
DECIDED BY YOU.
PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT, DYLAN CARLSON,
YADI MOLINA.
VOTE NOW.
IT IS ON YOUR SCREEN.
TOM, VERBALLY FROM YOU?
TOM: MY EARS STILL HURT FROM
THAT LAST HOME RUN GOLDSCHMIDT
HIT.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT'S WHERE I WOULD GO.
I LOVE THE FINER POINTS --
POINTS OF THE GAME.
THE THINGS THAT THE CARDINALS DO
WELL, DEFENSE, BUT NOTHING LIKE
THAT HOME RUN TO TURN THINGS
AROUND.
THE EIGHTH INNING AND THEN ADD
ON TO THE NINTH.
SCOTT: THE CAMPAIGN IS ON FOR
TOM.
GO GOLDY.
HE IS 6-9 IN THE LAST FEW DAYS.
TOM: YOU CALLED IT, YOU SAID HE
LOVES SITTING IN THIS PARK.
-- HITTING IN THIS PARK.
SCOTT: HE DOES.
HE SAW THE SPARKLE LITTLE BIT AS
A DIAMONDBACK AND NOW A LOT AS A
CARDINAL.
THAT'S THE THING.
YOU MOVE TO THE N.L. CENTRAL.
THAT'S A PITCHER'S BALLPARK,
LESS HITTER FRIENDLY THAN
ARIZONA BUT SOME OF THE
OPPONENTS IN THE DIVISION HAVE
FRIENDLY BALLPARKS FOR HITTERS.
WONG STAYS ALIVE.
TOM: I WAS A LITTLE SURPRISED
CHECKING THE PARK FACTORS TODAY.
ACTUALLY MIDDLE OF THE PACK IN
TERMS OF OFFENSE.
IT DOES SEEM LIKE MORE OF A
HITTERS PARK.
THE STATCAST PARK FACTORS,
WORKING ON ROLLING AVERAGES.
IT DOES HAVE A REPUTATION AS A
BIG HITTERS PARK.
SCOTT: ONE OUT IN THE NINTH.
2-2 FROM GALLEGOS.
A ONE HOP FOR EDMUND.
PART OF THE REASON WHY I THINK
THE CARDINALS CAN BE SO
DANGEROUS IN THAT ONE GAME IS
THEY DON'T HURT THEMSELVES WITH
MISTAKES.
WE HAVE BEEN GUSHING ABOUT THEIR
DEFENSE AND MILWAUKEE CAN TAKE
IT ON.
THE BASERUNNING FOR ST. LOUIS.
WE'VE SEEN THE BULLPEN BECOME A
PROBLEM FOR OPPOSING TEAMS IN
THE WAY IT IS SET UP NOW.
TOM: HOW ABOUT THE JOB BY THE
ST. LOUIS BULLPEN TODAY?
SCOTT: LIGHTS OUT.
TOM: AMAZING.
MILWAUKEE'S BULLPEN GOT IN
TROUBLE WITH SOME WALKS.
SCOTT: FIRST PITCH STRIKE TO
ADAMES.
THIS WOULD BE THE LARGEST LEAD
BLOWN BY MILWAUKEE THIS YEAR.
PREVIOUSLY, FOUR RUNS ON AUGUST
3 AGAINST PITTSBURGH IN A LOSS.
THIS WILL BE THE LARGEST
COMEBACK OF THE YEAR FOR THE
CARDINALS.
TOM: I'VE ALWAYS SAID WHEN IT
COMES TO PITCHING LATE IN THE
GAME, ESPECIALLY CLOSERS, IT IS
KEY TO AVOID WALKS AND HOME
RUNS.
IT SOUNDS OBVIOUS, YOU DON'T
WANT THEM ANY TIME, BUT IT IS
HARD TO STRING HITS TOGETHER
AGAINST POWER ARMS IN THE
BULLPEN.
THAT IS WHAT HARMED THE
MILWAUKEE BULLPEN TODAY.
SCOTT: ONE STRIKE AWAY.
I THINK BACK TO THE FIFTH,
LOOKING INTO THIS POST GAME SHOW
, 30 MINUTES DEVOTED TO THESE
TEAMS, HE WALKED THE PITCHER TO
START THE FRAME.
HE WAS ABLE TO ESCAPE.
TOM: BASES LOADED ONE OUT.
AT THE START OF IT.
SCOTT: LAST TIME THE CARDINALS
WON 12 IN A ROW WAS 1982.
40 YEARS AGO.
PRETTY GOOD YEAR FOR ST. LOUIS.
YOU KNOW WHO THEY BEAT?
THIS MILWAUKEE TEAM.
YOUNG OUTFIELDERS, O'NEILL,
BADER, CARLSON.
IT WASN'T THE BEST DAY FOR ADAM
WAINWRIGHT.
HE DIDN'T HAVE COMMAND OF HIS
CURVEBALL EARLY ON AND THEY
REPLACED HIM WITH A PINCH HITTER
.
TOM: TWO BAD PITCHES TO TAYLOR,
HE DID NOT LET HIM GET AWAY WITH
EITHER ONE.
A GRAND SLAM AND SOLO SHOT.
SCOTT: THE OFFENSE WAS NOT THERE
EARLY IN THE YEAR FOR THE
CARDINALS.
IT IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
TOM: I'M A BIG FAN OF CHAOS.
I LIKE PENNANT RACES THAT ARE
COMPLICATED.
THE CARDINALS ARE TAKING CHAOS
OUT OF THE NATIONAL LEAGUE
WILD-CARD RACE.
IT IS TOO GOOD RIGHT NOW.
SCOTT: IT IS NOT CLOSE ANYMORE.
ONLY A WEEK AND A HALF TO GO IN
THE SEASON.
3-2, LAST CALL FOR MILWAUKEE,
GAME OVER.
THE COMEBACK IS COMPLETE AND
OFFICIAL AND THE WIN STREAK
CONTINUES FOR THE CARDINALS.
AND 83RD WIN ON THE YEAR, ST.
LOUIS HAS RACKED UP 12 IN A ROW.
FROM 5-0 TO EIGHT-FIVE AND A
FINAL.
THE CARDINALS SWEEP THE BREWERS
IN FOUR GAMES IN MILWAUKEE.
THESE WILL MATCH UP FOR THREE
MORE AND ST. LOUIS TO END THE
SEASON SERIES.
WHAT A COMEBACK EFFORT WHICH
INCLUDED TWO HOME RUNS FROM PAUL
GOLDSCHMIDT.
SO MUCH MORE TO GO FOR US HERE.
WE HAVE TWO TEAMS WITH
STORYLINES ALL OVER THE PLACE.
LET'S BREAK IT DOWN.
POST GAME SHOW, NOW.
AND THE POST GAME SHOW IS
PRESENTED BY JIM BEAM.
WHERE DO WE START?
THE 12TH CONSECUTIVE WINS, 16-6
SEPTEMBER.
THEY WERE DOWN 5-0.
THEY COME BACK TO TAKE IT 8-5.
THEY TAKE THE SERIES AGAINST THE
FIRST-PLACE BREWERS.
MILWAUKEE HAD A CHANCE.
THE MILESTONE FOR ADAM
WAINWRIGHT.
MILWAUKEE HAD A CHANCE WHEN WE
OPENED UP THIS SERIES TO WRAP UP
THE DIVISION AND THE RIVALS SAID
NOT ON OUR WATCH.
NOT THE WAY WE ARE PLAYING
BASEBALL.
TOM: THIS IS THE LAST GAME OF A
FOUR GAME SERIES.
NOT SAYING THE CARDINALS WOULD
HAVE PACKED IT IN, BUT THE
INTENSITY REMAINS OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL WAY THEY PLAY
BASEBALL REMAINS.
GOOD, SOLID RELIEF WORK, THE WAY
THEY RAN THE BASES, THE AT-BATS.
GOT IT BACK IN A HURRY.
BUT I JUST LOVE THE WAY THIS
TEAM RESPONDED TO BEING DOWN 5-0
TO A REALLY GOOD MILWAUKEE TEAM
ON THE ROAD.
EVERYTHING IN PLACE TO SAY THAT
GAME WAS OVER.
CARDINALS RIGHT NOW ARE
LITERALLY UNBEATABLE AND THEY
ARE RELENTLESS.
SCOTT: 12 WINS IN A ROW.
WHEN IT WAS 5-5, PAUL
GOLDSCHMIDT SHOWED OFF HIS
MUSCLES.
TWO HOME RUNS TODAY, TWO RUNS IN
THE SEVENTH AND ONE MORE IN THE
NINTH.
HE IS YOUR YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE
GAME.
FINAL TROPHY OF THE YEAR.
HE'S GOT HARDWARE.
ON THE TROPHY CASE, WHAT A
PERFORMANCE.
HE WENT REPEAT FIVE.
TWO MORE HOME RUNS.
29 THE SEASON.
AND GOLDY WINS THIS ONE BY A
LANDSLIDE.
THIS WAS EASY.
90% OF YOU SAY THIS MAN.
AND TALK TO HIM ON THE POSTGAME
SHOW.
SCOTT BRAUN AND TOM VERDUCCI.
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE W, THE
COMEBACK WIN, THE YOUTUBE
TROPHY.
YOU ARE A STRONG DUDE, BUT THERE
IS SOME WEIGHT ON THAT >>.
IT IS HEAVIER THAN I THOUGHT.
SCOTT: BICEP CURLS.
TAKE US THROUGH YOUR AT-BATS.
WHAT'D YOU SEE?
>> THAT AT-BAT IN THE SEVENTH
WAS A BIG ONE.
I WAS JUST TRYING TO GET ON BASE
AND PASS THE BUCK TO O'NEILL
BEHIND ME AND WAS ABLE TO GET A
FASTBALL UP TO GET OUT OF HERE.
>> TAKE ME A LITTLE DEEPER.
TO ME IT SEEMS LIKE YOU NEVER
GET OFF THE FASTBALL, YOU ARE
ALWAYS ON TIME.
TELL ME ABOUT YOUR APPROACH THEN
AND OVERALL.
>> WHEN YOU HAVE TWO STRIKES,
YOU CAN'T BE GUESSING.
I JUST CHOKED UP AND TRIED TO
STAY SHORT TO THE BALL.
BOXBERGER HAS A GOOD FASTBALL.
JUST TRY TO GET ON TOP OF IT A
LITTLE BIT.
JUST TRY AND PUT THE BALL IN
PLAY AND HOPEFULLY SOMETHING
HAPPENS.
WAS ABLE TO HIT A MISTAKE.
SCOTT: WHAT HAS BEEN THE MOST
IMPORTANT -- IMPRESSIVE PART OF
THIS WINNING STREAK?
>> A LOT OF GUYS, O'NEILL HAS
HAD BIG HOMERS.
EVEN JUST SOME WALKS, TO GET
GUYS ON BASE.
THE OTHER DAY, SOME STOLEN BASES
WERE REALLY BIG.
WE JUST WIN IN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS, THE BULLPEN AND
STARTERS HAVE DONE A GREAT JOB.
JUST BEEN ON A GREAT STREAK.
TOM: WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
NUMBERS IN THIS YARD.
IS THERE SOMETHING ABOUT THIS
PLACE AS A HITTER, SOMETHING YOU
REALLY LIKE THAT SETS UP WELL
FOR YOU?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
FIRST COUPLE GAMES, I WAS 0-8.
WHO KNOWS WHAT WILL HAPPEN?
WHAT I HAD A GOOD DAY YESTERDAY
AND TODAY.
WHO KNOWS?
I DON'T PUT TOO MUCH STOCK IN
IT, I TAKE IT ONE DAY AT A TIME.
I TRY TO HAVE GOOD AT-BATS AND
LET THE RESULTS DO WHAT THEY DO.
SCOTT: THIS TEAM HAS LOOKED
DIFFERENT IN THE MONTH OF
SEPTEMBER, NO SECRET.
THERE ARE QUITE A FEW PLAYERS IN
THE MIX.
JON LESTER IS EDITED THIS TEAM
AND SO WAS J.A. HAPP.
LUIS GARCIA, T.J. MCFARLAND.
IS THAT A HUGE PART OF THE
DIFFERENCE FOR ST. LOUIS?
OTHERWISE, THERE HAS BEEN THIS
CORE GROUP AND WE DIDN'T SEE IT
IN THE FIRST HALF OF THE SEASON.
THIS TEAM LOOKS LIKE A PLAYOFF
BASEBALL TEAM IN THE SECOND
HALF.
IT'S THE BIGGEST REASON?
>> YOU HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD.
I THINK HAVING GUYS LIKE JON
LESTER AND J.A. HAPP HAS
SOLIDIFIED THE ROTATION.
EVERYONE HAS CONFIDENCE WHEN
THEY HAVE BEEN ON THE MOUND.
THE GUYS IN THE BULLPEN LIKE
MCFARLAND, I'M SURE I'M
FORGETTING SOMEWHERE ELSE.
THE GUYS THAT HAVE BEEN HERE ALL
YEAR CONTINUING TO DO A GOOD
JOB.
SCOTT: IS THIS THE BEST DEFENSE
YOU'VE EVER BEEN A PART OF?
THE NUMBERS SAY IT AND THE EYE
TEST SAYS IT FROM WHAT WE SEE.
I WILL GET YOU ONE MORE FOR THE
KIDS ON YOUTUBE.
>> I DON'T REALLY LIKE TO MAKE
COMPARISONS.
WE HAD ONE YEAR IN ARIZONA WHERE
WE LED THE LEAGUE IN DEFENSE.
LAST COUPLE YEARS, WE WERE
PRETTY GOOD HERE AS WELL.
IT'S DEFINITELY A BIG PART OF
THE GAME.
GREAT PLAYS ALL THE WAY AROUND.
SCOTT: MANY YOUNGSTERS LEARN THE
GAME BY WATCHING THEIR FAVORITE
PLAYERS ON YOUTUBE THESE DAYS
AND LOOKING AT CLIPS.
I WOULD SAY TO A YOUNG FIRST
BASEMAN, WATCH PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT
AND WHAT HE DOES WITH HIS PICKS,
HIS RANGE.
THE WHOLE DEAL.
THAT'S TALK ABOUT THE DEFENSE.
IF YOU COULD GIVE A TIP TO THE
LITTLE ONES OUT THERE, WHAT
WOULD IT BE ON HOW TO IMPROVE
YOUR GAME AT FIRST BASE, A
POSITION THAT SOMETIMES IS
OVERLOOKED BUT IS CRUCIAL TO THE
INFIELD DEFENSE?
>> IT SOUNDS SIMPLE, BUT JUST
GET OUT THERE AND PRACTICE.
A LOT OF TIMES DEFENSE GETS
OVERLOOKED.
COMING UP IN THE MINOR LEAGUES,
I THOUGHT, I HAVE TO HIT.
WHEN I MADE IT THE FOCUS AND
SAID, THEY WON'T CALL ME UP IF I
DON'T PLAY GOOD D.
I HAD TO START PRACTICING IN THE
OFF-SEASON AND SPRING TRAINING.
I SAW MYSELF IMPROVE A LOT.
SAME THING NOW, WE ARE OUT THERE
WORKING ON PIX, GROUND BALLS,
THROWING TO BASES.
THE BIG THING IS DON'T OVERLOOK
IT BECAUSE IT'S A BIG PART OF
THE GAME.
OFFENSE WILL GO UP AND DOWN AND
YOU WILL HAVE YOUR STRUGGLES,
BUT IF YOU ARE GOOD AT DEFENSE,
YOU WILL HELP YOUR TENANT --
YOUR TEAM.
SCOTT: REPS, KIDS.
IT SHOWS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THIS IS THE LAST YOUTUBE GAME OF
THE SEASON.
CAN YOU HOLD IT UP?
THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS TO THE ST. LOUIS
CARDINALS FOR THE W, 12 IN A
ROW.
HOOK US UP WITH THE LONG BALL
SPIRIT AND THE AUDIO AS WELL.
TOM: THE SOUND WAS SPECTACULAR.
AND FOR THE KIDS AT HOME, LISTEN
TO WHAT HE SAID.
ON THE HOME RUN AGAINST
BOXBERGER, HE CHOKED UP ON THE
BAT AND SHORTENED UP AND HIT THE
BALL A MILE AND A HALF.
LET THAT BE A LESSON.
SCOTT: PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT IS A
SMART MAN.
HE'S A CARDINAL.
HE FITS IN SO WELL TO THIS
ORGANIZATION.
HE'S HAVING A NICE LITTLE 12
GAME OR.
.378, 5, 11 BROUGHT IN, SCORED
19 TIMES AND SCORED TWICE TODAY.
HE SCORED SIX TIMES IN THE LAST
48 HOURS.
THE O.P.S. IS NICE.
NOW A TROPHY.
HE HOPES FOR ANOTHER TROPHY.
THE CARDINALS WILL BE IN THAT
OCTOBER DANCE.
THEY SUPER SWEEP THE BREWERS.
WE WILL GET INTO THE MILWAUKEE
CONVERSATION.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE FOR MORE
TIME HERE ON THE POST SHOW,
COMING UP.
>>>> SWING AND A SOFT LINER.
A RUN IS GOING TO SCORE AND THE
BREWERS HAVE THE LEAD.
>> HE'S A VERY GOOD BASEBALL
ANNOUNCER.
IF YOU LISTEN TO BOB FOR FIVE OR
SIX MINUTES, YOU WANT THEM TO
SAY SOMETHING THAT WILL MAKE YOU
LAUGH.
>> DEFENSIVE INDIFFERENCE.
AS WE CALL IT AND SCORE IT, WHO
CARES?
>> BOB HAS HAD THIS WONDERFUL
ABILITY TO GIVE YOU THE GAME,
AND THEN BANG.
>> THAT'S WERE MAJOR LEAGUE
STREAMING IS GOING.
I HAVEN'T SEEN IT.
THAT THING WAS SO BAD, IT WAS ON
AIRPLANES THE DAY WE FINISHED.
>> HE'S VERY FUNNY ON THE AIR
BUT HE IS AN EXCEPTIONALLY GOOD
BROADCASTER.
>> HERE IS THE THROW, AND HE IS
IN.
>> YOU REALLY FEEL THE GAME
THROUGH HIM.
WELL CERTAINLY HE'S A BREWER
BROADCASTER, SO IN THAT SENSE HE
IS A HOMER, HE IS NOT A MINDLESS
HOMER.
HE WILL GIVE YOU A FAIR CALL.
>> AROUND THIRD, AND THE BREWERS
WHEN.
-- WIN.
SCOTT: LOADS UP THE BASES.
IT'S UP TO TYRONE TAYLOR.
EXACTLY TWO MONTHS AGO AGAINST
THE WHITE SOX.
>> DEEP LEFT CENTER.
AND FORGET ABOUT IT.
TYRONE TAYLOR MUSCLES UP.
THAT IS HIS SECOND GRAND SLAM OF
THE SEASON.
THE BREWERS HANG FOUR ON
WAINWRIGHT IN THE FIRST.
>> WHAT A MOMENT FOR TYRONE
TAYLOR.
1990 NINE CAREER STRIKEOUTS.
MANY ARE ON THE EDGE OF THEIR
SEATS WAITING FOR THE 2000.
AND WELCOME TO THE CLUB.
2000 CAREER STRIKEOUTS FOR ADAM
WAINWRIGHT.
HE HAS A SEAT NEXT TO BOB GIBSON
IS THE ONLY TWO PITCHERS IN
CARDINALS HISTORY TO PUNCH OUT
2000.
>> FITTINGLY, IT WAS UNCLE
CHARLIE, THE CURVEBALL FOR
CAREER STRIKEOUT NUMBER 2000.
>>>> FIRST K OF THE DAY FOR
WAINWRIGHT HITS A MAJOR
MILESTONE.
THE NINTH PLAYER TO REACH 2000
STRIKEOUTS WITH ONLY A SINGLE
FRANCHISE.
NOW THE MATCHUP WITH TAYLOR.
TAYLOR GETS ANOTHER GOOD RIP.
WOW, TYRONE TAYLOR HAS ANOTHER.
WHAT A DAY.
IS THERE A HOME RUN CYCLE?
HE HAS A GRAND SLAM AND A SOLO
SHOT IN HIS FIRST TWO A.B.'S.
TYRONE TAYLOR WITH HIS SECOND
CAREER MULTI-HOMER GAME, THE
BREWERS LOVE HIM AS A LOSING
STREAK STOP HER, POTENTIALLY IF
YOU CAN KEEP THINGS ROLLING.
CARLSON GETS A HOLD OF ONE INTO
RIGHT FIELD AND THAT IS A FAIR
BALL AND HE'S HEADING FOR TWO.
NOW HEADING FOR THREE, DYLAN
CARLSON ON THE RUN.
HE'S IN FURTHER ONE OUT TRIPLE.
>> THAT IS CLASSIC YADI.
>> LOVES TO DO THAT IN THE
R.B.I. SPOT AND HE LOVES TO DO
IT.
CARDINALS ON THE BOARD.
THE CARDINALS LOAD UP THE BASES.
BACK TO THE TOP OF THE ORDER.
>> POPPED HIM UP.
CARDINALS STRAND THE BASES
LOADED.
HE'S 1-3 TODAY AND O'NEILL IS
COMING UP.
RIOS MAKING A NICE STOP WITH THE
GLOVE AND THE THROW.
IT IS IN TIME.
LOOK AT RIOS.
HE HAS ERRORS BUT IT'S ON THE
ARM >> A DYLAN CARLSON HAS BEEN
THE BEST BAT TODAY FOR ST.
LOUIS.
>> YELICH, HE WILL END THE
INNING.
ANOTHER SCORELESS FRAME AND A
5-1 EDGE.
THE BASES FULL.
CARDINALS WITH ONE OUT IN THE
SEVENTH.
0-2 ALL FOR ADMIN.
CONTACT ON THE RIGHT SIDE.
THERE IS ONE AT SECOND.
BACK TO FIRST.
IT IS 5-2.
TWO ON FOR GOLDIE AND TWO OUTS.
THROW TO FIRST AND THE RUN COMES
IN.
BADER SCORES AND IT IS 5-3.
ADMIN HOPS TO SECOND AND THIS
TEAM KNOWN FOR ITS BASERUNNING
ALSO CREATES A RUN FROM THE
REPUTATION.
ONE IN AND ONE ON.
HE'S GOING TO LEFT CENTER.
PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT WALLOPS THAT
ONE.
AND WE ARE TIED.
NUMBER 28 ON THE SEASON, THEY
HAVE COME STORMING BACK.
THIS TEAM IS DANGEROUS.
PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT POWERS UP FOR
TWO.
THE CARDINALS EVEN THE SCORE AT
5-5.
BUT WAIT, THERE IS MORE.
OUR RENATO ON FIRST IN THE
EIGHTH.
DYLAN CARLSON HAS HIT NUMBER
THREE ON THE DAY.
QUIETLY A GREAT PERFORMANCE FROM
THE ROOKIE.
AND THEN, YOU DIDN'T LIKE THIS.
TOM: I LIKE THE BASERUNNING ON
HIS PART.
HE TAKES SECOND AND IT TURNED
OUT TO BE BIG.
MOVES TO THIRD ON A WILD PITCH
RIGHT HERE AND THE RUN SCORED.
BEING ON THIRD BASE WITH LESS
THAN TWO OUTS, YADI KNOWS WHAT
TO DO IN THAT SITUATION.
GOT HIM IN WITH A SACRIFICE FLY.
ALMOST GOT OUT OF THE YARD.
SCOTT: HERE COMES CARLSON.
NOW IT IS SUDDENLY 7-5 ST.
LOUIS.
WHAT A FLIP OF THE SCRIPT.
GOLDSCHMIDT IS NOT DONE.
HE WILL TELL YOU WHEN HE'S DONE.
JUST SOME MAJESTIC BLASTS.
THUNDEROUS SMACKS FROM PAUL
GOLDSCHMIDT.
IN THE PAST FEW DAYS.
BOTTOM OF THE INNING, GALLEGOS
IS THE NINTH INNING MAN THESE
DAYS.
IT'S OVER.
IT'S THE 12TH STRAIGHT WIN FOR
ST. LOUIS -- ST. LOUIS.
LONGEST WINNING STREAK FOR A
TEAM SINCE 2017 WHEN THE ARIZONA
DIAMONDBACKS WON 12 IN A ROW.
THAT WAS PAUL GOLDSCHMIDT.
HE KNOWS WHAT THIS IS LIKE.
YOUR JIM BEAM GAME SUMMARY,
GOLDIE'S 3-5, TWO HOMERS, THE
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME
TROPHY.
CARLSON WITH THREE HITS.
WAINWRIGHT WITH HIS 2000 CAREER
STRIKEOUT.
HIM AND BOB GIBSON, THE ONLY TWO
IN CARDINALS FRANCHISE HISTORY.
LET'S NOT OVERLOOK TYRONE
TAYLOR, SOLO SHOT AND A GRAND
SLAM.
LET'S GO BACK TO THE CARDINALS.
ANOTHER CONVERSATION WITH A
PLAYER POSTGAME.
BRETT: YOU THINK ABOUT THE
POSITION PLAYERS FOR THE ST.
LOUIS CARDINALS.
IT IS EASY TO FOCUS ON
GOLDSCHMIDT, NOLAN ARENADO, AND
THEY ALSO HAVE A NICE YOUNG TRIO
IN O'NEILL, ADMIN, AND CARLSON.
I ASKED WHAT IT WAS LIKE TO BE
PART OF A TEAM THAT HAS WON 12
STRAIGHT GAMES.
>> IT'S AWESOME.
A REALLY EXCITING TIME.
GUYS ARE COMING TO THE YARD
PLAYING GREAT BALL AND HAVING A
LOT OF FUN.
CLICKS YOU HAD THREE BASE HITS.
WHEN YOU GOT THE TRIPLE, IT WAS
5-1.
WHAT EPITOMIZES -- EPITOMIZES A
STREAK, YOU GUYS DON'T FEEL YOU
ARE OUT OF THE GAME.
>> NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
THAT IS THE MOTTO WE'VE HAD ALL
YEAR.
IT HAS REALLY COME TO LIFE AS OF
LATE.
LIKE YOU MENTIONED, WE FEEL LIKE
WE ARE IN EVERY GAME SO WE ARE
PLAYING HARD.
BRETT: AS THE YOUNGER PLAYER IN
THE TEAM, YOU LOOK OUT IN THE
DUGOUT, HOW EASY IS IT TO FALL
BEHIND THESE GUYS AND FOLLOW
THEIR LEAD?
>> THEY MAKE IT REALLY EASY FOR
ME.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE OUT THERE
WITH THEM AND BE ABLE TO TALK TO
THEM EACH AND EVERY SINGLE DAY.
I'M REALLY LUCKY.
THEY LEAD THE WAY AND DO A GREAT
JOB OF IT.
BRETT: FOR A GUY WHO MADE HIS
DEBUT LAST YEAR AND A JACKED UP
YOUR, WHAT IS IT LIKE TO BE IN
FRONT OF THE CROWDS AND DOWN IN
THE STRETCH FOR THE PENNANT
RACE?
>> IT'S AMAZING, ANYTHING YOU
CAN THINK OF.
THE FANS BROUGHT BRIGHT -- GREAT
ENERGY ALL YEAR AND IT'S GREAT
TO EXPERIENCE THE ATMOSPHERE
WITH THE CROWDS.
IT DID NOT GET TO DO THAT LAST
YEAR.
JUST BEING ABLE TO EXPERIENCE IT
AND FEED OFF OF IT HAS BEEN
AWESOME.
BRETT: DEATH, TAXES AND THE ST.
LOUIS CARDINALS IN THE
POSTSEASON.
A COUPLE WEEKS AGO, WE THOUGHT
MAY BE THE CARDINALS WOULD BE
VYING FOR THE SECOND WILD-CARD.
THEY ARE RUNNING AWAY FROM IT
WITH A 12 GAME WINNING STREAK.
BIG COME OUT -- COME BACK TODAY,
PART OF THE 8-5 WIN.
WE WILL COME BACK WITH MORE OF
THE YOUTUBE GAME OF THE WEEK
POSTGAME FROM AMERICAN FAMILY
FIELD IN MILWAUKEE.
CLICKS IF YOU ARE ONE OF THE
THOUSANDS WHO FOLLOW WILLY
ADAMES ON INSTAGRAM, YOU MIGHT
BE WONDERING, WHAT IS WITH THE #
?
CLICKS WHEN YOU GET TO THIS
LEVEL, THINGS CHANGE.
YOU GET A NEW CAR, A BIG HOUSE.
SOMETIMES IT GETS IN YOUR HEAD.
CLICKS LONG AGO, HE DECIDED HE
WOULD NOT LET IT GET IN HIS
HEAD.
AS A 17-YEAR-OLD IN THE
DOMINICAN SUMMER LEAGUE, HE FOR
-- FIRST POSTED NO BOOKBAG.
THAT WAS IN 2013.
IT IS A LOOSELY TRANSLATED
SPANISH PHRASE.
ADAMES SAYS IT REMINDS HIM TO
STAY HUMBLE, NEVER BOAST, AND
REMEMBER WHERE HE CAME FROM,
WHICH WAS A SMALL TOWN IN THE
DOMINICAN REPUBLIC WHERE HE HAD
LOVING PARENTS, BUT NOT MUCH
ELSE.
>> THAT'S WHAT MAKES ME
APPRECIATE THIS.
GOD GAVE ME THIS OPPORTUNITY AND
I HAVE TO GIVE IT TO OTHERS.
>> WILLY ADAMES LOVES LIFE AND
LIVES IT WITH HUMILITY AND IS
SURROUNDED BY FAMILY AND FRIENDS
WHO WOULD NOT HAVE IT ANY OTHER
WAY.
>>: THEY WOULD SMACK ME ON MY
FACE PROBABLY.
>> THIS IS OUR FOURTH YOUTUBE
GAME.
INCREDIBLE.
I SEE THIS BALL GOING INTO THE
SECOND DECK.
>> YES!
>> OMAN.
I TOLD YOU TYRONE WOULD HIT TWO
HOMERS.
I DIDN'T SAY PIÑA, I SAID
TYRONE.
YOU ARE FOR SURE DOING THAT
AGAIN TOMORROW.
YOU HAVE TO.
WE GOT A GUY THERE.
I THINK SO.
>> THE SHOT AND IT LANDS IN THE
GLOVE.
>> WE DON'T HAVE THE GUY THERE.
>> I'M OUT.
I WIN.
>> THAT WAS NOT A FAIR RACE.
I WIN, THOUGH.
CLIQUES YOU ARE JUST WINNING ALL
YEAR, CORBIN BURNES, AND THANK
YOU FOR THE MICROPHONE --
MICROPHONE GLORY.
WE ALSO SHOUT OUT THE CURIOUS
CREATORS SPENDING TIME IN THE
LIVE GAME COMMENTARY.
THE PLAYOFFS ARE ALMOST HERE.
YES.
ONE MORE, AUSTIN SAYS, GREAT
GAME OF THE WEEK FINAL, THANK
YOU MLB, AND YOUTUBE FOR A
FANTASTIC SEASON, SO MUCH FUN.
CAN'T WAIT FOR THE FUTURE.
I KNOW YOU LOVE THE MICROPHONE
CONTENT AND WE HAD ALL YEAR
LONG.
CORBIN BURNES FINISHING UP WITH
A GRAND SLAM PREDICTION THAT
PLAYS OUT.
THAT'S PERFECT BECAUSE WHEN YOU
TALK TO HIS FANS AFTER THE GAME,
HE SAYS I CALLED IT.
TOM: HE ALSO CALLED THE SAUSAGE
RACE.
STAY HOT, CORBIN BURNES.
MILWAUKEE WISHES THEY WERE AS
HOT.
THEY HAD THE GAME 5-0.
I HAVE TO GIVE MORE CREDIT FOR
THE CARDINALS AND THE WAY THEY
CAME BACK AND TOOK ADVANTAGE OF
ANY LITTLE MISTAKE, SOME WALKS
LEAD TO BIG HOME RUNS LATE AND
THEY CASHED IN.
SCOTT: FIVE AND A ROW LOSSES FOR
THE BREWERS.
WE DID NOT SEE DEVIN WILLIAMS.
HE WAS IN THE DUGOUT.
HE HAS NOT PITCHED MUCH THIS
TIME.
HE WOKE UP, WASN'T FEELING
GREAT, I BELIEVE IT WAS, I DON'T
WANT TO MISIDENTIFY, BUT
SOMETHING ARM OR SHOULDER
RELATED.
HE DID NOT PITCHED IN GAMES LAST
YEAR.
TOM: I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON BUT HE HAD FIVE DAYS OF REST,
PITCHED LESS THAN FOUR INNINGS
THIS MONTH, SO HE HAS NOT HAD A
BIG WORKLOAD THIS MONTH BUT WE
SAW HIM IN THE DUGOUT LATE IN
THE GAME.
NOT IN THE BULLPEN.
HE DID NOT SEEM TO BE AN OPTION.
SCOTT: I DID GET WORD.
GO AHEAD, TELL ME.
DEVIN WILLIAMS INJURED A CALF
MUSCLE RUNNING IN THE OUTFIELD A
COUPLE DAYS AGO.
THEY ARE HOPEFUL IT IS NOT AN IL
SITUATION.
OK, SO IT COULD BE WORSE.
CALVES ARE TRICKY BUT IT IS NOT
AN ARM OR SHOULDER.
TOM: THEY STILL HAVE THE
DIVISION.
NO REASON TO PUSH ANYTHING.
GOING FORWARD, THEY BETTER MAKE
SURE THAT CALF IS NOT A
LONG-TERM ISSUE.
THAT IS PART OF A WINNING
STRATEGY FOR AT THE END OF GAMES
FOR MILWAUKEE.
WE TALK ABOUT WILLIAMS AND
HAIDER.
SCOTT: LOOK AT THE WHIFF RATE IN
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
HAIDER HE ON THE LIST, WILLIAMS
ON THE LIST, SO IT'S A FINAL 8-5
ST. LOUIS, GRABBING ANOTHER WIN,
12 IN A ROW.
WE'VE BEEN WINNING EVERY WEEK
BECAUSE WE HAD THE MICROPHONE
PLAYERS.
NOW LET'S BRING IT ALL TOGETHER
AND SEND YOU THIS.
>> I AM MIKE TO UP.
IF YOU WANT TO SAY HIGH TO
YOUTUBE, STAY HIGH.
>> HELLO, YOUTUBE.
>> HOT MIKE WALKING THROUGH.
>> BEAUTIFUL DAY FOR PLAYING
BASEBALL HERE IN ARIZONA.
>> I HAVE THE HOT MIC ON.
>> WHAT IS UP?
>> I HAVE THE MIC.
I HAVE THE MIC ON.
>> MIGHT NEED A TRANSLATOR ON
THIS THING.
THE WORDS ACROSS THE BOTTOM OF
THE SCREEN.
>> NO ENGLISH FOR ME TODAY, MAN.
MENO SPEAK ENGLISH.
>> [SPEAKING SPANISH" >> FOR THE
GRAM.
DO IT FOR THE KIDS.
>> PUTS IT IN FOR THREE.
>> SERIOUSLY MIGHT BE THE WORST
BASE RUNNER IN THE LEAGUE.
>> WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
WE SHOULD SCORE.
>> WHAT WOULD YOU BE DOING IF
YOU DIDN'T PLAY BASEBALL?
>> I WOULD PROBABLY BE A GOLFER.
>> DIDN'T YOU HOMER LIKE TWO
DAYS AGO?
YOU GOT POP, I RUN INTO BALLS.
>> [SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> THAT COULD HAVE BEEN BAD
RIGHT THERE.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS A SLIDER,
DUDE.
I CAN'T PICK UP THE BALL HERE AT
ALL.
>> I WAITING FOR IT TO BREAK.
IF I DIDN'T HAVE THAT PAD RIGHT
THERE.
>> [SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> THE BEST BEAUTIFUL GUY ON THE
TEAM RIGHT THERE.
>> WHAT A LIFE.
FOURTH INNING AND YOU JUST
STROLL OUT.
>> I WILL PUT IT IN MY GLOVE
LIKE THAT FOR A CURVEBALL,
SLIDER, OR A HEATER.
IF I THROW A CHANGEUP, I WILL
SOMEHOW GET TO IT BUT I DON'T DO
THAT.
>> THAT'S GOING PROBABLY LIKE TO
27 OTHER PARKS.
TELL YOU WHERE IT AIN'T GOING,
HERE IN DETROIT.
>> TELL YOU WHAT.
A LOT OF DUDES OUT HERE WITH
THEIR SHIRTS OFF.
KIND OF WEIRD.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT: CAN WE RUN THAT ON
REPEAT?
THAT IS SO GOOD.
THAT'S WAS GOING ON EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
TOM: YOU SEE THE PERSONALITIES
COME TO LIFE.
SCOTT: IT IS GREAT.
SCOTT:AND THEN THE POSTSEASON IS
COMING ALIVE.
WE ARE ABOUT A WEEK AND A HALF
AWAY FROM GETTING IT FIRED UP.
THESE ARE THE SCENARIOS AT THE
MOMENT.
FOR THE BREWERS AND CARDINALS
FANS THAT WERE WITH US TODAY, IT
LOOKS LIKE BRAVES AND BREWERS,
IT LOOKS LIKE CARDINALS AND
DODGERS FOR THE WILD-CARD.
STILL TO BE DECIDED IN THE N.L.
WEST.
THE DODGERS DON'T STOP WINNING.
BUT THE GIANTS JUST HAVE HAD NO
QUIT.
THESE ARE LOOKING LIKE 100 PLUS
WIN SEASONS.
WHEN WE GET TO THE END OF THE
REGULAR YEAR, ONE OF THEM WILL
HAVE TO TAKE ON A TEAM WE JUST
WATCHED TODAY THAT LOOKS REALLY
GOOD.
TOM: HOW ABOUT IF YOU WIN 103
GAMES AND THEN YOU HAVE TO PUT
EVERYTHING ON THE LINE OF ONE
GAME AGAINST WHAT IS NOW THE
HOTTEST TEAM IN BASEBALL, THE
ST. LOUIS CARDINALS?
THERE'S A BIG PRIZE IN THAT
NATIONAL LEAGUE WEST.
IT IS STAYING OUT OF THE
WILD-CARD GAME.
SCOTT: THAT'S WHY THE LAST WEEK
AND A HALF FOR THOSE TEAMS FEELS
LIKE THE POSTSEASON.
THEY KNOW THEY NEED TO TAKE
EVERY GAME RIGHT NOW.
OTHERWISE, YOU CHECK OUT THE
HIGHLIGHTS, YOU SEE A SCARY ST.
LOUIS TEAM.
THERE ARE SUDDENLY NOT MANY
FLAWS.
THEY WILL BE A FORCE.
THE BREWERS LOSE HERE, BUT THAT
SHOULD BE IN GOOD SHAPE TO WIN
THE DIVISION.
THE MAGIC NUMBER IS THREE.
THEY SHOULD BE OK.
WHAT A DAY, WHAT A FINISH TO OUR
SCHEDULE.
I WANT TO DO SOME THANK YOU'S.
OUR LAST YOUTUBE GAME ON THE
SEASON HERE.
WE'VE HAD WALKOFFS AND COME BACK
THIS.
WE'VE HAD SOME OF THE BEST IN
BASEBALL AND TERMS OF TEAMS AND
INDIVIDUAL PLAYERS.
I WANT TO GIVE A SPECIAL SHOUT
OUT TO SOME OF THE CREW BEHIND
THE SCENE.
I WILL START WITH JORDAN, OUR
TAPE OPERATOR.
PUTS UP
[CAPTIONING PERFORMED BY THE
NATIONAL CAPTIONING INSTITUTE,
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
CAPTION CONTENT AND ACCURACY.
VISIT NCICAP.ORG]